Dude, the people the people in my Discord are just ill. Why do
you Why would you do this? Why would you Why is this required?
What part of this was required in any way? This is just mean.
Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad. Dude,
the smelly Jean guy just got a trillion. Hassan is bad. Hassan
is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad.
Hassan is bad. Bad bad bad.
Had is bad. >> I don't want to I don't want to go over
the same thing again, but he did call it
A a douche.
Oh, douche. Somebody just said I was being a douche. >> Everybody
seemingly associated with Destiny is poison. I don't like any
of the orbiters. I don't know the new ones super well, but any
of the majority of the former ones. I think the only exception
is Turkey Tom. And Turkey Tom was Turkey Tom before he was hanging
>> Oh, my ears are burning. Boy, >> I don't really
like any of the Alogs.
>> Okay, I might just have to go. We ride along. Do we
want to just watch a little bit of the Nick stream? Where does
he start here? Let's see where he starts. So, let's see how this
goes. Okay, I want to see what Nick says. Let's check it out.
Okay, this is going on right >> On stuff and uh they're
probably not going to be happy with my responses to those opinions,
but hopefully I could do a good job of explaining myself in a
in a actively I don't know. I don't know. I'm going to tell you
how it is. And if you don't like it, I'm extremely sorry to tell
you, but that's how it is. Let's take a look at this clip. This
is the uh this is our palette cleanser before we get into the
super serious, extremely sad, scary news of the Hassan clip.
I did see that ye posted a clip from our previous live stream
and it was us shouting out Shawn the Black for making a a hit
tweet you know like the uh the picture was it what is the picture
like oh I got a hit tweet is that like the the Harry Potter girl
um
Emma Watson's car Hermione Granger I got a hit tweet she wanted
black hit tweet
quality quiet is for valid reasons this is the into an uproar
>> nothing okay >> I don't even remember what the
>> we're here finally I usually so it's like audible All
right, guys. This is the clip that turned the entire community
into an uproar. And I think a percentage of it is for valid reasons.
This is the clip that most people reacted to. If anything, they
heard an even shorter version of this. Where's the Dan Saltman
cut? That's the one that I really want to listen to because that
Oh, that's not good. Okay, that's not >> One is like 30
seconds long and he said it was upscaled. Was that mean it was
like AI upscale? They went to like obscene lengths to get this
clip as short as possible. Um, let me see this. Where's the Dan
Saltman Hut? Is this
Oh, no. This is not it either. What is Dan's current Twitter?
>> Dan tweet sounds like psychotic. >> DBL is his
personal account. >> I follow him. Why am I not seeing
Oh, cuz I'm on my [__] That's why. Uh, cuz I'm going
to need the alt tonight.
I got to be honest with you. I'm going to need the alt tonight.
Daniel,
I didn't. >> Sorry, but we're uh we're watching for the
redemption of Nicholas Dioro. Okay. I believe we're going to
see the redemption of Nicholas Yorio tonight. >> grab this
before the stream. >> I believe I fully believe. >> Here's
the high quality edit of Assan wishing for Heila's death. Please
do not use the scuffed version. We will use the Dan Saltman version.
This one is the 30 secondond hyper cut. and every
every type of arm >> edited this down to 30 seconds and
let him clear his I think it's part of it is because Assan [__]
is like all dead air but like this is a hyper cut and he immediately
and every every type of armed resistance against both the settlers
and also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank doesn't
matter if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids the violence that the Palestinians engage in in
an act of resistance >> by the Hey, uh, we can do this
argument. I don't know if I have to I don't know if I should
do it before or after cuz I made a prediction on what Hassan
was saying based on just the stuff that's in that one segment.
But if I told you guys, okay, the whole innocence thing, the
whole like, oh, the appearance of innocence thing was his point.
And people say that's what if I tell you he made that point before
that as well, like his entire point was, hey, I know you're trained
in your stupid fascist brain to think that the guys in uniforms
are the good guys, but that's not the case. He was doing it the
whole time he was watching. And yes, Hila is his example of the
most innocent, the most like, oh, you would be on her side. No,
even Ela. >> That is what he's actually doing here. Legal
occupying force is literally legal. Definitionally legal. Okay,
it's just the truth. >> Okay, this clip is insane. It is
a it is a legitimately crazy clip.
That being said, with this context, if this is the only thing
you hear, there are people who think that Hassan is not inching
towards not dog whistling. They think that he is literally saying
that you could go and
>> I don't even think he's dog whistling here. To tell
you the truth, I don't think he's dog whistling. I don't think
that's there. I think this is uh I think it's very obvious that's
not what's going on. >> That's that's not what the clip
is. I I hate to be the bearer of bad news. That being said, I
think that this is a clip of Hassan [__] being completely
brain broken by the constant feud with Ethan Klein to the point
where he throws something in that legitimately doesn't fit with
the argument that he's making in the video. In this clip, >> totally
fits with the argument he's >> I'll play it again. Everything
he's saying sounds
intense, like things that are currently able to happen
in Gaza. And then he throws in like >> even your favorite
podcaster's wife, >> which is entirely in past tense >> and
every every type of armed resistance against both the settlers
and also the Israeli >> This will help also help catch
anybody up who hasn't caught this yet. Okay, we'll watch. >> Force
in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters
like uh wife that part. >> Uh why bring her up? Because
it's a relevant example that he could talk to Ethan Klein with,
right? He's [__] with Ethan here 100%.
But it is a relevant example. It is a relevant topical example.
participate in >> It's all in present tense except for
participated which is in past tense. >> The violence that
the Palestinians engage in in an act of resistance against this
illegal occupying force is literally legal. Definitionally legal.
>> That being said, if you go listen to the actual clip
from the actual stream, you will get exactly what the clip actually
>> So this is the problem. Evil Johnny Bravo is Hassan
should probably be allowed to just talk directly to Ethan Klein
or Hila Klein, right? Do we disagree on that? We can't disagree
on that. He should be able to talk to them directly, right?
He should be able to say like weird crazy [__] about
them. I think Ethan was calling Hassan a sex addict on the stream
four days ago, 5 days ago. No, he just shouldn't be allowed to
talk about either of them. Or should he only be allowed to talk
about Ethan? It's not his dick. Uh Hila has commented, right?
Hila's commented on Hassan a couple times. I would say that if
Hila decided, okay, I would say if Hila decided at some point
she was like, I'm opting out of this and she just totally went
away. I would argue that you should go and you should leave her
alone. You shouldn't be going after her, right? But if Ela's
been participating, then I I think that's like a I think he could
talk back, right? Especially when it's like relevant. That would
be that would be how I'd look at it. And once we know what the
clip actually is, we can then move on to criticize it because
that is like a fundamental piece here that is extremely important.
We need to criticize what Hassan [__] actually says.
All right, so I think it's pretty obvious that Hassan [__]
mentioning Hila Klein in current day while describing a valid
military target is absolutely reckless and stupid. That being
said, there is additional context here that needs to be shown
to provide what he's actually trying to say in his argument.
Uh cuz I noticed the clip starts pretty late and this is probably
>> current political leadership in Israel does not want
a Palestinian state and the Israeli parliament just approved
a motion to annex the West Bank. Like any kind of >> Okay,
smart smart
settlers or the the Israeli military experiences in the West
Bank is literally legal. Okay, it is legal resistance against
>> Has Hassan played this fence Ela animation on stream?
Uh possibly. I'm actually not sure. I actually don't know if
he's played that animation, but my argument would be along the
sides the the the
I guess along the axis of like, oh, he's um
what would you say? Some people argue, oh, he's like uh he's
priming his audience. He's like radicalizing his audience. It's
like, dude, no. I'd say his entire audience is like already far
more radical than he is on the H3 or Hila questions, right? I
don't know if he's played it himself, but like everybody's aware
of it. Yeah. >> Then occupying military force. I cannot
>> like in this context he is absolutely talking about
people who are currently occupying the West Bank. People who
are actively invading the West Bank, not people who live in California.
>> I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying force experiences
in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally legal and totally
moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't matter if they're
the Alaka Brigade. Doesn't matter if they're a part of the Palestinian
Islamic Jihad. doesn't matter. >> Like everything that
he is saying in this entirety of this clip is talking about people
who are actively inside of Gaza. Now, that's not endorsing or
criticizing like this is literally just fundamentally understanding
what we're dealing with here, right? Hila Klein is not actively
occupying Gaza territory. That would not make her in his eyes
an active target in current day if they're DFlP, PFP, or even
former FAT militants. Okay? It is perfectly legal, perfectly
valid, and perfectly moral. Okay. 100%. This is not like a black
and this is just asking if you think he is aware the reaction
will happen at all when he says this. What reaction? Oh, you
think like he's baiting? No, I don't think so. I I don't think
so. And I think that's like proven out because it is like a reasonable
example and it is something that took four or five days for people
to even clip, right? Like nobody actually thought that this was
a problem. As far as I can tell,
nobody thought this was a problem when it was said, right? It
just sort of came and went and they're definitely hate watchers
who were watching. This >> is not a gray area. This is
black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and white than
this is >> like he is specifically saying that it would
be legal to do what he is saying. It would not be legal for a
stray missile to hit California.
It would not be legal to go somebody in the United
>> Israel is in the wrong. Israel, >> he's wrong,
by the way. We'll get there. But I need I need people to understand.
But that that's irrelevant to the clip. I I just I said this
right when it came out. I assume Hassan's wrong about international
law. I assume he has no idea what he's talking about, right?
I think that's pretty obvious. >> Before we progress through
this like >> I think he threw bait out for Ethan to crash
out. Yeah. Well, Ethan is Ethan is incredibly crash. Okay. Do
we have to watch the red bar segment on Ethan Klein? Ethan Klein
is like incredibly
like unfortunately neurotic is just the word, right? Neurotic
is just the word. He is incredibly neurotic.
Incredibly
>> Right now, this is not Hassan [__] making
the argument that the UN would just be okay with assassinating
a YouTuber's wife. Okay, once we can all agree on that, we can
move forward.
>> Is actually engaging in an apartheid, which is a crime.
>> Okay, but he platforms people. I understand. I understand
the issue. That's a good point. Yes, people like Ban Panata have
literally argued that. But like that's a good argument. lying
about what Hassan [__] says in this clip is a bad
one. >> In of itself, Israel is doing a genocide in Gaza
and aparttheite in the West Bank. Two crimes in and of itself.
And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your >> Pretty sure it knows more about international
law than you. Yeah, but I don't make claims about international
law. I try not to at least.
>> Yeah. Podcasters like uh wife that participate in these
raids. The violence that the Palestinians engage in in an act
of resistance against this illegal occupying force is literally
legal. Definitionally legal. Okay? It's just the truth straight
up. It doesn't matter that they look to be in garb that makes
you think that they're in the right. >> And the garb is
not like Teddy Fresh merchandise. Now, now that we've established
the terms of what we're talking about, I think it's absolutely
outrageous to mention Hila Klein in the context of killing people
who are actively
um actively inside of the Gaza Strip, actively either perpetuating
the genocide or occupying space that isn't theirs. I think that
he is so brainbroken by the constant fighting with Ethan Klein
that even in a even in like an argument that he's facing while
watching a video trying to describe a current day situation,
the only thing he can think of is the Klein's. Um I think it's
reckless to do that. I think that people can take that the wrong
way. My evidence for that is the fact that this statement came
out and everyone assumed it was about today and a bunch of people
on Twitter are >> Dude, the people the people in my Discord
are just ill. Why do you Why would you do this? Why this so [__]
up? Why would you Why is this required? What part of this was
required in any way? This just mean
up, dude. Justifying it because of of her ride along that she
did uh like some 20 years ago, right? Like even if the
Just sounds like Hassan is just sounds like Hassan is just being
a dick and confrontational by occasionally saying his enemy's
wife who used to be his friend would have been justified to be
killed 10,000 years ago or sorry 10 years ago. I think it's like
20 years ago actually. Luawi. Yeah, he's like sorry. He is doing
both. It fits with his point. He is trying to say to his chat
repeatedly over like an hour, hey guys, I know you're trained
to think that the guys in uniforms are the good guys. No. Hey,
I know you're trained to think that these guys who look like
slobs who look like [__] terrorists that they're
bad. No. Okay. No. No matter what, they're in the right here.
And he highlights it multiple times going through the the whole
segment. >> Isn't explicitly that Gila Klein is is an active
target in current day. That clip went around and that's what
people thought it was and then people spent an entire day justifying
it. So my position that things are getting scary in this community,
it's 100% accurate. My position that I think uh people should
send support to Hila during this, I still stand by it. I think
that's a really good thing to do because
I think this is probably fine. I criticized Nick for this. I
think this is probably fine in retrospect. I think I criticized
him and I said I feel like you should take it down. I feel like
you should have taken down that Willie retweet if he wasn't going
to watch it. Personally, when he's when people are saying, "Hey,
this guy's slandering people." I think you should have gone like,
"Oh, yeah. I I'm going to retweet that." But I I understand he
feels pressured by people and well, we didn't do the bingo thing
here. I just wanted to catch up on this to be honest with you.
See what he was going to say. Did he not say even if they're
former Fata militants, wouldn't it stand a reason that he's applying
the same logic to both sides that is a current or former militant?
No, it wouldn't stand a reason at all. Nolan Void wouldn't even
stand a reason a little bit because he's talking about the people
doing the resistance. So he's saying even if they're former fat
militants, they can still resist. Wait, do you know who do you
know what fat is? Nolan void.
You do. Okay. You're saying combatants on both sides. Uh, I do
not believe there's any reason to think he he like it applies
forwards and backwards. He's saying no matter how bad the person,
right? Like, hey, even if they're a former fatal militant who
like held hostages on an airplane or some [__] they
should they're still valid. They're still valid in resisting
in the West Bank, in the occupied West Bank. West Bank, especially
in area A, right, where the PA is supposed to have authority
over all security operations.
I think that is where where Mala is in that specific place. That
that like what are we doing? How is Israel doing this >> I
think that this is legitimately getting to the point where it's
it's accelerating so much I wouldn't be surprised if things start
to get a little bit worse before they get better. Uh we we've
been seeing skulls sent to people's houses. It's an allout doc
war right now. Um and people are not like >> It's not an
allout doc war at all. It's not an allout doc war violent on
social media uh associated with this entire situation. So that's
my opinion on it. But to get to that opinion, I have to tell
you the actual context of the clip before we move forward. And
now we've done that so we can engage with it. This is the clip
as it was posted the 42nd >> matter of their DFLP >> and
I don't think this clip does a good enough job establishing that
we're in the context of in his opinion in the context of people
who are actively perpetuating this >> Nick did a great
job here overall I think Nick did a very good job like probably
even better than I suspected right in my opinion I will say the
skulls reference okay at what point are you 5 months past the
skulls being sent and it's like okay we're not in the environment
where the skulls were sent like things had cooled off And they're
still talking, but like things have cooled off. What's up, Darius?
How's it >> Or actively inside of a a zone that is not
their land. >> Or even former fought out militants.
>> Darius, why didn't you win? Why didn't you win scavenger
hunt? You were in the final thing. What the [__]
happened? >> Okay, it is perfect, perfectly valid, and
perfectly moral.
>> Oh, many such cases. >> 100%. This is not like
a black and this is not a gray area. This is black and white.
Okay. It doesn't get more black and white than this. >> Israel
is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an apartheid,
which is a crime in of itself. Israel is doing a genocide in
Gaza and a partite in the West Bank. Two crimes in and of itself.
And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occ. >> And again, there are multiple
reasons why this clip is bad in the context of other things that
you can use. But if you're arguing that that's what he's saying,
you're wrong. You're 100% wrong. If you're arguing that he platforms
Madame Panata regularly and doesn't care that Bad Panata is a
crazy doxer who said horrible things about Hila Klein who's on
simulations her in video games uh or that he said that anyone
who's ever supported the IDF in any capacity is a Zionist right
that like shouldn't be like uh considered as a local dog catcher.
I'm going to agree with you every single every single step of
the way. If you're arguing that what he said here is inappropriate,
especially for those explicit reasons that I've just listed or
any of the other ones off the top of your head, like that he
glorifies terrorism as like musical people or he has promoted
ship raids where like hostages go away for like eight months.
Like these are all like extenduating factors that absolutely
are to be like considered when you hear clips like this. And
if you think that he's dog whistling, I'm not going to tell you
you're wrong. I'm going to say I don't agree with you, but I'm
not going to say that you're wrong. But if your interpretation
is that >> Oh, that's interesting. Hold on. Nick doesn't
even believe it's a dog whistle. Did you catch that? That he
said, "I'm not going to disagree with you. I won't I I sorry.
I will disagree with you, but I'm not going to say you're wrong
if you think it's a dog whistle." That's very interesting that
he just gave away. Did you hear that?
Hold on. That's reasons that I've just listed or any of the other
ones off the top of your head like that he glorifies terrorism
as like musical people or he has promoted ship raids where like
hostages go away for like eight months. Like these are all like
extenduating factors that absolutely are to be like considered
when you hear clips like this. And if you think that he's dog
whistling, I'm not going to tell you you're wrong. I'm going
to say I don't agree with you, but I'm not going to say that
you're wrong. But if your interpretation is that he is explicitly
calling for the death of Hila Klein in current day, you are incorrect.
So this is the reaction from LSF about this clip. Bro really
had to make absolutely sure he was talking about heal here. This
is kind of my issue with the clip entirely like that she doesn't
belong in this conversation and that's why I think it's like
brain broken for real. I thought it was a title saying that she
was included in the people that he was talking about for 90%
of it. I think he's just talking [__] and I don't
know that I care that he's talking [__] or care enough
to like criticize it, right? Like it's the same talk they've
been doing for months. People have been saying Elo was in the
IDF. Elo went on a night raid for months. It's >> specifically.
No, cuz he'll be talking about something. You know what it it
is? It's very similar the way that Hassan [__] will
be talking about an issue and then he'll just latch back to Destiny.
>> It's a it's common. we've seen it for like a really
long period of time where he'll be talking about something entirely
unrelated, entirely different and then he'll be like this is
exactly like the time [__] Destiny because he really
wants to talk about it more and he can't stop himself from doing
it. I think realistically if Assan [__] just let
loose he would do an entire week of streams just about Destiny
about Ethan about Hilo but he feels like he needs to make content
so it kind of just like slips through the cracks kind of just
breaks out when it has an opportunity. Um Twitch is probably
going to donate subs to I mean the Twitch will not ban him for
this. I think we all know that. But ultimately, do you want me
to sit here and
>> I
Twitch shouldn't ban him for this. It would be insane if Twitch
did ban him for this. >> Redo the list of like times where
Twitch doesn't apply their toss equally or
>> dude. Dude, no. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Oh,
come on. There's no reason they would apply the toos to this
instance. >> No. I I don't think he's going to get >> be
real. >> Um, but I don't expect any of these people to
get banned for anything. So, at this point, I think that's kind
of just understood. >> Uh, waiting for how this one is
out of context. I think it is. I I think it pretty clearly is,
but um that doesn't make it a good clip. That doesn't make like
that doesn't make that doesn't invalidate Hila's feelings about
it. Doesn't invalidate Ethan's feelings about it. I haven't seen
his video yet. We're gonna check that out today, but it is completely
out of context. I mean, we all knew that he'd do the seal laugh
if someone attacked Hila, but it's nice saying it out loud. So,
Ethan reacted to it and he said, "If I started saying like, Hassan
is a propagandist and therefore a legal military bl." >> He
supported terrorist groups in the clip. Uh, bro, hop in the Discord
if you want to say like this. Where did he support terrorist
groups in the clip that he's saying that if a terrorist group
is engaging in defensive violence against the occupying force
that that's morally okay? That's a defense of the terrorist group,
dude. And he openly defends terrorist groups. Like that's the
sad thing. There's so many places where you could just say he
openly like defends terrorist groups. There's so many. And you
had to add it to this cont. You had to say it's in this clip.
It's like obviously not there. Come on. >> Which I do not
believe.
Everyone is going to be okay with that. This is the fourth time
a leftist Twitch streamer has explicitly called for me to heal
his >> Uh, Black Cat, hop in the court, though. We're taking
disagreements tonight.
Taking disagreements. Enter the waiting room. Enter the court.
Let's go. Nobody has been uh reprehended for this death threat
by Twitch. Not even once. For comparison on YouTube, Banana Panata
played an FPS game where you play as a soldier and murder Israelis.
He is simulating murder on Hila in the game. And I that is a
direct quote. He was like, "Can we find all of the the uh the
secretaries?" The secretaries.
Um, so he absolutely did do that and as a result he caught a
weekl long suspension. >> No Twitter space stuff. Uh,
dude, I could try to do a Twitter space. >> Do I know that
it would work? I've heard that the Twitter spaces are also Okay,
hold on. We'll we'll see. Maybe I'll I'll do it after
he knows there are repercussions for making death threats on
YouTube. Now, one thing specifically with Hila Klein and I I
saw we actually touched on this last stream and I want to address
this one specifically. Um, I don't know when it became
fair. Not not fair. Fair isn't the correct word. I don't know
when it became a the core principled issue that Heline decided
to go on a ride along and sit in the Humvey during a raid and
that was apparently the big problem that people had with this.
Am I missing something? I feel like we spent like 6 months where
people just were criticizing Helilocline for even being the secretary.
I feel like only now I guess they get like an optics check. >> No,
I What?
I think I don't think that's >> they correct me if I'm
wrong. I know we got some Hassanabi heads. some some more like
uh left
left-leaning people in the crowd. I'm pretty sure it's always
been the worst thing was going on an illegal raid, what they
call an illegal raid into Raala, right? She called a >> that
like that was eventually not going to beable
or I guess an engageable argument anymore. But I quite literally
remember the majority of people saying that she's a child murderer
explicitly because she was a secretary for the IDF and uh the
ride along wasn't even even a factor or if it was it was very
small factor because they were condemning her just on behalf
of her being a secretary to begin with. But now all of a sudden
it's like well we were never mad about that. It's like no I'm
pretty sure you were. Uh she didn't even kill anyone. Uh Ethan
claims she didn't even fire a gun outside of basic training,
which I believe if she wasn't armed during the one um Humvey
ride, I don't think they like gave her a like I don't think she
saw combat as a secretary. So I do believe that there's no reason
not to. So yeah, I don't think she killed anybody. But yeah,
so that was what Ethan Klein said if I started saying Hassan
is a propagandist and a legit military target.
Um, I I think that Hassan and Destiny are both people and they
constantly use each other being as an opportunity to deflect
from themselves being it's like a snake eating itself, you know,
only it's two different snakes. Like one one snake is eating
the tail of the other snake that's eating its tail. Yeah. Hassan,
Destiny Vosch. I mean, the entire community, everybody's seemingly
associated with Destiny's poison. I don't like any of the orbiters.
I don't know the new ones super well, but any of the majority
of the former ones. I think the only exception is Turkey Tom.
And Turkey Tom was Turkey Tom before he was hanging around. >> Oh,
my ears are burning. I don't really like any of the ALOGs.
>> I think that like Destiny has kind of poisoned commentary
discourse probably in the last couple of months. I think that
everything he touches related to Ethan Klein gets a little gross.
I I I feel like Destiny has essentially just like infiltrated
and poisoned the entire drama community in some capacity. Does
anybody else feel >> That's kind of true. That's a little
true. J is an ALOG now. I swear to God I like explicitly didn't
even pull any of this guy's tweets around this to cover, but
it doesn't matter. Reality doesn't matter. People just say it
and then it's true, I guess. I don't know. It's just like um
it's like an arabos. It's just kind of gross. I don't know. Look,
look, I'm not going to say that I wasn't a huge fan of Destiny
at one point. I'm a fallen fan or whatever. Um but I have been
thoroughly slapped with a reality pill and it is just absolutely
embarrassing to see this continue to go on. How did you say that?
How did I say what? That's a new cope. Is Smagle a big Destiny
fan? I'm a Fallen fan. Literally. Yeah, dude.
Uh now, apparently Hassan was barred by an event from AT&T,
so he couldn't get into Lwig's event because of AT&T >> How
come you're not invited to these things anymore? I am. This is
just the one thing that I can't do because look at that. You
see that in the corner right there? They don't follow me. >> What
What can we do? Gregor Samso. What can we do? >> That's
insane. >> Yeah, I'm literally in the creator league. Uh
I just haven't participated in any of the events. >> Uh
he didn't name us directly. He's almost certainly when he says
a logs, he's talking about me and Quan. I would assume he's talking
about me and Queman, but I was whatever. I'm just happy he's
doing good coverage >> cuz I was injured for most of the
time. Why don't they like you? I don't know, man. Think think
for a second. So, is he just admitting that like everybody on
him? Well, I mean, he wants us to say that it's Ethan Klein and
Dan Saltman's fault, but I still think it probably has something
to do with the terrorism. >> Why could a major corporation
>> do you think that I'm a bad person for still liking
Destiny even though I acknowledge he low-key sucks? I don't want
to sit here and get linked into this topic uh and argue about
this for 24 hours a day because there's enough clips of Destiny
like crying that I'm like counter opt or whatever or something.
There's like four clips of it, so I don't really want to create
another one. But, uh yes and no.
I don't know. If you're acknowledging that he's
then like, yeah, no, it's fine. I guess if your position is that
like Destiny is saving the left, I definitely think less of you.
Um, if you're a casual fan who just really doesn't give a I guess
I kind of respect it. But if your whole thing is like we need
Destiny to like save lefties from becoming right-wing conservatives
and and save politics, I probably have the lowest opinion possible
for you. I think like only lower than that would be like Jared
Fogle or like Bo Blacks. not like a particular not like a a particular
political content creator who isn't necessarily uh you know like
a pariah figure at all. I mean a political who gets like coverage
from mainstream news and corporations are learning not to be
associated with extremely volatile on the internet. I don't know
if that's true. I think man I don't know if that's true. I really
don't know. I really have no idea if that's actually true. I
don't know man I don't think so. I don't think so. I guess we'll
see. What has Boax done besides being somewhat trans and um I
guess embarrassing for Nick? Embarrassing optics >> in
general. Just think what could it be? Is there one issue? Because
like these companies normally don't mind progressive politics.
What is the one issue that causes a lot of fear in the hearts
and minds and souls? >> It's just crazy, dude. Hassan [__]
confirms that he lost a sponsor. He thinks it's a big play to
like insult Ethan, but again, there's just so many reasons why
>> I think we're probably not gonna keep going on Twitch.
We'll see. I think we're not really we've we ain't got a lot
of people on Twitch right now. Okay.
I I'd like to run the Twitch stream or I would like to run the
Twitch stream more often, but uh the Twitch is just not
Listen, people like the kick. People are liking kick more and
more, I think. I hope. Okay. Okay. So, Twitch guys, head over
to kick kick.com/jdk.
All right. Kick.com. We're heading over there. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Would lose a sponsor here. That
wouldn't be people reaching out as well. It could be either way.
Ultimately though, I do think his actions are responsible for
why he's become a why AT&T has decided he can't play with
his friend Lewig. Like that's a thing that's happening. Uh stoastic
terrorism. Stotastic.
It's it's stotastic terrorism, right? That's how you [__]
pronounce it. I'm not going to get a million comments
how you [__] um Yeah. I mean, I think that that is
probably a good definition for Hassan 100%. This is the clip
that that I saw. Is this the one that I posted? There's one that
I posted that is like satirically satirically bad. No, this is
the clip of of uh Hassan denying it. Again, this is a huge problem
with Hassan [__] because every time I listen to a
clip of him trying to explain anything he says, he's so egotistical
and that he's never even able to explain
>> That's crazy. >> It is what it is. I guess
>> Cyber, thank you very much for 9 months.
Stream ended, but I still subbed. Wow. Thank you very much. >> This
illegal occupying force is literally legal. Definitionally legal.
>> Scholastic terrorism. Got it, bro. It's just the truth.
And no, it's not. If somebody attacks Hila Klene, they're going
to go to jail. >> Okay. So, when I say that there are people
who think this position I need to just pull up mine. >> Okay.
Yeah. This is the tweet that I posted. This is an insane quote.
I'm sorry. Like, I feel like you have to be I feel like you either
just got clickbaited super hard. I don't again. This Asmin Gold
clip is just bad. >> If it's your favorite podcasters like
uh wife that participate in these raids, the violence that the
Palestinians engage in >> next actually calling them out.
That's >> An act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal. Definitionally legal. Okay. It's >> like
I'm sorry if people don't think the course correction is worth
it. Listen to what Asmin Gold says. >> Truth. And no, it's
not. If somebody attacks Hila Klein, they're going to go to jail.
Why is he telling people this? Why would he be say what is wrong
with you? Do you think he'll get banned? >> Like I know
that we all realize Hassan [__] is highly unintelligent.
What are the odds that like Hassan [__] is so stupid
he thinks that you could walk up in a a US citizen in the name
of a foreign power >> and then >> oh wait you said
a primer I see thank you very much >> illegal at that point
if you're coming away thinking that that is not even what he's
implied implied is a different argument if that's what he said
and
>> and you're not going >> what are the odds that
is so stupid he thinks that you could walk up in a US citizen
in the name of a foreign power >> and that it would be
legal at that point if you're coming away thinking that that
Not even what he's implied. Implied is a different argument if
that's what he said and meant. >> Nick's Nick's got the
talking points. Okay. Nick's exactly on our page. You love to
see it. All right. Obviously, if you think that Hassan saying
it's legal to execute Ela Klene in Bair, okay, you're insane.
You've lost your mind.
>> And you're not going hm. What else was after? What was
before or after the 30 seconds I heard on Twitter? I mean, I
think that's at that point kind of on you. Implied is a different
argument. If you think he literally said that that like you could
walk up on a US citizen in cold blood in the US in current day
and you're just like that's a legal thing to happen and the UN
would like shake your hand. I mean at this point I don't really
know how to help you >> for this at this point. I don't
think so. I think that Twitch just doesn't care. I do. I think
that Twitch is they're so >> by the way a dog whistle cuz
if you think it's a dog whistle and you agree with the the framing
that I presented for it, that's one argument. If you think he
literally said that and he was just wrong, that's not what dog
whistling is. Right? If I tell you, if I go, you know, you can
legally kill doggy, right? And if I said that deadly >> hold
on. You didn't even pay for the false statement. You can murder
somebody, it wouldn't be dog whistling. That's not how dog whistling
works, right? Like if I if I go on stream, >> what a what
a dog whistle, guys. That explicit call to violence. That explicit
like noting that Heloclein's a legal target, a legal target for
murder. What a That's such a so hard to hear. That's a dog whistle,
guys. This is a dog whistle. It's not as bad. Somebody said you
could legally him, right? Obviously, don't do that. I obviously
disavow that. That's not what a dog whistle is. That's kind of
saying the whole thing out loud. >> Logically captured
by like I don't know what to do. I don't. He wants in on the
lawsuit. I guess so. I mean like he's making a direct call. >> So
what about the but like here's the argument. This is how you
know that you're like completely like a member of the totally
[__] brain. If I explain to you like legitimate arguments
towards like just actual of like what's actually happening and
your first response is but what about the senator? But what about
the gun that he tweeted? But what about the schematics? But what
about the 60 segments you've already done on that? >> Oh
god. Nick is no Nick don't do it. Nick, I'm going to tell you
now. Just stay in the matrix, okay? Take the blue pill, Nick.
Stay in the matrix. Don't start actually engaging with these
people. You will There's no end to the Okay, you need to stop
now. Stop now. Don't point out that it's insane to do that argument
when you're actually arguing about a totally different point.
Do not do that. Okay? Or you will do not do it. Do not do it.
Do not do it. Just stay in the matrix. Keep making your money.
It's not fun over here, okay? It's not fun. It's not fun. It's
not fun. Don't do it, Nick. Don't do it, Nick. Don't do it. Do
you hear that? If if you're responding to when I say this is
like not a real threat, okay, not a real threat. And if your
response is, but the senator the gun tweet and that's crazy.
Oh boy. Looks like this guy's riding Hassan [__]
now out of nowhere. >> Like a member of the totally brain
dut. If I explain to you like legitimate arguments towards like
just actual of like what's actually happening and your first
response is but what about the senator? But what about the gun
that he tweeted? But what about the schematics? But what about
the 60 segments you've already done on that? Well, that's like
a just I mean, yeah, obviously. Yeah, it's a totally valid argument.
This one's just not, though. So, I just want to make sure that
you're aware of that. Um, your your defense mechanism shouldn't
be, "But what about this other clip?" It should be like, "Hey,
let's just make sure the things that we're saying are correct
so Hassan doesn't report back to his audience and tell everybody
that they're lying about him again." You know, I hate Assan [__]
I think that you hate Hassan [__] right? So, when
it comes down to it, I think that the clips about Assan [__]
need to be the best represented clips possible on every opportunity.
The opportunity >> Oh my god. It's like someone said this
for so long. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my
good god. It's like watching my own stream right now. It's like
watching my own I love this. I love this. >> To post something
that we don't even know if it's accurate or not is a risk that
we are not willing to take or we should not be willing to take
explicitly because we do not like Assan [__] We don't
want to give Hassan [__] more opportunities to dismiss
us when we criticize him. Right? Nobody likes that. Nobody likes
when Han [__] tells his audience that everybody's
crazy and they all just go, "Oh yeah, these guys are crazy."
Well, if you post things that are completely out of context and
you say that Hassan said things that he didn't say explicitly,
not implied, explicitly, all you're doing is arming him to dismiss
you again in the future. And you could argue that nobody cares
about it, but there's a lot of people who watch his streams and
they all think you're crazy. So, that's like a major factor when
it comes to criticizing Hassan. I think that there are people
out here who are extremely bad faith who clip things extremely
bad faith and all they do is feed the Hassan [__]
machine and allow him to continue maintaining a large audience.
I think they are counterproductive to what everybody else is
trying to accomplish and that being exposing Hassan [__]
for being one of the easiest targets of terrorism support in
modern day social media. Hassan [__] can literally
there's a clip of him every single day that is above board. All
these responses that you're sending me. Oh, but what about the
gun schematic? But what about Bad and Panata? But what about
uh the time that he had the terrorist or musical people? But
what about >> All this is is proving my argument. Those
are all good arguments. This one is a bad one. We have so many
good arguments to work with. Why do we have to fabricate one?
Right. >> That's all that's that's the point. That's that's
the overwhelming point. But yeah, all for violence. A direct
and immediate call for violence again. And again, I'm sorry.
I got I'm sorry. I got to stop myself again. I know I'm getting
ahead of myself here. When you say that I'm not being fair. This
is the bare minimum. This is not me trying to get a medal or
a pat on my back or be the king of both sides in it or be a centrist.
I hate this guy. I just want this to be a good functioning argument
so you don't help him.
This is not me trying to help [__] This doesn't help
Hassan [__] at all. If everyone just acted above
board and clipped all the good, it would do way more damage than
just lying. You know, I don't need you to say, "Good job, Nick.
Nick is fair. Nick's doing a great thing here by correcting the
narrative." The best thing you could possibly do is just send
people in the correct direction so we Oh, guys, I probably need
to chill here early on, okay? Guys, if you like the content,
go ahead, donate to the stream. I'm probably only going to do
the extra two hours, but we do need to hit that $60 for the extra
two hours. So, guys, if you like the content, you want to watch
more content, okay? Go ahead, donate to the stream. All right.
I realize that's super early tonight. Um, but I I have a [__]
little of work to do, so I'm probably going to only stream for
a little bit if we >> understand all the context this way.
>> that's that's all I'm trying to say here. It doesn't
help Assan [__] to correct somebody when they when
they tweet misinformation that gets 100,000 >> against
people that are American citizens. That's insane. Oh my god.
Yeah. Now you come to that conclusion. Well, I mean, no, I've
said that before. I mean, I have. And so, yeah, make a post like
mic. >> Also, I listen, Techone even DM' me cuz I because
unfortunately, like when I tweeted this out, right? When I had
posted my uh breakdown of this whole situation on Twitter, Teone
reached out to me, totally cool about it. His tweet just happened
to be the one that I quote tweeted. So like yeah I'm telling
you I don't think this is like the most outrageous position but
um >> did they correct? Did Tech correct or >> so
from here let's talk >> Wait I don't think this is the
most outrageous position he 100% means to pander to his extreme
on clip blows up mainstream on Twitter. Wait did te did tectone
correct and say like oh actually this is uh this is not what
happened here. Maybe tee just corrected and we can say like wte
techone for once. Hold on. Can we can we see detect do it or
do we do we do we get it? Do we get a correction on the Hassan
thing? Hassan, Hassan, Hassan. Where's the Hassan correction?
Oh, this just a retweet of Dan and he totally keeps running the
same direction, lying openly. Wow. So, he corrected or sorry,
he said he apparently messaged Nicholas, found out exactly what
was going on and still still is this way. That's crazy. Okay.
All right. We keep going. >> Like, yeah, I'm telling you,
I don't think this is like the most outrageous.
>> Well, that's kind of like correcting. No, it's not.
It's not even remotely close to correcting.
But um so from here let's talk about what he had to say because
I think this is pretty important to go through. Hassan [__]
who's exposed by my husband to be a dis sorry disgusting creep
has retaliated by calling for violence against me. Think back
you'll notice a trend. When he wants to get Ethan he attacks
me. This is just another glimpse into the psyche of a man that
does not see a woman as his equal. He uses women to whatever
end he needs. It'll be revenge gratification or to massage his
ego by exposing their nude bodies without their consent to his
boys.
Look, I think of all above all else the people who are being
talked about here in this context recklessly by Hassan [__]
specifically Hila Klein who I've had to go through like I tweeted
out um what is it I tweeted out like Heloclein support is pivotal
right now and the amount of like insane vitriolic around and
under that tweet is just so range cuz even if Assan [__]
didn't explicitly call for the death of Hillel in current day
that did not stop people on Twitter people on X people on social
media from defending the scary fun and I think this is I think
this is a pretty solid clap back. Yeah. and then puts up the
clip just another Sunday and ultimately for Hassan
>> uh second you just posted a whole bunch of that I don't
even know that my first respon I'm going to read this actually
hold on my first response is that any advocacy for violence should
stand assuming should stand assuming maximal bad faith and on
the and on the speaker as political violence is literally the
nuclear option that we should not be willing to take under any
circumstance that isn't perfectly above board and allowing even
the risk of crypto advocacy or accidental advocacy for below
board violence is condemnable There's a direct connection to
the So basically if you are
this person if you like um if anybody so if you could possibly
make an argument that you could consider this as violence you
actually should I guess call that out or something or like treat
that as if they're calling for violence that seems extreme right
so when you say like treat that the same way maximal bad faith
uh I assume you think people should be deplatformed for advocating
for political violence so basically if you accidentally misspeak
in that direction, you should be deplatformed. I that can't possibly
be what you mean. So,
um I either way, I don't think I think there's no way you can
construe that as he's calling for political violence, right?
I don't think there's any way you can conrue it given the full
context, but I don't know which clip you watch. >> It is
kind of just another Sunday. That's Yeah. F. Did we get taken
down by the government? Well, it's not on my end, so I'm still
going to keep going because you just got to refresh in the middle
of the speech.
On my end, it's going to be dead air. give you 30 seconds. Three.
30 seconds is not a three, two one count, but I'm giving you
three, two, one. I think it's extremely careless. Well, it's
it's not just careless. Careless would be implying that it just
slipped out. It was an oopsy daisy by accident. Um, I think that
like Hassan [__] in certain ways is malicious by
having to weave them in there in like situations that >> Sorry,
when I say political violence, I mean political violence in the
context of the United States where political violence is not
okay. It's not a part of the paradigm. Obviously, political violence
is a massive part of the paradigm in the Middle East, right?
in Israel Palestine that is like it's literally political violence.
It's all political violence, right? Um he's advocating for violence
in a circumstance where you are being like uh where it's people
are illegally coming in to to conduct security operations in
your area, right? So it's very clear Hassan's not advocating
for any violence in America where we are against political violence
>> that involve like death. But ultimately this was kind
of the groundwork that was laid during the debate when Hassan
[__] was arguing with Ethan Klein over whether his
wife was a terrorist. Right? If if Hassan [__] is
arguing that Hila Klein is a terrorist in a debate setting, it's
not necessarily surprising that this is his position. >> Well,
you bring up Hila's name in that context. Uh and again, I'm going
to say this and I'm going to make this point repeatedly because
it is the perfect example for the point he was consistently making
for the past 10 minutes or so in that context, right? But Assan
championed Luigi after what he did. Okay, then Hassan did call
for political violence back then or he did support tacitly political
violence.
Seems kind of silly. I don't know why it would be related,
right? He this is not like an an over. >> It's both. Again,
it's both. I'm telling you, he I can tell you his exact thought
process. His exact thought process would be this. He would think,
okay, he's like trying to think of like how to make this point
to people that it doesn't matter what member of the IDF like
what they're doing. If you're coming in and conducting like some
kind of uh oppressive operation, you are a valid target in this
area, right? You're a valid target in this area. And from there
he goes, "Oh, here what's like the what's the example I could
pull to?" It's literally Hila Klein. And he probably thinks like,
"Oh, maybe I shouldn't." And then he's like, "Yeah, obviously
I should." Ethan talked about this today. He did. We'll get to
it eventually if Nick doesn't >> talking about this for
quite a while. >> I have enough with Asan this squad no
matter where you stand. >> I asked if you want to hop on
again tonight to actually go through just the the argument alone,
the just the the clip alone. We've gotten all the Hassan bad
out. We can just talk about the clip itself. I think >> um
this came from Tom Ward. Tom Ward spoke out. She's generous,
kind, caring, and an amazing wife, mother, and boss, and she
hasn't harmed anyone. Go [__] yourselves. And then
she said, "Thank you, Tom Ward." So, yeah, I'm hoping she's doing
doing good right now. Apparently, uh Ela and uh Ethan are getting
closed carry uh licenses or they uh have applied to get them.
I think that's probably the best bet. It's a [__]
do that without using her, but is he is he compelled to is he
forced to? Is there a reason he is forced to? Gray flag. Why
Why should we say it's like morally bad if he doesn't obey this?
I would say if Hila has removed herself from the situation, which
I think there's possibly some argument. I didn't see her during
the Hassan Piker's Predator thing. Okay, I didn't see her during
that. She references it after Hassan brings her up, but I don't
think she was there for that. If she's removed herself for a
long period of time, and especially if she said, "I'm removing
myself. Please don't bring me up here anymore." I feel like you
could respect that. I personally feel like you should respect
that. But
>> yeah, I just think this is a bar that's um that's crazy,
right? I think this is a bar that's crazy.
Uh and again, there's no amount of bad faith that can make this
not true, that he is not talking about violence in in the context
of North America in any way. He is he has actually cut that out
entirely. second.
So, uh I generally think probably if I had to say like vibes
wise, I feel like you shouldn't um you shouldn't bring up Ela
Klein, but I also think that nobody treats him with that charity,
right? I sort of understand why when nobody treats him with that
charity, he doesn't want to apply it reversely uh in a reverse
sense. Scary time again. Like you're joking here and you're gonna
people are going to take a pit out of me saying this getting
like >> Like what wasn't one of the things wasn't one of
the replies to that original tweet and Dan wasn't that like Dan
talking about trying to dox Hassan's dad? Am I crazy or was there
a bunch of [__] about doxing Hassan's dad in one
of those threads? Like these are the people who are operating
against him. I >> He's kind of crazy. I think potentially
someone could be hurt in this conflict. Uh when I went to VidCon
the week before, somebody got shot in the head over a copyright
dispute. >> So it's not completely unheard of. Um, do I
think that Hassan [__] is gonna do it? No. Do I think
that like fans are [__] crazy and people are getting
exceedingly violent and justifying exceedingly violent rhetoric
and they've been doing so for about a year, even unrelated to
this drama? Yeah. By the way, I would not have any I would have
not have any uh sorry, I would have a lot of heat for Hassan
if he did something negative, right? If he if he did say something
like this, if he if he did if I had any suspicion that he was
directing violence towards Ela Klein or saying that she's a valid
military target or doing anything beyond talking and using her
as an example of the thing he's talking about, right? I would
totally call that out. I'd be like, "This is total bull." Right.
But unfortunately for everyone here, the example just fits so
perfectly into what was actually happening that it's it's rough.
Okay. It's a rough one. >> Yeah. X has been X has been
like gradually getting more violent when it comes to anything
related to uh politics even outside of Israel Palestine for like
over a year now. I think it really started with the CEO. I think
when people turned around and said like based on the CEO and
regardless of what your opinion is, I think that's when I started
seeing people get a lot more violent and then from there I think
it's just kind of tapered off. It kind of got out of control.
But yeah, there was a copyright dispute that happened in Las
Vegas where a guy rolled up to an IRL streamer and shot him in
the head and killed his wife too. So I mean I'm just saying it's
it's pretty [__] scary right now. So I think it's
probably better um that that stuff is said out loud to bring
awareness to it. leader, hop on the stream. Hop on the stream
and you can explain to me exactly why it's >> Yeah, for
sure. >> You hop in streams all the time. >> The
Mudahar video was funny about it though. I will say the Mudhar
we did cover the Mudhar video about that. What did he say? That
his mind was blown when he saw what happened in Las Vegas and
he issued an apology. He's like, "Oh boy, >> Like I I suspect
ever the best argument I'll run into is it's just weird. It's
just like kind of weird to to mention Ela. It's just like really
weird to mention Ela. That's like the best argument people can
do, right? It just seems weird. It seems like you you shouldn't
mention Ela. It seems just weird to mention Ela. Does this not
show Twitch's double standard with a Destiny ban? No. >> Sorry
guys for my verbiage cuz he was cuz he makes like OBS recording
videos. I guess it just didn't click that he opened up a video
about a dude. I'm thinking like I saw a title of a video. This
is a pretty hard segment. So, we'll do a bit of a palette cleanser.
I >> Isn't it weird? No, it's not weird. It is literally
connected directly to the point he is making directly.
It is direct. saw a video the other day and it was called real
life aimbot or something like that and I'm like that's what Mudahar
would call a video on true crime like if he made a video >> oh
I see I see um a apostate I would say probably I guess you could
say it's a double standard in that Destiny was probably banned
like he could have been banned from Twitch for a bunch of reasons
where he actually got banned and the clip he got banned for was
like just totally right it was complete right yeah exactly second
thank you for at least being good faith on that aspect okay um
but like yeah des was banned for basically no reason, but that
doesn't mean it's a double standard for anybody but Destiny.
Destiny is just a weird like Destiny just is hated by people,
right? >> Yo, they have someone like their wife. He would
title that [__] like real life
I was I sat there. I was dying when I was I was having a giggle
myself in the middle of the night when I was reading that. He's
wall hacking. That's some [__] that Mudahar would
put in like a very highprofile uh thing. Yeah. So, that's he
climbed being terminally online uh talking about politics in
Israel Palestine 247 broke his brain. He was like this before.
Just look at what he Ukraine which boils down Ukraine deserves
what's happening to it. There is so much untapped potential.
I think that Willie was the only one who really covered it because
we were going to cover it on my video. Um like me and I think
I don't know if Tom was on at that point. It was like me and
Tom thing. The the [__] video has taken many forms
for my channel that never released it. Turkey Tom was involved
in like a lot of the planning not like the planning for the actual
video but he was going to be involved in the video at some capacity
and um
we a lot of that was going to be Ukraine. Like I was I was involving
Dylan Burns. I was asking Chud Logic. I was trying to get like
political people because at that point Chud wasn't really a drama
guy. He was more of a politics guy to come in and kind of speak
on it because politics wasn't really my strong suit as like a
video essay on his channel. It still isn't, right? But there
was so much to talk about related to um Hassan [__]
Ukraine. I think this is a classic clip. No, we've seen this
one before. Drew Pavo >> with an iconic 39 second clip
>> doing one good thing which is that like if you have
these millionaire billionaire wasp fail sons um at least taking
them out of other colleges so they can only do date to other
billionaire millionaire failed daughters is like in some respects,
you know, from a utilitarian perspective of course a little bit
better. You know what I mean? taking these guys. >> Do
people think this is him like saying is good? Like we we understand
the argument here, right? If you're a socialist,
well, these people are oppressing because of their collected
wealth. They are the capital class. They are technically oppressing
the people below them. So, if they're going to, you know, if
those rich losers are going to people, might as well other rich
losers who are also oppressing the the the
what do you call it? Like the worker class. That's like what
he's saying. Let the rich each other. Yeah.
as it's like pretty obvious that's what he's saying. He's not
saying is better if it happens to if it happens like to rich
people. He's saying that they're going to so at least they could
rate people who have the same like overall
Yeah. same overall class structure. Um it's still a it's still
like it's such a stupid thing to say in general, right? It's
like such a stupid thing to say. It's just rage baiting I guess.
But >> and and um and and putting that >> the reality
is that Hassan [__] is not like an intelligent person.
I think that's fairly obvious. I think that's kind of known at
this point. Yeah. Again, the way that Hassan [__]
has spoken about women his entire career going back to like the
the early TYT days when he was talking about if they're old enough
to mount they're so I guess I just don't watch as much Hassan
[__] as you gray flag. I don't see him cry about
microaggressions. Does he do a lot of that in modern day crying
about microaggressions? I would say what is the closest I've
seen him come to crying about microaggressions? Would it just
be like reading Islamophobia into stuff where it has no place?
Is that like what we're calling crying about microaggressions?
Like this is just this is just like a weird double standard argument
that I don't super care about, right? At all. Like I I I literally
don't care about this double standard argument at all. Like I
don't have to engage with like what about his opinion on this
other thing? No thank you. Okay. This clip specifically as it
exists
is not a call to violence. Not an implicit call to violence.
Not an explicit call to violence. It's not a call to violence
of any kind. Right? So you can say what about bad empanada and
like what about his opinion on micro? Shut up. I don't care.
I don't care.
>> Count the old enough to mount, I think, is the quote,
right? Up until now, like the clips that are resurfacing of I
saw there's like a new one that's going around of him almost,
I think, drunkenly talking about like peeping the nudes off of
his phone and stuff. He's just like a repulsive. He's a repulsive
frat guy. I didn't realize that. Isn't he like 30? Alexa, how
old is Asan [__] The streamer doesn't know what
wrote the words in 1805 and the song was >> Alexa, stop.
Alexa doesn't know. Alexa, do you know who Assan [__]
is? Alexa, do you know who Assan [__] is? >> I'm
not quite sure how to help you with that. Alexa, do you know
who Son [__] the Twitch streamer is? >> I'm
not quite sure how to help you with >> What the [__]
Alexa, do you know who tipster the YouTuber is? >> I'm
not quite sure how to help you with >> Do they remove YouTubers
from Alexa? Cuz these things used to come up. Um Alexa, do you
know who Ethan Klein is? >> Ethan Edward Klein is an Israeli
American YouTuber, comedian, and >> He is the host of the
H3 podcast. He first found fame with the YouTube channel H3H3
Productions created by him and his wife. >> Dude, Alexis,
do you know who Bowls is? >> I'm not quite sure how to
help you with >> Yeah, they cleaned it up. Now like only
like really notable figures are in there now because it used
to have like everybody in there. >> That's so funny.
>> Sorry. Skip through. Skip through. Skip through. Where's
the next thing? We're gonna go to Ukraine. Go to Ukraine for
a quick second. This is spinning.
>> Is he trying to read it as fast as possible so his chat
doesn't hear it. This guy's hitting like the the fast verse in
rap god so he doesn't have to repeat it. >> Soner was exposed
by this. >> You know, he should just watch the content
nuke on stream at I got it, dude. This is how his son Piper needs
to watch the content nuke so his audience can't understand any
of the talking points. You guys know. >> Okay, hold on
a second. I'll be right back. I just need to get some more
>> Content new. Dude, this is how he's going to do it.
He's like, "All right, listen. I'll finally react to this right
>> Um, I'm going to pull this thing up. Content new Cassander.
Okay. >> All right. All we need to do is set it to 4x speed
and then we use our then we got to just use our plugin that we
have here that can make it go even faster, right? And then we'll
set the video to 10x and then it's ready for Hassan [__]
to show to his stream. Then he can actively engage with the content
in like a reasonable fashion. Yeah, this is better. I think I
think that he might like I think the chat might be more receptive
to these arguments. He he could show it like that. I think he's
making a lot of good points here, but I'm not really sure. Dude,
you can actually watch this video in like a reasonable amount
of time if you 10x it. What? You only have two. If you have YouTube
premium, you get four. And if you have an extension, you can
go all the way up. I Dude, it's all the way up. The XQC emulator.
God, >> disgusting creepers retail by calling for vans
against me think back and you'll notice a trend when he wants
to get eth and he attacks me. This just another glimpse of the
psyche of a man who does not see women as equal. Okay, dude.
This is literally
girl bossing genocide defense.
>> Okay. And this is why Hassan [__] is such
a lovable idiot because like he actually can make an argument
here, right? There is an argument to be made here. But then he
just says that Hila Klein is girl bossing genocide defense. She's
defending herself because she thinks that your comment could
have put her in danger. Hila Klein has not committed the genocide.
Hila Klein has not anybody. Hila Klein was a secretary who did
one ride along. Okay. It's just actually insane. >> I do
find it quite funny. Okay. I do find it quite funny. >> Immediate
stunt has nothing to do with dead air that comes whenever you
bike or >> I do find it quite funny that Hassan basically
takes any attack on him as an attack on Palestine directly. Okay.
That says a lot about his ego. That says a whole heck of a lot
about his ego. >> Response here women. >> Girl bossing
genocide defense. I'm sorry. What is it possible to respond without
invoking her gender? >> Ironically, Asan exhibit. I didn't
even realize that. Oh no. Wait. I literally didn't even realize
that. So the whole thing is about how Assan doesn't treat women
barely. And his response is just like, "Ah, you're girl bossing
it." That's like if somebody was like, "Nick, you're being kind
of misogynistic." And I just looked in the eyes and I said, "Please,
please make me a sandwich." That's that's essentially what Assan
Piker's response was. That's extremely funny. I didn't I didn't
lock in on that one. Yeah. Hassan touches briefly on the recklessness
with nudes from his Snapchat blames Destiny's community for making
it a big deal. Again, these are all This is why Hassan [__]
is such an easy target. He just says stuff that's easy to talk
about. >> The people that came into his community that
like dramatically shifted his community cuz I every now and then
when I go >> Did we lose sound? Did you lose? I don't think
we lost sound. You might have lost sound. Jesus Palestine is
a meat shield. Okay. Sure.
Yeah. on Reddit like it shows up on my [__] game
page and the stuff that I see from the subreddit of a community
that I was a part of that I was like literally a host on with
the leftovers podcast. The say about me on there is mindboggling.
I sometimes I read it and I'm like is this Steven Crowder subreddit?
Like what the hell is going on? They'll be like Hassan is a Islam
supremacist. Uh he hates he loves the Armenian genocide. He's
a he's a >> Does he ever see the clips that are attached
to those statements or does he think that these are just blanket
>> Ultra nationalist.
Um I Islamic supremacist. I don't know about that. >> It's
shocking >> that Danny DeVito Danny Devito been like Hassan
strategy. We've been talking about this since like January. He
doesn't ever actually show the content that he engages. He's
actually this is actually like the actual Hassan defense. I don't
know what the actual like what the written down one is, but what
he does right is he assigns like a couple of positions that he
deems to be like absurd. Right here is A, B, and C. They're absurd.
And you know where I find them? The streamer Destiny's subreddit
or Destiny's viewers have put this into the ether. Now, Destiny
is code for disregarded this because because uh Hassan [__]
has primed his audience for all Destiny related criticisms for
like the entirety of his career after their falling out. So,
when people hear something and they go, "Oh, that's a Destiny
critique." His core audience then just logs out. They don't they
don't research it. They don't do more information. The Destiny
defense that he >> Yes, genetic fallacy is always stupid.
Okay, you have to contend with the the clips themselves. Okay,
I think the best example of this was the guy who did the post
on the Pisco subreddit. That was a perfect example of like, hey,
just so you know, that clip that's super bad faith like to use
that clip as an example of this, right? And I agree on that.
I said multiple times when we analyzed the clip like I think
Assan [__] is almost certainly like yeah, like a
bordering on communist, like a chaom. I think he loves China.
I think I don't think his Russia stuff's all that bad. Like his
Russia opinions, I think he like kind of isn't a fan of the current
Russian administration, but his his opinions on China are insane.
All right. And I think there's probably ways there's probably
clips of him defending camps or something along those lines,
right? I think that probably existed, but the clip itself and
like the argument the guy made in that thread, those are all
really good arguments, right? Genetic fallacy goes hard on the
internet and if you're not using it, you're losing to stupid.
Okay, but it's wrong to use it. It's just it's straight up wrong.
>> Uses is just enough to shut down the audience.
So now in the future if anybody targets Assan [__]
for any position of the Armenian genocide, be it Nick Dioro,
Turkey Tom, Ethan Klein, any of these other people. Well, the
audience is already primed that it's a destiny defense. This
is a destiny talking point. They're talking to Destiny. Destiny
wrote this. This is coming from his community, right? That's
that's the dismissal tactic. And it works over there. It legitimately
works over there. It worked for years because nobody could have
broken through Hassan Piker's uh community until Ethan Klein
because they had a shared audience. That's why a lot more blows
have been coming in the last year and there were a lot of uh
nothings prior to that. Like there were controversies with Hassan.
Hassan did go viral. There were things that broke through. Now
everything is kind of landing. His shields are down
>> It's lunatic behavior. And I'll see like people defending
Destiny in the subreddit being like, "No, Hassan actually saw
uns that's the whistle right there. >> Has received unsolicited
news on a Snapchat." And that's somehow the same if not worse
than what happened to Destiny who was a real victim of of uh
this this situation where he was like both non-consensually and
consensually recording people that he was having sex with. and
then unconsensual like oh they're saying that >> I think
unfortunately Hassan is kind of just on a comeback train right
right like he was he had a quite a falloff in 2024 when we were
covering him quite a >> and then the Ethan Hassan Destiny
stuff okay this all pumped him back up I'm I'm afraid he's just
like kind of coming back I don't know if his shields are down
necessarily right now I'd like them to be
a side also Destiny like you see what's happening here this is
like the this is the official defense is just pull up everything
Destiny has ever said >> fully sharing it with random Discord
eirls that he wanted without telling anybody else that he was
sharing this revenge material. That's actually the >> Like
it's like Hassan, anybody who's like a rational critic of you
probably agrees with all of this. The only thing this does is
like feed his audience.
>> Yeah, I think most people do agree with that. Yeah,
exactly.
I think the funny thing is is the people who made this art, it's
how do I put this? It's like I think people track the way the
information flows, right? Like it's obvious Dan was trying to
propagate this a lot and we kind of laughed at him and said you're
kind of silly. Do you remember when Dan went live right after
the Destiny news dropped and he like brought this up that Hassan
like had showed somebody let somebody see nudes on his phone
in Snapchat and we obviously pointed out how that's not even
close and then eventually that works its way up to Ethan and
Ethan's got his like document where he's going through all the
clips of this apparently happening even though some of them are
totally inconclusive. We can go through that segment at some
point. Maybe >> it's a reason to ignore everything that's
being said. >> If not, Hassan is worse. As a matter of
>> like that's the type of that that is the type of mental
mask you only engage in if you have a deliberate attempt to actively
put down an enemy of Destiny while simultaneously bring up as
a as a viable alternative, which only leads me to believe that
the community is entirely changed and all of those people are
eventually going to [__] leave. >> It's it's
not even like so normally it's what we're used to hearing is
are you going to criticize my character and my friends? You know,
there's an ongoing genocide, right? And children are dying. But
in this case, it's like, how could you possibly criticize me
when Destiny is distributing Pixie's nudes without her knowledge
or I guess sorry, videos without her knowledge. Like, there's
so many bigger things going on right now. The the the cinematic
universe of degenerates is much larger than you could even comprehend.
It's like, this is just pathetic. This is so yeah, I had posted
the Asmin Gold clip and I thought at that point this probably
needed correcting in some capacity because once it hit that then
all of a sudden my whole feed is like Hassan calls for the immediate
execution of Heline, which is just not what happened. Hassan
says there's not much he can do about the monsters awful sociopath.
So now his argument is that like he's mad that Asmin Gold is
talking about him. >> Are you worried? >> He's mad
about everything but the actual things that people are upset
about. It's >> No, not really. What can I do? >> He's
mad that Asold is bigger than him because he was constantly like
crying and moaning about how Twitch like um like was like an
open platform for everybody and then a conservative actually
made it past him cuz again there was a time period where his
son the biggest political streamer on Twitch was one of literally
every other like I think like the biggest um conservative streamers
were just barely at the partner level or below and then Asmin
Gold one day decided to start watching Donald Trump speeches,
right? Like it was an entirely uh left-centric hug box for it
had to have been like two years. They just kind of banned all
of the conservatives, right? It was like a lefty hug box and
specifically like getting to be like a far-left hug box.
>> Again, like I don't know if you can really compare IRI
and loader box to the size of Assan [__] >> It
was >> Do you think Hold on. Do you think um Do you think
Nick will point out that Ethan is not telling the truth here?
We'll get this. We'll get this popping up and him pointing out
that this is like a clear and obvious lie.
We'll get that. Right. Hey, this is a clear and obvious lie.
I should mention the people who are clearly and obviously lying,
right? Nick did his his like criticism and his walk back before
these people went live today. It this is like totally false.
Yes. Yes. Now Nick will say nothing. Hold on. I was trying to
find the Hassan clip that he's watching. Just watch it. >> Let's
just watch the actual clip. >> Not really. What can I >> Not
really. >> What can I do? There's nothing I can do. It
is what it is. >> Dude, could you Hey, buddy. Could you
learn some signaling to your audience? Bro, don't do the don't
do the uh what do you call it? Like the doom posting, okay? Don't
do don't do that. Don't do that [__] with your audience
there. Like, come on, man. They can't keep you >> I do
think that it's um gotten worse over time and will only continue
to be elevated by Asmin Gold and many other people like this
who are just like awful, awful, monstrous sociopaths. >> Little
bit. Um
no, I'm talking about his his coverage of that video leader,
but I'm I'm also talking about in my two-minute video. There's
enough there that you can easily see what he's talking about.
If you want to argue how there's like an implicit thing, uh,
you can feel free. You come on for the two-minute thing. Okay.
>> Are you worried? No. >> Oh, we watch this. We
watch this. Let's go through Nick until he's like through this
clip. >> Adding it up for dramatic effect.
>> Interesting though that he's playing the other side
of this. They've been trying to get me banned for a while. So
now I'm going to try to get them banned. The next thing I saw
here was him pulling up Destiny's logs, which at this point I
still haven't read them. We're going to read them now together.
I think it goes down to a nameless Destiny. Say, uh, feels weird,
man. Cinema. Wow. lives matter. Put me in the No, it has to be
below. Is it Is it top down? So, Destiny had linked a clip and
I imagine it's the clip saying, "I honestly think you could perfectly
justify attacking/blanking Hassan in real life for statements
like this." So, that's not a dog whistle either. That's also
just saying it out loud. Um, and what you do when you do this
is you give Hassan [__] an opportunity to play a
victim. And he is like, you can't Well, so yeah, it's not just
Hold on. You victimized Han, but you are literally calling for
his death.
Sorry. You are essentially calling for his death. like this is
so different and I understand this. So I honestly think you could
perfectly justify attacking such Hassan IRL for statements like
this is what Destiny says, right? So he's not saying go Hassan
[__] now, but he is doing the next thing which is
like this is this isn't a dog whistle. It's still like an explicit
call for violence, but it's it's not him saying you have to go
do it now. It's him saying, you know, I think you could justify
for this. Yeah, I think you justify killing him for this. Destiny
did what Hassan people think Hassan is doing. Yes. Yes. Exactly.
I every part of this drama so far has been, "Oh, you're going
to dox somebody? That's fine. I'll dox your entire extended group
of friends where it's like, oh, you're gonna [__]
talk about like, okay, well, we're call It just continues to
escalate and escalate and escalate and escalate and escalate
and escalate and somebody's going to kill somebody's going to
kill one of us." It's kind of scary. That's the moral That's
the moral of the story. It's kind of scary. Yeah, it's been It's
been ugly since day one when people are like It's like, hold
on. But why are we Oh, I
Oh, man. I don't want to I don't want to soy out over this because
I just try not to soy out about it, but like dude, it's like
not close and these sides are not doing it's not a back and forth,
right? It is not a back and forth in any sense,
right? It is one side going insano mode the whole time and the
other side like kind of referencing the people going insano mode.
Okay, it's like it's not even remotely close at all. Like Hassan
goes Hassan uses Hila in an example that clearly puts her outside
of any immediate action where it is actually like tightly related
like tightly related and relevant.
And then Destiny's like I think you could for this. It's like
not close, right? They're totally disproportionate.
They're not close in any way. >> Like Ethan Klein opened
the door for doxing when he filed these lawsuits or targeted
the Snark mods. It's like broinata has been doxing since day
one. It's probably why Hassan [__] didn't want to
pal around with him prior to uh having an endless Ethan Klein
video machine that he was willing to attack because none of the
content creators on the commentary community agreed with him.
But uh yeah, people are crazy, dude. Destiny gave him a great
moment to use a victim card. You want to see somebody like we're
sitting here talking about how a bad Asmin Gold clip can provide
Hassan some defense. This is like a golden apple in in Minecraft.
We're talking about in Minecraft defense. Like do you think that
any Hassan [__] chatter who's fringe who might agree
with any of your positions right now is going to turn code on
this? You think they're going to read a message of somebody saying
that you could you could literally Hassan [__] in
real life and they're going to go, "Wow, you know, I actually
really sympathize with this guy." No, because Destiny is like
a broken down, disgruntled um entertainer who's living life in
scorch earth mode now because and I don't even know why because
I think he's gaining viewership again. But it's not respectable.
It's just kind of making it more difficult to criticize the guy
when you do stuff like that. Yeah, the Forever Holy War. I mean,
you're talking about no in real life. You're making reference
to Sam Hyde. The Sam Hyde stuff. It like you could literally
play the Sam Hyde clip next to this and it reminds me of like
uh that's a wild thing to say. He literally said it about me
and Quimman like six months
Dude, it's like bro, I wanted to I almost quote tweeted this.
was just like first time like oh welcome welcome to the welcome
to the club buddy welcome to the club >> Carl Job's um
Billy Mitchell video where it's like Billy Mitchell is obviously
saying something >> oh great flag you'll be okay buddy
don't worry about it >> Carl Job is actually extremely
mad and looks pathetic we're all going to be >> you could
play a Sam Hide clip where he's like per I'm coming to you but
like that's something you look at like a that's kind of funny
like I mean I understand why he doesn't like it but that's pretty
funny this is just Destiny being angry that he couldn't take
down the illegitimate child that he spawned into the internet
a couple years ago and that like Hassan hasn't committed a Vochike
scandal that boxes him off away from the rest of the internet.
So maybe he will at some point. Who knows? Yeah. Uh, how much
longer will YouTube allow this dude to stream? Spent years stalking
me with his community. So that's the claim that came out. And
again, it's just like it's literally the same day that he created
this whole Hilo clin controversy and then Hassan starts playing
the victim. So you see the clip of him talking about Asmin Gold
and kind of pulling for that, saying the community is like harassing
him. And now you see the clip where he's like, "You got to do
something about Destiny." So now it's like a flag war, too. If
the stuff wasn't bad enough, now they're flagging YouTube channels.
I think that's the worst part. So this was the tweet that I put
out. Um, and I think this is again, this is kind of what we've
reiterated for the entirety of the stream. It's absolutely [__]
reckless to be talking about current day and I don't really care
about what your position is on the region of Gaza. Uh because
that's not necessarily the issue or necessarily the point, but
like and you could absolutely have issue with what he's saying
in the clip from that context as well. I'm not like denying you
that. But um yeah, it's absolutely reckless to be talking about
something in current day, making arguments about currently occupied
Gaza, and then because you hate Ethan Klein to like invoke his
wife in the middle of that argument. If >> it wasn't for
the fact that Nick hated you and Queen, he would say something
about the Willy Mack convo where he threatened you.
H maybe >> strictly in past tense and just move past it
like nothing actually happened because yeah absolutely it could
be interpreted as dog whistling. I don't think it is. It could
be interpreted as dog whistling. It could be uh it could be read
by a psychotic [__] person. >> The crazy thing
is is apparently Willie complained about me and Quimman all the
time, right? Apparently he constantly complain. I literally stopped
talking about Willie for like months. I literally like I was
basically totally off. I I didn't say about him, right? And he
would still take [__] to me all the time.
It's crazy
and does something crazy. I think that if you're going to talk
about stuff like this using real life examples, you have to be
pretty clear about it. Yeah, 100%. You have to be pretty clear
about it. Um >> uh second stream's going really good, >> especially
when it's not like like I made a joke one time about Hassan um
because he had tweeted out the picture of a gun schematic to
a sitting US congressman or senator or something, right? Like
he had tweeted out the gun schematic that we're going to see
in a little while and I think I made a joke retaliation because
like they were saying stuff like uh oh, this is just an edgy
joke. Oh, this is loud. Oh, this
>> Whoa. That's second with the five gifted. Uh guys, we're
six subs away from another two hours on the stream. Six subs
away and we get two more hours. Let's go. Get there. Get there.
Get there. 27 minutes left. >> That's how his community
was justifying >> Second. Thank you very much for the or
something. And I quote tweeted. I'm like, "Oh, I love edgy jokes."
So I tweeted the IDF has like the funny can do the funniest possible
thing. And it's a bunch of streamers in like California or something.
Right. That was like a whole controversy. So I tweeted the IDF
can do the funniest possible thing to >> I It wasn't even
autism soap box. It was literally I was just like, "Oh, I'm going
to like argue." I don't know. I can be aggressive sometimes in
arguments. I don't know why I'm so aggressive in arguments sometimes.
Okay.
>> Feels bad. You know why? Cuz I don't [__]
know the IDF and the IDF can't do in California or in Vegas or
wherever TwitchCon is. I can't call the IDF and have them intercontinental
missile to blow them up. That's why it's like that's that's edgy
humor. Invoking some and this isn't even humor. This is just
him arguing a point invoking somebody who's not currently in
the region because he's mad at them, right? It's absolutely insanely
reckless to do this, especially when it can be interpreted that
way. Um, not just any gun. Well, yeah, it wasn't just the gun
schematics, but uh why do you think he said it? I mean, I've
explained that multiple times. I think he's brain broken by the
controversy and wants to take every excuse he possibly can to
talk about it in the context of still trying to justify that
he's doing the right thing. I think that like Hassan [__]
wants to continue covering the Gaza conflict and wants to continue
to say he's above it. >> Oh yeah. Uh leader, you have to
join the waiting room. >> Can't it can't stop leaking out.
He needs to stop talking about the starving >> You don't
have to join the waiting room. I can drag you in just a second.
>> Okay. Hello.
>> What's up leader? How's it going?
>> Yeah, it's going well. How are you
>> Uh reasonable.
Okay. I I think uh I think I think you're uh you've got this
you've got this backwards. I would say that it appears to me
that um Hassan uh is is like
is I would say that in some way he is uh I'm I'm bit nebulous
into sort of like the I think in some way yeah I think his son
is calling for violence against um healer under certain circumstances
that you could interpret it that way. >> Okay. So, >> you
need to clean this up because obviously like I feel like this
can't just be he's calling for violence. Like >> you believe
it's dog whistling. You believe it's uh like covert coded in
some way. >> He's obviously not directly calling for violence,
right? >> Well, okay, this is my point. >> Uh Hassan's
like he's uh in the in the what he says is basically that he's
fine with attacks on the um is the IDF and the uh settlers.
The settlers I believe is like a civilians. Yeah, that's what
he's referring to when he says settlers. He's saying when you
attack civilians on the ground that is legal and moral. They
are an occupying force. Correct. >> Uh he's saying the
settlers are an occupying force. Do you know what the documentary
is about? >> As I haven't seen the larger 10 minutes. >> I
haven't I haven't seen >> you can see it in the two minutes
I'm doing. I think you can see the title. It's um it's about
armed settling settler violence in the West Bank.
So, so you're saying to me that when So, you think that when
he says settlers, he isn't referring to civilians?
>> No, he's he's obviously not referring to civilians.
He's not doing that thing. He is watching literal like actual
violent settlers over here, like armed violent settlers. When
he's saying settlers, I I think Do you think it's unreasonable
to say that when he says settlers, he's referring to the people
on his screen who are being called settlers? >> Yes. Yes.
But I I Okay. Do you doesn't Hassan have like a um isn't hasn't
Hassan now I don't have a quote for this so I could be wrong
I'm willing to I'll admit that >> I believe he said that
like foundationally I would agree that he is found he said foundationally
so what I think he's done is I think when they brought up this
second thought like settler babies quote I do believe that what
he said was well that is kind of true technically cuz he's an
who's like well they are you know almost everybody in Isra is
like kind of a settler. >> Yeah. Yeah. Sure. >> Sure.
Sure. Sure. So, so basically it's like would you call a group
of Mexicans who came over and like formed a colony in the States,
built like a little structure, had weapons, and anybody who came
to like to to move them off of that land, they fired at. Would
you say that those are civilians? >> No, but I don't think
that accurately paint portrays the picture in Israel
>> No, it doesn't. But I'm saying that this is what's happening
in the West Bank, right? He he oh also he is saying within the
West Bank. That's the context of this whole thing. And I think
that much is clear from the two-minute clip. No, he's talking
about actions you can take in the West Bank. Uh
um what did he say at the start and experiences in the West Bank?
Okay. Yeah, he does he does mention the the um uh the isbank
the West Bank and the Gaza Strip. Yeah, sure. I can I can I can
definitely agree to that. Um, and he's watching a documentary
on settler violence in the West Bank. And he has just watched
the um IDF come and like a storefront or something of somebody
in I believe this is I I believe it's area A, but I'm not sure
if this is 100% an area A. All right. But so as long I guess
like as long as you're willing to like accept that uh when he
says settlers, he's not referring to civilians, then your argument
is true. But if you do take a if you take like if you take when
he says settlers and he has used this uh term more broadly before
to mean like more in a more broad then you could in my argument
would be uh Ethan and Heila have gone to Israel before they visited
they visited Israel. I'm not sure which particular parts I just
know they have and if they're in Israel they are civilians there.
So, in a more broader
>> you could say that maybe, right? Maybe I would say,
you know, he's not calling for violence for them in thing, but
he does call uh a healer a um a uh what is it? Uh one of those
uh he calls her like he participated in the the raids and IDF
raids, right? So, he's like directly attributing
uh uh healer to like, you know, someone who like does these raids.
So, I I just I I don't I don't think it's 100% clearcut that
he's uh that, you know, he's not in the green on this. >> I'd
say he's like very close to the red. >> Um I think he's
pretty in the green. So, we could go and look at the the two-minute
clip again. I believe he is also talking about people who are
engaging in military operations, essentially people who are like
armed. I believe he's talking about like it's okay to militarily
resist these people. >> Um I'm not 100% sure if that's
that's obvious here uh from the even the two-minute clip. I'm
pretty sure that's the case though. Like he even starts talking
explicitly about the IDF. Uh that could be the case. I just like
when you say that it feels weird to me that you would throw in
like a like you know Ethan Klein's wife in the middle of like
all these terrorist um organizations and uh you know but you
know >> Klein's wife's name in in the middle all of these
terrorist organizations. >> Yeah. I think I think that
so you're right. Yeah. Yeah. I think that's a little bit weird
if we're on the if we're on the topic, right? >> Uh, no,
cuz she's engaged in the So, he is describing that like that
you could technically So, what he says is actually, you know
what? I do. You want to watch this other part with me? I'm I'm
grabb this other timestamp for both of us. Okay. >> Yeah,
sure. Let's watch this together. Whatever you need to go through.
>> Yeah, cuz I think um this is more instructive and this
is from before and I'll I'll grab this and we can play it and
I think it lends a lot of uh additional context to this whole
thing. There's about five minutes before where the clip picks
up >> like any sort of sympathy or any sort of like mention
>> here. Let me back it up just a little bit here. She's
watching this document
>> The IDF comes over
this person's [__] Like these things,
>> are are
marginal in comparison to like obviously the the
death and destruction campaign in Gaza, but this is a part of
everyday existence for Palestinians in the occupied West Bank.
These guys are one illegally occupying
uh the West Bank for the record. And they do this [__]
on a daily basis. You like there are a million videos like this
where they just like go into a storefront and just [__]
it up. I just think um we should watch this whole thing because
it is informative. It's about yeah, like I said, about five minutes
before the actual stream clips to know the context of like sitting
in there, they go through their social media to look for things
that they can find that they can arrest them on like any sort
of sympathy or any sort of like mention.
>> these are images not dissimilar to the Gestapo harassing
random citizens and packing up Jewish people in Germany. Now,
while I say that's hyperbolic, I'd say this is obviously like
what you call like, you know, fasy or something, right? Like
they're the police force. They're by by military force alone,
they're coming in and just like with these people. Seems like
>> Yep. That seems pretty stressful to me. >> Yeah.
There's no there is little to none armed resistance against these
freaks for the record. >> Even though they are terrorists,
they are in direct violation of international law. And it is
legal. It is literally legal if every single Palestinian there
took up arms and started actively fighting against those terrorists,
the Israeli occupying force. That is literally legal and moral.
Okay,
>> So he's clearly talking about the occupied for occupying
force in area A of the West Bank,
>> right? right now. Maybe it's not clear he's talking
about, but he's talking about the occupation. >> No matter
how no matter what all of your previous social conditioning has
taught you, understand that what they are doing, regardless of
of uh the the state violence that they're doing here, what they're
doing is illegal. >> Okay. So, what all of your what was
that preconceived immoral? Okay, >> let me let me hear
that again. >> No matter how no matter what all of your
previous social conditioning has taught you, understand? >> Yeah.
No matter what all of your previous social conditioning has taught
you, right? This is one of the points he makes is in favor of
the idea that he is talking about how despite how this might
look like the moral act in the situation because they look like
American soldiers kind of despite that that's not true >> and
that what they are doing regardless of of uh the the state violence
that they're doing here what they're doing is illegal racist.
Why use a racist voice to mock Israelis? I don't know because
it's funny they're doing a genocide. Does that hurt your feelings?
>> I'm sorry. That's also just funny. Probably not great
in terms of people calling him an anti-semite, but uh that's
just funny. I agree with you, but I don't think legality is the
issue. No, I'm just explaining to people that like what they
think is legal is obviously seeing armed military uh you know,
members of the state, members of the [__] military,
members of the police force. And automatically we're conditioned
to thinking like, oh, what they're doing is a legal thing. Maybe
So, point two, um, when you are looking at the military, when
you're looking at guys who are dressed like this, you automatically
assume what they're doing is okay, right? But it's not. Doesn't
matter how doesn't matter how they look, it's not okay. >> It's
racist, but it's like still a >> This is I'm I'm also just
largely pointing this out for my chat. I realize you didn't really
challenge me on this. I'm just pointing out for my chat because
this was a point I was making last night. It's a point I'm going
to continue to make is he's driving home this point, right? That
it doesn't matter what the Palestinians look like. It doesn't
matter what the Israelis look like in this context. There is
no context in which the Israeli military can do anything to with
these people and they're the moral actors in any way. They are
immoral by their presence. Their presence alone makes them immoral
actors in this case. >> It's not. It is completely illegal.
>> Okay. This is not like a police uh a member of the police
force like being of racist to a a citizen. This is like even
beyond that. That is abhorrent. That is up. That should be prosecuted.
But this is a step beyond that. >> Green screen. The visitors
arrive in small groups to look at a tomb up the street. The Palestinian
city of Hebrron is in what is known as area A of the West Bank.
It means it's >> okay. It is in control of >> that
literally said, "Why you love Israel? You are being racist."
>> Dude, it's up that he sounds exactly like Just. Okay,
that's the really up thing here is that like I can't tell the
difference between that voice he just did and justs. Like why
use racist voice to mock Israelis? I don't know cuz a country
doing
>> I'm sorry that's just facts here and gets in their feelings
when I'm doing like like a bad German accent >> that's
just facts that it's like exact. >> Is it a f? What happens
authority? But everyone here says the presence of Israeli soldiers
and settlers is designed to make a point >> to emphasize
who's really in charge. This is a journey around the West Bank
and inevitably it starts at the wall
So, so, okay. So, I I feel like this is building up the context.
If I tell you we're about I think 30, we might be we this might
be where the clip starts. >> Israel from its Palestinian
neighbors. >> One second. >> It is imposing and is
in many ways a symbol of Israel's desire to segregate the people
who live on. No, no, no. We're about a minute away from where
the clip starts right now. >> From them, >> the wall
was built over two decades ago to stop Palestinian terror attacks
inside Israel after a wave of violence. But there is more than
a wall to all of this. The West Bank and its people would make
up the lion's share of a Palestinian state if one were to be
recognized.
Geographically, it's on the West Bank of the River Jordan, which
is where it gets its name from. Current political leadership
in Israel does not want a Palestinian state, and the Israeli
parliament has just approved a motion to annex the West Bank.
It doesn't necessarily mean it'll happen, but it shows the thinking
>> like any kind of violence that >> Okay, this is
where the clip starts right here. So, I'd say does that does
that context change your mind on anything here at all?
Um, it's still it's still uh like within the like like you made
you made a good point about him like sort of uh talking about
the uh West Bank and you know why sort of like uh like I can
see the context there that you provided. Yeah. All I'm trying
to it's still to me though it still strikes me as like a very
odd thing that he's bringing up Ela Klein within like the with
sort of in the confines of all of this and uh
>> you understand that went on a raid into area A, right?
This is an area a zone where it is illegal by definition for
Israelis to be here, for Israeli military to like operate here.
It's under the security authority of the Palestinian Authority,
right? They're they're the security for this area. And instead
of like
and that's what Ela Klein did. It happens to line up one to one,
right?
That it's like the exact same thing. She was with the IDF participating
in a security
>> I guess raid >> in area A the area where it is
illegal for the IDF to be.
>> Yeah. Then then like then you would agree with me that
he's calling for violence for like Ila Klein because she has
gone to like Israel before >> when she was participating
in that raid
>> in this in this area. If she were raiding into area
A that is where she would be a valid target, right? I I guess
like the I I see what you're saying with the context, but I think
that like broadly Hassan would agree like that the but more broadly
that more all of Israel would be like a valid military target
for Israel. >> But that's not that's for Palestine. No,
that's not even the point he's making though. He's saying under
international law, this is legal. And when he talks about it,
he says legal right before this part, right? He's talking about
legal, which means he's obviously referring to area A. It's not
legal for Palestinians to terrorist to attack in with terrorism
or or let's say
violent resistance people anywhere in Israel. Civilians anywhere
in Israel. That's insane. That's not what he's saying here. He
is saying it's legal. It is legal under international law. So
he's saying in area A, Israel has no presence. I don't know if
he's correct here. I kind of doubt he's correct. But that is
that is what gives away what he's talking about, right? That's
what makes it very obvious to me what he's talking about is he's
talking about area A and how Israel is not allowed to have a
security presence there >> and that anybody who is operating
under the guise of the here is a val is a valid target for any
uh any violent resistance. You're allowed to defend yourself
if there is an occupying force from another country who's entering
your country and with your I don't think anybody disagrees with
that. Right. >> Um well listen I think I think there's
a lot more to the Israeli conflict than just what uh Assan's
playing right now. Um, but uh if you're like literally talking
about defending yourself, then that's perfectly fine. But when
you bring up like someone who's in another country, who's not
a part of the IDF currently, who's uh who's um uh you know, essentially
like a wife in the middle of California, and in the context of
all of these other like all of these like terrorist groups and
you're you're okay with you say you like they say they say um
Israeli uh settlers, I I take when he says Israeli settlers,
I take that to mean civilians. Now, I understand to you that
I understand what you're saying. There are people that are not
um Israeli settlers.
>> I have to ask you again. He's saying it's illegal to
do this violence. It is not legal to go out and attack any Israeli
citizen. >> So it kind of gives the game away, right? With
the context, it gives the game away entirely. What he's referring
to, where he's referring to it, that that like makes it obvious
what's in his
>> He he also calls it moral
>> resist. It's totally legal and totally moral, right?
Yes. >> So it's not just it's not just legal he's talking
about. >> No, he's saying it's both. >> So it has
to be legal. It's not just it's not just legal, but by by virtue
of it being legal, he's referring to a very specific area which
is not the United States. It's not broader Israel. It's just
area A. Right. >> Right. But if for example, if Hila Klein
was to go to Israel, then she would be a totally moral target.
>> No. No. We're going to we're go
A. If you went to area A, it is possible. It is possible he might
give you if she went to area A, she would be a valid target.
It's possible, but I believe it's when she went on in the context
of the raid, right? So, if she went into Habbron, it's possible
Hassan could say, "Oh, she'd be a valid target." But I don't
think so, cuz I don't think that would be moral. If she just
went in as a civilian, I don't think that'd be moral at all.
And he's not talking about somebody who's there peacefully, right?
Hold on. He's not talking about somebody who's there peacefully.
This is in the context of he's freaking out about these Israeli
citizens up the storefront or sorry the IDF people up the storefront.
He's watching a documentary on violent settlers. So it seems
to me pretty obvious that when he says moral he means if you're
there up if you're not there for peaceful reasons go [__]
yourself, right? You're a valid target. Hey, I can see what you're
saying JTO. But I would say that when he says moral and uh I
think in a more broader context I don't think his son gives a
[__] when it comes to uh when it comes to like violence
that's done against Israel or is Israeli um settlers. And when
he says settlers in my what I'm hearing I understand that you
you've got good context perhaps even you've got some reason to
believe what you're saying but in my mind when he says settlers
I have every No no you you are just you're actually going against
the evidence in front of you because you don't want to admit
that like you've come to the incorrect conclusion right like
I've I've given you basically incontrovertible evidence about
what he means so you you have to admit at at base that he's not
saying Ela Klein is a valid target where she is um in broader
Israel That is that is >> where she where she is where
she is where she is. But if she was to go to Israel then I would
say then to go to oral not just not just Israel you have to you
have to give me this not just Israel you cannot you cannot walk
away from this. It's not just Israel it's area A. But I don't
even think he's arguing by the way. I don't think he would argue
that non-combatants peaceful civilians who have entered area
A don't think he would argue they should be targeted either.
That's why I think he says the thing about the raids >> if
we if we like in his broader coverage of like the Israeli top
Israeli conflict and we apply that
in a secretary uniform on patrol in the West Bank. I'll show
her how bad Hassan can be. Wink wink. >> Okay. Thank you.
Hassan after dark for the $3. Uh go ahead. Sorry. Sorry about
that. Crazy people tip in. If you talk about if you talk Where
was I? If you talk about um if you talk about uh if you talk
about Hassan and like the broader context of like what Hassan's
opinions are and you apply them to this, I don't think it's like
totally unreasonable that that like Ela Klein could take this
as like a death if she was to go to Israel.
>> So I don't I think emotionally you can do anything.
Like I don't I don't think there's and Klein and Ethan Klein
are both the most neurotic people that exist on planet Earth.
So I have no doubt that they think this is a real death threat.
Okay. But unfortunately for them, their or us, their emotional
state is not what makes this a death threat or not. And it's
clearly not a death threat. And he is clearly talking about within
area A, right? He is clearly talking about this. And he's not
saying that anywhere in Israel she is a valid target. He's not
even he's not in Israel, by the way. But like we've we've categorically
eliminated the United States 100%. So now we've we've agreed
entirely that it is not a direct call to violence, right? >> Sorry,
you're laughing. But you have to agree that it's not a direct
call to violence. Yes. If if you want to say that if Hila Klein
going to Israel is a you know if you want to sort of make the
distinction between like where she is and where she could be
and say because she's not in Israel she's not a it's not a direct
call of violence then you can you can you can you can take that
position. I don't even want to argue with that with you. >> Sure.
Okay.
>> What what do you think a direct call to violence is?
I I actually do. What do you think a direct call to violence
is?
It'd be like it'd be it'd be like directly calling it'd be directly
calling for violence of someone. It'd be like go kill a client.
>> Can you directly call for violence
um saying that like like is it a direct call for violence or
is it a direct um
>> how would you put this? Oh, if you come if you come
to Australia, I'm going to you up. Is that like um >> I
wouldn't I don't even think he's doing that here. Like I don't
even think I I can like say it's like less it's not it's not
conclusive that he means uh she has to be a militant area a although
I do want to keep listening here as well cuz I am interested
to see but I I just don't think I I don't think there's almost
any way you can call this a like a call to violence on El Klein
like saying you should go do something to El Klein. I don't think
there's any reason for them to be scared. I don't think there's
I don't even think that like Yeah. I just I don't think there's
anything here. Jan 6 flashbacks. Wait, this is nothing like January
6th. This is not close. This is not even a little bit close.
Yeah, that latter statement I was like I was trying to figure
out how to make it like location conditional and I was just trying
to think through that in my head so I shouldn't have said it
but whatever.
I'm just saying it's not a direct call to violence. Obviously
it's not it's not explicit. It's not even implicit that like
she should be a target for violence. It's saying she could have
been a target for violence because she participated in these
raids. >> Okay. But I would say it's a current because
he he says that that she did and she did participate in those
raids and he throws her in with all those other like uh uh those
uh you know all those terrorist groups essentially you know with
the IDF with the settlers she's a part of that group that ingroup
that is okay to be targeted. So if she's in part of that ingroup
and she's in Israel why is that group okay?
Um
I mean why is that >> in this context? Is that group okay
to be targeted? >> You in the specific context of the video
or like in a broader context >> in the context of Hassan
is reviewing a video right now and he actually had a specific
moment which we went and looked at that started him down this
train of >> in in the specific context of the video then
it would be like within that area a you referred to. If you if
you referred to like Hassan's general political views, then you
could take that broader
>> why would you do that? Do do you not think that like
Hassan or like um any of Hassan's orbiters are like unhinged
and don't call for like violence on people? Because they do it
all the time. I I would say that actually morally here if when
he says morally I think that removes all non-combatants, all
non like Yeah. non all nonviolent people
You are implying you're you are giving your putting your you're
pushing your morality onto Hassan. I think for I think morally
Hassan views that all of Israeli people are um moral targets.
>> I don't believe he thinks civilians are moral targets
>> didn't he spent days >> so I would say that there's
probably some argument like from a socialist I I'm not well versed
in socialism. Okay. There's probably some argument from like
a socialist point of view that if you live in Israel after the
Palestinians have been like ethnically cleansed out of a lot
of the areas that you're living there under some kind of violence
in general. But like I don't think I think this is like proximate
violence, direct improximate violence, not like the overall violence
of the state and the looming threat of like the Israeli military.
He he he didn't he spend like a didn't isn't there like some
famous clips out there of him spending like ages like justifying
why October 7th had to happen and October 7th is an attack on
essentially just Israeli civilians. >> Do they according
to him like Israeli wait do you think do you think it's crazy
to say that October 7th was definitely going to happen always
under the current status quo? Uh I I I
I I don't think I don't think it necessarily needed to happen.
That's what you're >> I don't think it needed to happen.
I think it it was going to happen. >> But back on maybe
but back on to like my original point, I feel like Hassan has
used has justified
um the attacks on Israeli citizens by before and the October
7th is what I would point to to say that. And if you want to
say that if if Hassan is okay with people attacking Israeli civilians,
he's perfectly okay with them attacking El Klein if she was in
Israel. >> I again, you keep saying in Israel that is clearly
what we've both agreed essentially that there's no way to interpret
this clip that way, right? Given the context of the clip, that's
the whole point is I think I think it's incredibly disingenuous.
I think it's
completely disingenuous to take a streamer who is doing a long
segment, right? a long segment watching a 30-minute video. I
guess he's only five minutes in, but he's doing a long segment
on a video and he is building up like an idea of the story he
wants to tell. And he is explicitly saying like it doesn't matter
how moral you think these people are because if you're western
pig dog conditioning, right? Doesn't matter how that these people
are not allowed to be here. This is not okay. Their with these
people is not okay. And he's like building up this story the
whole time. He's like, no matter what you think, these people
are not okay here. Even if it was your favorite podcaster podcaster's
wife when she went on those rates, right? Like I think I just
don't think there's any way to think he's like doing a direct
call to violence here. I think I think >> because I think
it's the only people who want to strip out the context of what
he's actually talking about and ignore the facts of the matter
are people who do this maliciously. I'm particularly wellversed
in defending against this and like knowing about this because
ironically this is what happens to Destiny a lot, right? Destiny
would get clipped like a 30-cond clip and if you look at like
the four or five minute segment it's like oh it's a totally understandable
position he's doing,
>> Okay. Yeah, sure. I I don't think you should have any
or anything. Just saying that like that's where I would know
this sort of strategy for >> I don't I don't right but
I don't think that's what's going on here. I if I understand
that you're saying that he's done a long form segment I can see
your point. I just don't think that like Hassan and like with
Hassan's views that like cor that sort of like makes sense to
me at all.
You could be may like you've got a point. I'm not saying you're
crazy. I'm not saying your your views are completely out of this
world. I am saying to you though that like it is entirely reasonable
for anyone to think that this is a that almost a call to violence
and that uh and that to to broadly claim that it's claim that
like Assan's an innocent good boy. He's done nothing wrong is
just >> I'm not saying that. I'm not saying anything like
that. I am saying that when you look at the statements made,
it's conclusive that he's not calling for violence against Ela
Klein. And when I say it's conclusive, I mean like there is no
logical way you can interpret his statements and read it and
think that he is calling for violence against Ela Klein. Now,
when you say reasonability, when I say as this as the court transcript
reads, there's 0% chance you could read it this way and then
you're like, "Oh, well, what additional context is there?" Oh,
only additional context essentially in this clip that like continues
to reinforce that he's not calling for direct violence against
El Klein, right? Like it's >> can you sorry can you repeat
that last bit for me one more time please >> that if you
look for additional context to inform the actual statements as
they come out like when you do that it's like oh all of the additional
context you go back and watch this which I'm surprised nobody
has because it's very obvious the whole time what he's talking
about when you go back and watch it it's very obvious how he
gets to this point right and so like I'd say I'd say already
there's no way to say he's justifying uh like violence against
a because he is saying legal and moral where would it legal and
moral to attack or sorry, how could it be legal and moral to
attack a non-combatant in California? >> Right. Okay. You
you rais
and within like the context of like that video, maybe not, but
within Assan's broader context. Yeah, absolutely. you want to
why is he naming someone who's who's not not a who's not a settler
who's not currently member of IDF who's not got like none of
the above criteria
>> and and and and he's and he's bringing them into this
from across the thing from from across the state. It makes no
sense. It's almost like there is additional context you can apply
to this and the additional context the additional context would
be everything we've gone. I think you can add all of the context
in about how Hassan thinks of settlers and still not get past
the fact that he's saying it's legal here. >> You have
to give Hassan
so much charity. >> I have to give him no charity. Just
to be just to be clear, you have to give him negative charity.
You charity. You have to be bad faith.
>> Negative charity. That's what I hear after I try to
do jokes.
>> Okay. Okay. So, so you so you think that it would be
bad faith to apply Hassan's previous statements to this um to
this uh particular uh >> No, but I think his previous statements
his broader statements can't wash out the statements he's making
here, right? >> Like they could only be applied basically
equally like like but it's very clear when he says legal immoral
there's nothing in his anything he said that says it's legal
immoral to attack Ela Klein in California, right? >> Obviously
not legal, >> right? There's no reason to believe that
he could be saying you could attack Ela Klein in California,
right? >> His son's never denounced like attacks on like
um civilians. >> He's never like taken back those statements.
He's he's he's perfectly fine with the attacking um like a civilian
force and and Line's a civilian right now. What more do you want?
It's not. That's like you have to apply like an incredible amount
of charity to get past his like that backlog of like Hassan bad
statements and bad clips and his like bad like uh him talking
about this [__] non-stop.
>> Why Why do you have to get past them? >> Why do
you have to get past them? What do you mean? >> I'm saying
in this in this context, why do you have to get past them? >> I
just don't understand why you have to get past them. Like you
can include them. You can just include them, right? You can include
them. I think so. So, there's probably some way, let's just try
to include the settlers thing. Okay, so he thinks all Israelis
are settlers. Now, we've listened, we've watched this. It's a
it's a documentary about settler violence. I wonder if there's
anything else here. Let's watch through the clip again, right?
We can watch it from here. We'll watch the actual clip and we'll
just see if there's given our like current understanding. I'll
try to maximally apply as best I can the idea that settlers could
be civilians anywhere in Israel. and I'll see if there are things
that he says that make me go, "Oh, wait. No, he clearly doesn't
mean all over Israel, right? I'll try my >> Okay, sure.
Let's do it. >> Or the the Israeli military experiences
in the West Bank is literally legal.
>> here. Hold on. Because you might have said settlers
right off the bat here, >> which is where
it doesn't necessarily mean it'll happen, >> but it shows
the thinking. >> Like any kind of violence that Israeli
settlers or the the Israeli military experiences in the West
Bank is literally legal. Okay. >> Okay. So, he's already
cut it down to just the West Bank,
right? But Israeli settlers, let's think he he means any Israeli
civilian. Let's see if he means any Israeli civilian. >> It
is legal resistance against an occupying military force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. >> So, he says occupying military
force there. Is that enough to escalate civilians in your mind
or not? >> Okay. But in Hassan's mind, when you he's all
Israelis are are um are uh
Um the >> occupying military force
>> that's but that all of Israel is occupied to these people.
You know that >> Occupy milit military force. >> I
am I hear you and I'm saying to you that there isn't that much
of a distinction to Assan like what what he's previously talked
about these hypes of things. You're he's saying military.
>> I I hear what you're saying. >> Uh yeah sure.
So Archandro gives us the point here which I've heard some people
say which I don't know if it applies to or not but that all Israeli
civilians could be considered active or in the military because
they are mostly reserves for the military. Right. >> There
you go.
>> Sure. Well, I'm sorry. Just to be clear, you should
have that argument yourself when you're making this. Okay? I
shouldn't be pulling that argument from my chat for you. You
should you should not be you should not be doing this with like
without that argument in your mind.
>> I'm just saying I'm I Well, thank you. I don't have
evidence that applies to >> I don't have evidence that
applies to Hassan, right? I would need that. But conditionally,
we could just say, let's apply this to Hassan. He thinks all
Israeli civilians are are combatants are are military force
and settlers.
>> Are colonial settlers and are oppressing the Palestinians.
Yeah, >> sure. But this is oppression. This is violent
oppression. I believe this is like violent oppression that requires
self-defense is the context. But again, I'm going to try as best
I can with you, okay? To be in my Hassan bad mindset, okay? Just
keep watching. >> I appreciate that. We need that. We need
>> It is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind
of violence, any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying
force experiences in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally
legal and totally moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't
matter if they're the Ala brigade. Doesn't matter if they're
a part of the Palestinian Islamic Jihad. Doesn't matter if they're
DFlP, PFLP, or even former Fatal militants. Okay? It is perfectly
legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral. Okay?
So, that's another point to say it doesn't matter what these
people look like, right? It doesn't matter what their reputation
is that by virtue of them doing defensive violence in this area,
like defensive uh Yeah. violence in this area, resisting, doing
self-defense, right? They are valid. >> Yeah. Yes. But
once Okay. I I don't want to I don't want to go over the same
thing again, but he did call it like
a douche. Oh, douche. Somebody just said I was being a douche.
Bro, I'm being so nice. [__] you. Um, sorry. Go ahead.
>> Uh, what
me? Um, no, just to just to sort of like break apart what Hana
said. He's calling it and moral. Like moral isn't like it's not
legally and moral. Moral is like he thinks it's moral as well
as separate from like illegal as well. It's legal and moral.
So it's they're like separate things is what I'm trying to get
at. >> Yeah. But but it's a ven diagram. You have to the
only people this applies to are are people that it could be both
moral and legal to attack. Right. So while while those would
be different groups, it's the overlap of those two groups who
are the people who are okay to attack. Right. Like I don't believe
it would be moral to attack non-combatants.
I don't believe I don't I don't think Hassan would think that.
But I guess I would need to see, you know, if I is there really
no clip of Han saying of of course I don't uh allow attacks on
civilians. Is there not a single clip of him saying that anywhere?
Can we really not find a single clip of this guy saying obviously
I don't think you should attack civilians? There's not a single
one. That's pretty bad. Okay, >> I'm Listen, I want to
say there's not, but I don't know that for a case. I don't know.
>> Well, I'm saying there's got to be a clip. Okay, this
is super relevant. Watch this until 242.
uh have >> Oh, this is just baby settlers. I gave him this
at the start of the debate, right? That he thinks that I I gave
this him this at the start of the debate that I think Hassan
has said that he thinks all Israelis are settlers, but I do think
there's a difference in >> the the legal ground to violently
seize back their own homes from these settlers. This is a reality
and that is precisely the reason why they have to exist under
endless occupation in the >> You know what? And that's
why I say if it was settlers that would be a lot more understandable,
but let's not offcate. Okay, I understand what you're saying.
But this dude just called babies >> No, I I understand.
And there are baby settlers as well. But there are baby settlers
as well. There are babies in the settlements. >> But the
babies that weren't >> Wait. Oh, I didn't realize he meant
the actual settlements either. There. >> So, he's not qualifying
all civilians as settlers actually, which I thought he was doing.
He's saying people who are in the who are civilians uh who would
be babies in the settlements. Settlers equals militants. No,
that's that's what uh that's what Ethan says. >> Second
thought is doing. Second thought
>> I know. >> Okay. So, let's
wait. Oh, I know. Hold on. >> Understand? And there are
baby settlers as well. But there are baby settlers as well. There
are babies in the >> But the babies that weren't they were
>> I know. >> Okay. So, so now that we establish
that No, no, hold on. Now that we established that, the the other
school of thought here is that all matter of of uh Israelis living
on uh Israel proper are a a uh that are they also uh doing the
exact same thing in the eyes of some. I I do not agree with that
because I don't think that that is a a reasonable solution and
it's not realistic anyway and that only uh will will lead to
the complete evisceration of Palestinians and and far right is
>> okay. Yeah. He pretty clearly says he doesn't think
that you can count all Israeli civilians as settlers. Then
>> now
that's a stated position and I realize that that stated position
is going to be challenged. Okay. people are going to say obviously
he's just lying here but >> I would I would say that his
like his he he he went hard for um
uh when they attacked like uh on October 7th um and that I think
if if my correct if my recollection is correct he justified the
whole thing saying that you know this was always going to happen
and that you know possibly Israel's fault >> yeah we need
to find the um the Piers Morgan segment where that black woman
was on with him and totally mogged him in terms of calling out,
right? I think we need to find that cuz I'm almost positive that
he said eventually he was like, "No, I'm not going to disavow
because there's like an occupation and a genocide going on."
And then eventually he's like, "Obviously, I don't think you
should attack civilians. Obviously, I think civilian attacks
are bad." I want to say he said that. I'm almost positive he
said it, right? But he doesn't want to. He's like got this whole
cope about how, oh, you shouldn't disavow these groups because
it's like a it's a like misdirect from the crimes of the of Israel.
Yeah. Anyway, so it seems pretty clear from that he he doesn't
consider all Israeli settlers in this context.
So
>> Well, let me see if I can find that uh that October
7th clip. I may have it some here somewhere. >> Sure. Yeah.
I think I I think so here's the problem is a lot of commentators
said, "Yeah, with the status quo as it was, of course there was
going to be more attacks. Of course there's going to be something,
right? The baby settlers thing follows him regardless." Yeah.
I mean, unfortunately,
like that's one of those things where that's something I would
do, okay? I'd get like super and be like very very specific about
something. Well, there would be babies in the settlements when
he's like it's like, "No, Hassan. People are going to read that
the wrong way. Shut up. Shut up. You don't think those settle
you don't you don't think those are valid targets, Hassan? No.
No. Hassan, no.
Hold on, YouTube." Piers Morgan. Hassan October 7th. Piers Morgan
uncensored. There's no way this is it, right? You always have
>> Oh, no. This is This is not it. Hold on. Let me go back
to Piers Morgan
>> I don't think my series has gripped the >> Let
me see if I can find it here just off of the uh full picture
here. We're looking at this. >> We're looking at this.
While you look for your quote, I'm going to look for
>> I think it was this. I'm pretty confident it was this.
We'll see. Crack talked about it. >> Crackhead Barney was
here. It is this one, I believe. So, let me see if I can find
civilians.
Oh, I don't have the transcript open. Jesus. I was like, dude,
I can't find a single comment on civilians. Civiliz civilized
narrative. Civilians
>> Yeah, I know. And that was also unjust and unimaginably
cruel. But of course, the Israel defender is also defending when
it fits your narrative. >> Civilians and hundreds of thousands.
Now listen, listen. Let's get back.
But when it goes, let's refocus the conversation to the points
that you made. Let's refocus the point. You said remind everybody
I'm actually moderating this but that's an interesting point
that Emily just raised Hassan. It does seem that you're very
selective about the violence that you support that when you support
it it's justified when other people use things in a violent way
that you don't support it's unjustified. Seems like it's all
skewed to what Hassan Per thinks. >> Yeah. Obvious not
necessarily just what I think. I think that there are obvious
markers, obvious boundaries. I don't think violence against civilians
is justified. I >> I knew this happened. I knew this happened
the whole time and I had to listen to tell me that he's never
once said it's not okay for them to attack civilians.
I knew he did this cuz I remember reacting to him being like,
"Hassan, why did you just go through this whole thing where you
don't want to denounce? Why didn't you just say that you denounce
attacks against civilians?" Right? He does this all the time.
He does this all the time. And he's got this stupid cope about
how like it's like you can't denounce the group. You should like
you you shouldn't give any ground on this. You should just keep
making the point that like obviously there's an apartheid or
there's a genocide going on. Dude, he's so stupid. But no, no,
no, no. Sorry. I'm just going to say everybody is going to um
everybody's going to say that uh he's lying here anyway, so it
doesn't matter. Go ahead, leader. >> I was I'd been much
more interested to see if he'd be willing to say that on his
own stream. >> Um I would be shocked if he hasn't said
that on his own stream, to be honest. >> If you want to
if you want to listen, I'll I'll take an L and say because I
don't think I don't think I I would like to say that. I don't
think he said that on his own stream. So, you can get a fat W
on with me right now if you can get him you can say get him denouncing
um violence on his uh on his stream. >> If somebody wants
to go look through his film channel, I I feel like I feel like
um he might not have said it on his own stream to be honest with
you.
>> Let's just keep listening.
>> you finish first. No, no, no. You finish first. I was
going to say, yeah, because like the argument for why he's on
here denouncing violence is because he wants to appeal to a more
broad audience so he can bring him in and talk about it. But
like in reality on his like own stream, he'll just constantly
like appeal to the drags and be like the most unhinged [__]
idiot in the world. Apply, you know, to his own fan base because
he can >> Maybe. Yeah. I don't know. I think there's a
reason to when you go on these things be like more optically
sound, right? Not go off in the same way you would on your stream.
And I think everybody does that. Now, it seems like people tell
me he misrepresents his positions that he's like clearly and
I think I don't know where he might have diff or like, you know,
modified his positions over time versus what he's like hiding.
But I I think when you're arguing about specific points, it's
hard to hide your power level when it's like on specific points.
Do you know what I mean? Without just being like a straightup
liar. But then I think that looks bad to your audience. >> I
mean, I I don't know. May maybe I I I have very little trust
in Hassan's like ability to like tell the truth, but I I'm a
hater, so you can you can do it. You can take with that what
you will. I doubt he's I doubt Hassan like says many meaningfully
truthful things to his audience or if he did say lies to them,
I doubt they would ever be called out.
>> Once again, I hate Hassan. So, you can you can take
that as you can take that with a grain of salt salt. >> I
think Hassan's like a hateable person. He's obviously um he's
obviously like uh not a super sincere political actor a lot of
the time. He's a very hateable person. Um anyway, hold on a second.
Are any of these not statements he's made? It's not okay to attack
civilians. Settlers are not civilians. It's okay to attack settlers.
Babies are there. Babies there are settlers. So, I think he said
it's okay to attack settlers. I do think he'd say there are babies
in those settlements, right? I do not think he is avowing I I
my hunch is that he's not avowing those babies. Okay.
My hunch is that I don't know that I can see that. And he says
it's not okay to attack civilians. I do believe. Wait,
would that not all follow though? Yeah, I I think that all follows.
I thought you were saying there's a contradiction there. Hold
on. People are giving me clips of Hassan right now. >> What
would you say to Ethan that said that the ANC punished those
that citizens? First and foremost,
that's literally what I say.
I believe in a truth and reconciliation committee that will appropriately
look at every single person that has intentionally killed a civilian
and punish them with the necessary punishment that they deserve
for doing that. That happens after the apartheid, by the way.
That doesn't happen right now. You can't do that right now. There's
no way to prosecute this. This is something that I've talked
about a lot. The picking and choosing of supporting anti-colonial
Okay. So, I mean that's him saying that people who target civilians
should be punished, right?
>> In a way. Yeah. In a way. Yeah. He's What do you mean
by
>> Oh, he's saying after the war is done once like uh >> Yeah.
I said we'll be punished. Sorry. I didn't say he's like actively
arguing against It's not him actively saying it's totally morally
wrong to attack civilians. He's saying that they should face
repercussions for that. But that's all we have to agree to cuz
that's all I saw there. Okay.
>> Okay. All right. And then there's one more that we got
here. Give me a second. >> Against civilians is is completely
Uh speakers and media representatives
that have uh actively communicated all of the violence that has
unfolded on October 7. I myself have also uh maintained the position
that any kind of violence against civilians is is completely
unjustifiable.
But I think it's more productive to at least be a resilient voice.
>> See, here's the problem. >> Oh, there you go.
Yes.
Well, but and this would have been an honest stream. He streamed
this. But I will say Hassan doesn't do himself any favors. Okay.
Hassan looks like a total
when these are his positions as they stand alone. And then when
he's asked to disavow the Houthies kidnapping the civilians on
the in the Ethan Klein debate, he refuses to he refuses to condemn
the Houthies for doing that. And I think the easiest thing in
the world for him to do there, he has this like weird brain aneurysm
that happens, right?
And he doesn't he doesn't want to do it. I don't know why he
he doesn't even have to condemn the Houthies. You'd say, "I condemn
any attacks on civilians obviously, but you know, blah blah blah
blah blah. Here's some other [__] that happens, right?
Sorry, I'm but I do think like he said all of the things." Okay.
He just disagrees with you on a principle and it seems pretty
the principle seems kind of consistent. It's a principle for
his optics. I don't know why, but in any case, he seems to be
saying, "Yeah, no civilian attacks." >> Yep. Yep. That
was sure. I was wrong on that particular point. That's fine.
>> Oh, give me one second here. I just need to uh I need
to start keeping track of my clips because uh if I let my clips
go, I'm going to um what is this? Hassan
[__]
Uh denouncing civilian attacks.
And this would be also denouncing denouncing civvy
attacks.
Save. Sorry, I need to save all of these for the sake of having
them. Um sorry, this would be I don't have an army of clippers
giving me everything that all the all the thousands of clips
I need to uh you know
>> listen I I think that's totally fine when you say well
if you have a clip of this or if you don't have a clip of this
I think that's perfectly fine I'm not like super or anything
Barry Q thank you for the 18 months thank you so much Barry really
appreciate it buddy thank you thank you thank you thank you thank
you so
again I think um that's totally fine I don't expect you have
a like an army clippers or anything like that yeah it's fine
So, we should go back to this as well. >> Go ahead. >> I
would like to point out though that on October 7th, which was
um uh you know, uh was it October 7th or October 9th? He October
7th, I think, uh Hassan came out with his stream and he basically,
as far as I recall, completely justified the attacks on the civilians
or he didn't or he didn't condemn it then. He was saying, you
know, this did you think this coming out of nowhere? um you know
these attacks it it it would appear to a layman and I think to
I haven't seen like every single hour of his song content but
like from what I saw out of it he was justifying those uh those
attacks then
which is like in stark contrast to what you play just then right
if he's out there like washing the mouth of like an attack on
on uh hundreds of like Israeli civilians
then I agree it's good that he's denouncing
violent against civilians, but you know at the same time he'll
he'll he'll >> send after
you know he'll say
come occupy my strip so we settle and make babies baby that's
that's essentially pointing out okay I think I got you the clip
but uh I sent you the clip in your DMs but that it's no a whole
it's like the Hassan bluster stream essentially where it's like
a clip from that where it's uh you know the I think it was like
the day after >> Yeah yeah sure sure Um, uh, thank you
for the donation. Thank you for the three Hassan after dark.
That was weird, but thank you. And
yeah, send me the clip and we can look at it. I'm just saying
that like I man, it just sucks cuz like that's why unfortunately
we have all the what do you call it? We have all the um additional
context here that makes me feel like
my call on this is just totally correct that like there's just
no way to justify saying he's like calling for violence against
Ela Klein.
Um,
like it seems like outside of the October 7th, he's pretty obvious
about what his opinions are like in terms of attacking civilians
helping you out. Okay. Tenstone's looking for clips on your side.
>> I'm not doing the show.
>> God damn it. Shut up. You're such a loser. Tenstone.
You
for that clip. You very much. What are you doing? >> What
are you doing? Okay. Okay. Hold on. Okay. Hold on. So, you you
feel like you do you feel like you've fallen back from Hassan
is calling for violence against Hila here at all? >> I'm
not as confident on that position, but you know, I'd still I'd
still I'd still say it, but I'm not I'm definitely not as confident
in that position as I was when I came in. >> Okay. We we
have to at some point talk about why you're still confident when
pretty much every preconceived notion you had is >> sort
of been undone. Undone. Yeah. >> I feel like you should
say I do not believe that at all anymore. >> I don't believe
there's a strong I don't believe there's a strong case for it.
I mean, as I said, I Okay. Is that Is that happy? You happy with
that? >> Okay. Yeah, sure. That's good. Thank >> Take
it. >> Bye. Wait. The same moral culpability. But unfortunately,
Kingler, there's just no way to get around the fact that he means
people engaging actively here. There's just no way to get around
that. It's incredibly obvious if you watch the segment that this
is what he's referring to, right? He's literally talking about
this situation. In this situation, if all of the Palestinians
joined up, if all of the Palestinians here joined together and
were violent, they would actually be legally justified in doing
so. Which again, I think there's no reason to assume that's correct
because it's Hassan, right?
>> I'm not doing this. >> You Ozel you. I clicked
on that unfortunately. I clicked on that. Do we have anybody
else who like is going to come and does anybody else want to
talk? cuz I I totally talked to more people, but it seems like
all of the people who had heat yesterday have run. They've all
run many such cases. So many people have heat. So few people
show up. It's sad every time, dude. But oh well. Did you see
him just did you just see him change his mind? Oh no. Leader,
hold on. Hold on. Did leader put something in text? Wait, I didn't
see Did leader put something in text or Yeah, we should we should
be thankful to leader for calling in. Okay. Thanks for calling
in, leader. Again, I think uh I'm saying he changed from 100%
confident to not confident. Sure. Yes, he did. Had his confidence
shaken. All right. I think I think we walked through that pretty
well. And it's like pretty clear what Hassan is saying in this
case in my opinion.
Um no, it's fine, leader. It's fine. Just you changed from like
100% confident $5. So confident. >> This is the real Hen.
I am definitely calling for violence against JSTLK.
somebody of like the Cherry school of thought. Okay. Do you guys
see this crazy [__] You see this crazy Cherry tweeted?
You see this? This is a valid military target. All resistance
against him is perfectly legal, perfectly valid and moral.
Up. It's up. Okay. It's up. Is she wrong? Yeah. Maybe not. Maybe
not. Is there anybody else? Is anybody else going to step up?
I might message Really and just see if he wants to walk through
the clip again. Right. But his his clip's all going to come down
to the audience. And then like that's So here's my thoughts on
the audience thing. Okay, my thoughts on the audience thing are
if you are not directly or indirectly calling for violence. I
don't know what culpability you can have for people taking something
you are not intending to or actually putting out into the ether.
I don't know how much culpability you can have for that. Right?
Like the every argument I see where somebody tries to argue that
somebody's responsible for the violence, they at least have to
implicitly have the intent to cause violence against that person.
Right? That applies to Trump. that applies to every situation
I can think of like this. Uh, is this the penguin that's supposed
to be dressed like uh wearing a Nick Nick Wick Leafit? Yes. Yes,
it is the Nick literally has this shirt. I think it's got I think
it's got colts on it like magnums, you know.
Avatar is too straight to be neck. Okay. All right. I did I did
snap out. I I don't know if I was doing finger guns or not. I'm
pretty good at snapping out finger guns, though. You can hear
the snapping. Let's go. Okay. All right. We're back to Nick for
a little bit, I think. That's cool that we got all these Hassan
clips, though. Oh, wait. I need this clip here.
Uh, hold on. I just do this now when I'm like in the middle of
stream. We're just going to do this now where I pause and I go
and say, um, denouncing violence
against civilians.
I'm just going to do this now and like go and save clips pretty
constantly because it's just good to have these things to build
up my own archive over time. 14-minute H3 vid about his this
latest drama stuff. Oh,
let's go. Okay, we got this as well. >> Sunday afternoon.
I'm Asan [__] put my family in danger. I need your
help to stop this. Yeah, this is this is complete bull. This
complete utter bull. Okay, this guy's full of right now. He's
a lying piece of [__] This did not happen. Filott's
so good. Fil is good. especially if you know how to use it. By
the way, I'm willing to go out and you hear me. I'm willing to
say like what the other side of the argument is. I'll say, "Oh
yeah, well, Hassan looks mighty weird when he won't just denounce
attacks on civilians, kidnapping of civilians, right, in the
case of the Houthies." So, he can say, "I don't believe that's
ever justified." But it's like, dude, why will you not like actually
just say no in the moment? He's got some principle about like
not calling his friends out. He's like the he's like the current
but formerly anti- Nicholas Dioro, okay? where it's like Nicholas
was about accountability for his friends and now it's more about
like no I don't want to do that ever. Hassan will not give accountability
to terrorist organizations. Okay. If you oppose Israel he will
not enforce accountability on you. He will say in other context
where he's not being asked to announce that he thinks it's wrong
but when he when asked to denounce a specific group for the action
he'll go I don't know what you're talking about. No I don't really
denounce them. No I don't want to do that. Is that the best argument
against Hassan? Um, I mean, or you could argue against his audience,
I guess. But again, on the audience front, it's like I don't
know. There's there's just a mix. There's like a co of arguments
there that I don't think necessarily add up to like, oh, he can't
joke about Ela Klein, right? I just don't think it adds up to
that. Uh, have you done your No, we haven't done the Hassan deep
dives yet.
>> My family. >> Let's just start this and after
this we can go back to our uh After this, I'd love to watch this
and then go back to the Nicholas stream. Okay. I think we watch
this, then we go back to the Nicholas stream because I have a
feeling that with the Nicholas stream, we're going to have to
see some we're going to see some stuff here that we're going
to be like, "Hey, Nick, I think you um I think you should uh
be careful on this."
>> Were there
unjustifiable acts of violence that uh civilians had to endure
justics
or at least aesthetically believes in radical politics. You are
not seeing the entire You're not seeing the entire picture. Were
there brutal, unjustifiable acts of violence that uh civilians
had to endure? Absolutely.
Absolutely. I've seen the videos. I know. I saw >> uh I
I saved this clip, by the way. Whiskey the dreads in the back
of the pickup truck. That shit's completely unacceptable.
Okay,
that might not represent the interests of the Palestinians, but
that is violent retribution.
That was an inevitability.
Okay. It's violence is unstoppable in that situation if all you
know is
>> Him giving the ELA take in the past. Well, I sorry I
I'm like aware he would have given this take in the past about
the raid or whatever. He did this in the >> settlement
an abomination. Settlers in the West Bank are religious zealots.
They're monsters. They're genocidal. I've even said the West
Bank settlers are valid military targets when >> Yeah.
He he doesn't he doesn't think that. I don't think because he
claims that but his wife was defending the West Bank when she
well not defending the West Bank but defending Westbank settlers
when she went into Ramla to a raid you know probably not a valid
military target
about that >> you talk about like colonial >> you
know you know you know you know >> bank settlement >> okay
we got anyone else coming in for debates here I'm just I'm continue
to call out if you if you think you got the juice if you think
you can make this Okay, cuz I will I do actually want to argue
with Rally one more time on this and just walk through like exactly
why I think
man I'm trying I haven't thought about how to defend against
his argument that it's just like the audience cuz it just seems
like I I don't know what to do there, right? Then that that argument
probably applies massively across all content creation, right?
And it's like what should be the penalties for that? It's like
a totally different thing.
And I don't know, maybe there's no reason to talk anymore because
he already I think Rey already agreed that there's no way to
say that he's implicitly or explicitly justifying violence against
El Klein here,
right? But the audience thing is like a totally different argument.
Jacob in the Discord right now. Okay, hold on. I'll pull Jacob
in and he can entertain the stream for two seconds. I'm going
to use the bathroom.
Wait, what? Did he actually join up or not? Ozel, are you lying?
Are you lying to me? You lying to me.
You lied to me. You piece of [__] Okay, hold on.
We're going to go% >> This is >> We're doing Ethan
Klein. Okay, we're doing Ethan Klein. We're doing Ethan Klein.
I'll be right back. I need you to >> And I got a text from
a friend with a link to a video in it. And it's a video of my
good old friend Hassan [__] claiming that my wife
Hila would be a valid military target,
PFLP, or even former Fat militants. Okay, it is perfectly legal,
perfectly valid, and perfectly moral. Okay, 100%. This is not
like a black and this is not a gray area. This is black and white.
Okay, it doesn't get more black and white than this. Israel is
in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an apartheid, which
is a crime in and of itself. Israel is doing a genocide in Gaza
and an apartheid in the West Bank. Two crimes in and of itself.
and every every type of armed resistance against both the settlers
and also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't
matter if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these doesn't matter if
>> so Hassan has been trying to claim that he meant only
people during the raid would be legit to uh exact violence on
it. But even if it's true that that's what he meant, why is he
making it sound like she
>> Hold on. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Um, if you hear
the audience, so I understand that you could like hold your audience
to standard. I just don't understand if there's no way to establish
that that's a translation. How in the are we going to actually
How in the [__] are we going to actually decide that
that's what it means, right? Like I don't know if there's any
evidence at all that that doing this that that like this is going
to lead to something or that Hassan believes his audience hears
it that way. I don't think there's any evidence that Hassan's
audience hears it as this is makes Ela Klein a valid target right
now. I just don't think I don't think that's most of his audience.
Okay. I just don't I don't agree with that. I don't think there's
I don't think there's evidence of that. Oh, Hassan is bad. Han
is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Han is bad.
Dude, the Smelly Jean guy just got a trillion. Hassan is bad.
Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Han
is bad. Hassan is bad. Bad bad bad. Assad is bad. Uh, let me
put up I'll do maybe like one more hour for 45 >> escaped
justice. Wouldn't that justify a form of justice? >> 0%.
I sorry it's obviously not going to be 0% but I'm saying like
I don't think a tangible percentage of his audience think like
you could just attack Klein right now. I don't think there's
any even the people who are like oh genocidal
genocidal
what the people have names for her okay nicknames and stuff.
Even if they use those nicknames, I don't think there's any reason
to believe that those nicknames actually lead to her getting
attacked or something. They just have this joke about Ela Klein
being like genocidal, right? Because she went on a raid into
Raala, called it a terrorist city. This catching up to her, right?
It's something she has coming, right? Why even include a specific
person who hasn't served in the military in 20 years? Why does
he mix up past and present tense while he's discussing this?
You know, does
again, if you guys didn't watch, okay, we hit No, he hit the
60. I added the two hours uh soap box. I I added the two hours
for the 60.
the the issue he has to contend with is just like the perfect
example is it's like he is literally going back and forth and
when we watch he is talking about how people interpret them as
okay, right? They interpret they interpret the IDF as okay. They
interpret them as the moral actors there, but they're not. They're
not. They're not. It doesn't matter how moral you might think
they are. Doesn't even matter if it was Ela Klene right now.
Again, non-combat. There's like a whole bunch of arguments you
get into that are deeper from that, but to me, it's like very
clearly just the exact example of somebody who is not engaging
like super aggressively there that just the Israeli he thinks
the Israeli presence overall is illegal. >> Is this a responsible
use of his words and his platform? Don't you think that even
if what you're saying is true and you meant only people on that
raid would deserve violence that invoking a specific person is
really appropriate and true and doesn't that have the >> wait
what a raid would deserve violence that invoking a specific person
is really appropriate and true and doesn't that have the risk
for provoking the >> wait But that's not the that's not
the same thing. That's not even what you tweeted out. You said
he directly called for her death. The He just totally changed
it. Is he correcting? Where's the correction? >> Craziest
people in your audience to think that maybe it would be a good
idea to uh my wife, right? Like what are we talking about, dude?
And also, Ela was a secretary. Okay. him and all of his friends
here. They're trying to invoke the uh image that Ela was somehow
some uh commando that was constantly going into raids and kidnapping
people in their sleep. She was not in a combat role. She was
a secretary. She never fired a bullet outside of basic training.
Okay. And Ela is what these people always dream about. What?
Hold on. I just feel like shouldn't Ethan just contend with the
reality? It's like she went she went on this raid. I understand
what you're talking about. It's bad. What do you want me to say?
She's an Israeli that left Israel.
She's an American citizen of 15 years now, a mother of three.
This is this is the idea of the perfect Israeli, one that leaves.
Despite all that, the son is suggesting that it would be a moral
victory for someone to murder her. This is actually the fourth
or fifth time someone has directly called for violence
>> Not saying it was a moral victory if somebody would
murder her. That's not That's objectively not what he's saying
in any way. Ethan is just lying.
He's just lying. He's just lying. Uh even if she wasn't a consc
conscientious objector, she had no role that was sending her
into the West Bank. She volunteered to go in, right, as a part
of a military raid. >> Me or a Twitch, >> nonparticipant,
non. >> And so far, none of these people have been uh punished
for making these threats. And I don't expect Hassan to meet any
repercussions for this either.
Right. And Hassan himself has a troubling history of calling
for political violence. Here is the infamous tweet he made to
Tom Cotton, a sitting
congressperson.
And no matter what you think about Tom Cotton, what what Hassan
tweeted is mad. This is the gun that a vigilante used to
um
Shinszo Abi, former prime minister of Japan. This is the the
schematic. >> This is an actual coded call to violence.
Yes. Yes. Ethan, you found the difference. He's taking somebody
in the US right now and he is saying kill this like like he's
a landlord or something. >> Addicts the exact gun he used
to this guy. So I mean he is directly suggesting that somebody
make this gun and start killing politicians. There's no other
way to interpret this. >> That's true. Yes. Hassan was
totally calling for political violence right there. And it's
incredibly different from what is happening now.
>> But nobody seemed to really nothing seemed to really
happen from that. This is his most recent one where he's saying
someone should Rick Scott. >> There's about $50 billion
estimated that are lost every year in Medicaid. Just >> Oh,
we're going to we're going to do the whole thing here. This is
not a this is not a >> just in fraud alone. No, >> if
you cared about Med >> and I think I think you this is
like the best filter for people when they listen to this. This
is the best filter by far, right? This one right here. This one
is the one where if you think he's calling for violence here,
you are a like totally dis disinging like it's just obviously
not true. >> Medicare fraud or Medicaid fraud, you would
Rick Scott. Okay.
>> Someone should
there's about $50 billion estimated that are lost every year
in Medicaid just in fraud alone. Nope. If you cared about Medicare
fraud or Medicaid fraud, you would Rick Scott. >> So he's
saying that to who? To the Republican House Speaker
to [__] Mike Johnson. Yeah, Mike Johnson. >> Okay.
You wouldn't make Rick Scott former governor of Florida. Rick
Scott. You wouldn't make him uh a prominent part of the Republican
party. There's about So this is a once again Hassan referring
to a a sitting congressperson looking straight into the camera
and saying
Rick Scott. Of course he'll explain it as Rick Scott uh committed
some Medicare fraud and yada yada yada. But again, he has a massive
platform and a responsibility to choose his words carefully.
He can't be doing this and then also claim that he's against
political violence. He's saying if rep He's literally This isn't
even This is such a stupid bar to hold people to, right? He's
saying if Republicans cared about Medicaid fraud, they would
do something about Rick Scott. They would they would hurt Rick
Scott because Rick Scott's the biggest Medicaid uh fraudster
in like America. It's calling out hypocrisy, right? He's not
saying you should kill Rick Scott. He's saying obviously you
guys don't give a [__] about this because if you
gave any amount of a you'd probably not have as a prominent member
of your party one of America's biggest Medicare fraudsters, Medicaid
fraudsters, whatever the [__]
It's just not it's just not what he's exhibiting. And once again,
there was a recent example of him sitting next to the great Taylor
Loren laughing about how a an official was forced to resign after
receiving death threats. He's in he's he's applauding it. Go
ahead. 874
Belleview Drive and I'm going to kill you with my AR-15. Like
that's what the that's the type of messages they were leaving
in this dude's uh of this dude's office and he's resigning. Like
he's literally this is his last term. So So I think that people
are a lot more radical.
This is >> why did you have to fix his quote for him? Uh,
if Republicans killed or sorry, if Republicans cared about Medicaid,
they would murder Rick Scott. Oh, I guess he said if you cared
about Medicaid, you would kill Rick Scott, right? It's still
the same thing.
He's referring to Mike Johnson. You don't have to fix it. It's
like actually good on its own. If you guys worried about If you
guys were worried about Medicaid, right? Oh, okay. Never mind.
This is a time is an unprecedented time to to really get others
on board uh to explain to them that it's not your neighbors.
It's not like a Guatemalan migrant that is responsible for all
this that you're going through on a daily basis. Not transpersoning.
I think this is a unique opportunity to get even Deborah's
>> You think Hassan cares about Medicaid Medicare fraud?
>> No. But sorry. Yes, for one. Yeah, probably. But two,
he's not the person on TV talking about how they're getting rid
of Medicare fraud. That's that's Mike Johnson in that context.
Mike Johnson's going, "We're doing great things. We've gotten
rid of all of this Medicare fraud, Medicaid fraud, whatever,
whichever medical program fraud." Okay. Obviously, >> on
board with that, like White Wons. And you actually wrote about
this and and uh it was a great video where you talked about,
you know, someone has to do it.
See when I say that everyone knows exactly what I mean that which
which is I think that shows that there is a lot of anger a lot
of resentment and untapped potential uh untapped revolutionary
potential as a matter of fact and it's a great opportunity for
for organizing I think in these unprecedentedly horrible times.
>> So when he says uh someone has to do it he's referring
of course to the act of assassinating the president. Now, I hate
Trump as much as any other lib, but I am not I do not want anybody
to the president. I don't think that would help. I think that
would probably not help. But that's the
>> Oh, crazy point. >> Wait, I didn't even listen
to that. Sorry. I'm still looking around. I'm I'm messaging people
about uh like coming on >> That's what he doesn't want
it to help. He wants he wants uh to collapse society so he can
you know usher in this revolutionary period. Do you guys know
what stochcastic terrorism is? You hear this term thrown around
a lot but let me define it for you. Sarcastic terrorism refers
to the public use of inciting rhetoric often vague or coded by
an influential figure to provoke violence from a pre >> You
know the funny thing here though is do you know what the actual
funny thing here is? This clip came and went because Hassan's
audience did not interpret this as a as a call to violence. Right?
Nobody who watched that stream originally interpreted this as
a call to violence. But 4 days later,
Dan Saltman and Co decided that they were going to take advantage
of Ethan's neuroticism and publish the clip and with him personally,
right? That Hassan was not doing this. It's objective from the
context, the clip in context that that is not happening, right?
He's not calling for violence against Zila. It's not even possible
that you could think he's calling for violence against Hila.
He he's saying that these Palestinians have the right in area
A to rise up against the IDF. That is and and settlers. That
is the context under which he's speaking. Okay.
So nobody nobody could possibly interpret it that way. But a
bunch of people who want internet points, who want to continue
an internet war published this clip to with Ethan, right? And
they know Ethan's gonna go and and lose his mind about this.
And they don't care about Ethan at all, right? They don't care
about him at all. >> Predisposed individual or group
able to plausibly deny
for the resulting violence. There's a form of political >> Oh,
I should say uh I don't have proof that Dan was the person who
clipped that fully. Um I do know Dan made the more incendiary
clip. So I should say I don't have proof of that. Uh I should
walk back that allegation. I suspect Dan, but I do not know for
sure and would not hold him responsible for it. There we go.
We fixed it. We fixed it. >> But rather a calculated use
of language that is statistically likely to incite violence in
a suspected individual.
This is when I read this, it kind of blew my mind cuz this describes
to a exact does Ethan not think that him lying about what Hassan
said, does that not actually stochastically increase the chance
of somebody Hassan? Does he not know that Destiny came out and
said somebody should kill Hassan? Does he is he really gonna
raise the temperature right after Destiny said Hassan should
be he's gonna go live and just raise the temperature like this?
You see how gay this is? By the way, we all see how disgusting
it is, right? How it's like totally totally disingenuous. Can
it just be a mis uh it could be Billy Joe Bush, but Nicholas
already tweeted out the full context. Nicholas already tweeted
out the correcting this and I know he follows everything Nicholas
does. Okay, I know he follows everything Nicholas does. act t
the kind of language that the pattern of language we're seeing
Hassan deploying this is it you know in his own words by the
way and very ironically
um Hassan said this to me when I was on his podcast I think he
is a narcissist I mean when you watch that video the narcissism
rage at Coffeezilla was insane because his video was just >> I
mean it's it's it's posturing man >> well thanks CN Katrina
CN Katrina thank If you're going if you're going to court was
so wrong about every >> jester ty hop on the stream. Hop
in the cord, bro. Hop in the cord. Get on here. Let's go. Hop
in the court. You disagree. That's what this stream's all about.
Call in right now. Hop in the cord. Come defend your point. Let's
go. You believe you can believe you. Sorry. You believe you can
defend this. I want to see it. I want to see it now. >> Yeah.
But it it listen if we've survi if we've learned anything about
the court of public opinion it is deny deny deny if wait I just
want to make it clear that anybody who believes in this stocastic
terrorism argument would have to agree that to a lesser extent
at minimum to a lesser extent possibly as much but in a lesser
oh you're here
>> no wait you actually joined
donated $3. His head is so damn small. What the hell? >> It
really is a tiny little head, isn't it? Let's go, Jastaster Tai.
What's up, man? How's it going? Welcome to the stream. >> What's
going on, man? >> What's going on? So, you think Hassan
was What What do you think Hassan did here? Hold on. Let me get
my uh notepad up and I'll start walking. What do you think? What's
the claim? Or do you want me to make my claim? Which one? >> Uh,
I can go first. Um, I think it's pretty obvious that Hassan was
like implying at the very least that Hilo would be a valid military
target or
um, yeah, that's pretty much it. >> So, you think that
he was implying Oh, apparently you're quiet. Hold on. Let me
see if I can turn you up. Okay, I turned you up a little bit.
Okay. Um, Han is implying Ela is a valid military target. Do
you want to be any more specific on that? that he's she's a valid
military target um when engaging in military conduct when she's
staying at home with her kids in or do you just like >> Uh
I don't know. I'm just I'm just looking at like what Hassan said.
So he said that
>> the I guess the favorite podcaster's wife, he was saying
that she was uh the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank.
Like he mentioned that in Hila like right after that. So I don't
know why he would do that if that's not like an implicit
um justification for any violence to her. >> So this is
happening in area A. He views or believes that under international
law, all raids into area A are illegal. That Israel, any Israeli
military member who's engaging in security operations in area
A is a valid target, could could be attacked and is not illegal.
Okay, that's what he believes.
So do you think that he could possibly be saying that? Do you
think it's possible he is saying okay it would be legal to attack
Ela Klein in California because he says as a part of this that
it was both it would be both moral and legal to do so to >> Was
she was she was she part of the occupying military force that
is in the West Bank right now or >> yes she was a part
of the IDF. She went on a raid the West Bank.
>> Okay. So why is Hassan making a claim about current
day? because he is saying no matter how innocent you think these
people are, no matter how much you think that what they're doing
is legal. Nope. Doesn't matter if they're a part of that occupying
force, they are a valid target, including this person. This person
would also be a valid target. So, it serves two purposes. One,
to take a shot at Ela Klein because Ethan Klein's continued to
do like content on him, like negative content, right? >> And
two, >> that uh
Oh god, I just realized that arguing this against certain people
would be very easy. Um, so and two, it it perfectly maps on to
what he's talking about, right? Like that is somebody who would
have been a valid target during those operations. >> You're
presenting it like it's mutually exclusive. I don't understand
why. Also, didn't he >> because he says it would be legal
and >> Okay. So, she's just >> Is there any way to
interpret Is there any way to interpret Elila Klein right now
where she is as it would be legal to attack her? Do you believe
Hassan's interpreting it that way? >> No, that's not what
I said, though. >> Okay. But that's what he's saying. So,
are you just not going to engage with what he said? >> Did
he say that? Did he say that you shouldn't attack people who
are passed in the military
of IDF, but if they're in California, they're fine or like what
is the >> He said he said attacking these people is both
moral like uh it's justified moral. It's like a valid action.
Klein as an example.
>> Yes. Yes, it doesn't matter what how could he use how
could he use Ela Klein in the modern day where she is in California
as an example if he says legal. So you if if you're saying that
then you would have to believe that he thinks it's legal to murder
Ela Klene in >> No. But why would he use her as an example
at all? >> That is that is just true based on the statement
because there is a context under which there is a context in
the past where she would have been a legal target to him >> where
he thinks that. Okay. >> So, if he didn't think he was
a legal if he didn't think she was a legal uh target now, then
why invoke her name at all? Like, it's like I feel like >> because
he is because she is a perfect example because he's watching
a documentary on the IDF on IDF overreach in area A and she is
a part she went on a raid that he believes is IDF overreach in
area A. So, it's a relevant example.
>> uh and
it's funny and taking a shot back at the clients who are doing
content. Well, Ethan's doing content attacking him. So, there
are the two reasons. So, if you ask me again why I think that,
it's going to be that same answer every
>> It It doesn't contradict the the idea that he was saying
that she would be a military target. You don't just I seriously
doubt that if you >> Why doesn't it contradict it? >> I
was going to say cuz I don't think that just because you stop
being a part of the military that I don't know exactly what the's
full politics are on it. I I would doubt that just because you
stop being a part of the military, you just like retire or something
that you're not no longer a valid military target. So unless
>> this is only in the conduct only in the cont uh sorry
context of military operations and and armed conflict in area
A. That's what he's watching a documentary on that. There is
no possible way you could like get outside of that context because
that is the only context under which it is fully legal to just
attack the Israeli military out of >> I understand you're
giving me the context. The context just doesn't contradict what
I'm saying. it like >> it completely contradicts the it
completely contradicts what you're saying and it's what he's
talking about leading up to the clip. >> So he's literally
talking about it leading up to the part that got clipped. >> So
it's not reasonable to assume that he was talking about Hila
Klein even though he didn't give any like u because of the >> Oh
I'm not talking about Hila Klein like right now. I'm just talking
about like if she was in the military before >> that the
rest of his qualifiers disqualify her from from saying her right
now. >> You didn't give that qualifier though. That's what
I'm saying. >> He didn't give the explicit qualifier on
>> He's saying in the past she would have been a valid
target. He didn't give any explicit qualifier, right? But the
qualifiers he does give rule her out as she exists today. >> It
doesn't. It just can't like it doesn't. There's no reason to
bring it. >> Absolutely does. It absolutely does because
there's only one context under which he's literally said multiple
times in this video. Okay. In the video he's watching, he says
right now these Palestinians in this video we're watching actually
it would be legal for them to attack the IDF who are [__]
with them right now. actually in area A this is all illegal right
they the Palestinian authority the people with the authority
here the all Israeli like IDF operations here are illegal which
I don't even think is true I think they can coordinate with the
PA and and be there right but that's what he's saying so he's
saying it would be legal for them to attack so that is very very
a very specific context he's talking about the whole time >> okay
I'm I'm not if you think I'm saying that he's like calling for
her to something that happened to her today I'm not I'm just
saying that >> when is he calling for something to happen
to her? >> No, I'm saying if you think that's what I'm
saying. I'm not saying that. I'm just saying the idea that um
she participated in a raid
uh in the past would make her a valid military target today because
she probably they still cuz even um his whole community just
doesn't like the fact that she did that in the first place. She
never like condemned it or anything in their >> So she
So he says it would be legal, right? We can just go listen to
it. Let's listen to uh where do we want to go here? We're not
going to go with this clip. We're going to go 3 hours 5804. This
one is where we Let's listen to the clip. Okay, we'll just listen
to the clip from the beginning and >> we'll walk through
and we'll see what we >> Or the the Israeli military experiences
in the West Bank is literally
>> the violence they experience in the West Bank. So already
we're talking about violence in the West Bank, right? Do you
need me to back it up or
>> do you do you trust me on that? Do you need me to back
it up that he's saying uh any violence towards illegal settlers
or military in the West Bank is legal? Do you disagree on that?
>> Okay. No. >> Legal resistance against an occupying
military force. I cannot
I cannot
>> So against an occupying military force, what do we think
that means? >> The force that's currently occupying the
West Bank in area.
>> Okay. Is Ela Klein a part of that force?
>> No. Oh, that's why I thought it was really weird that
he would just invoke her name or imply her name. >> Was
she a part of that force? >> Uh, I don't think so. >> So,
she went into Raala on a night raid. Now, it is ticky tacky.
Okay, broadly considering her like a IDF commando or something,
that's insane, obviously. Okay. But she did in fact volunteer
to go on a night raid into Raala, which is also an area A.
>> Okay. So, she was in the past, right? So he's he's literally
in the context of these Palestinians in the documentary I'm watching
in area A could violently rise up if they wanted to and it would
be perfectly legal. So he's clearly talking about a contextual
situation that excesses
Ela Klein as she is today. >> But you only invoked her
name because she just happened to participate in a raid. I guess
like
>> the idea that this isn't like this like >> guess
what >> to be.
Yeah. So that's one of the two reasons. Do you know what the
other reason is? >> Is there a reason that What's the other
>> He's a petty [__] who's talking.
>> Okay, that's these things aren't mutually exclusive
though, so I don't know why. >> But it is mutually exclusive
for him calling for violence against her. We're saying she's
a valid military target in the US anywhere. The context is if
you are participating in the military force in area A, then you
are a valid target,
>> Yeah. But it doesn't disqualify what I said. it. So
your your argument is so let me see if I could get your argument
precisely because this is what um
um is a valid military target. Let's make it more precise for
her
is still a valid military target
for her previous
service in the IDF where she entered Ramala
as a part of an IDF raid. So this is what this is what you're
saying, right? Whoops. Oops.
Would you say that's accurate? That's more >> Yeah, because
the his community still criticizes her today for participating
in that raid. Plus, they don't.
>> Well, well, they do, but I don't think that I don't
think I see any evidence that they think she's a valid military
target for that. So, okay. Uh, it's not
>> It's not implicit in talking. I'm sorry. Those are like
very different things,
>> it's not talking [__] if they genuinely
believe that she's immoral for participating in whatever raid
they think that she did or whatever. >> Do you think it's
wrong?
>> Do you think it's wrong to believe she's immoral for
participating in that raid? >> Not necessarily.
>> Okay. Then what's the problem? >> If you're because
if you're justifi
Well, if you think it's um immoral that she participate in the
raid, then one can argue that you think that she's an indefinite
military target.
Does it matter if she moves to California or Louisiana or the
Pacific Ocean? Like, it doesn't matter cuz I still criticize
her for that today even though it happened in the past tense
or >> So, you think you can't criticize her for that without
thinking she's a valid military target? >> That's not what
I said. I said that the community currently criticizes her um
>> even though it happened in the past. So, it's reasonable
to assume that they're um that they would just think that she's
an indefinite military target um if the for whatever reason >> because
she because they don't view um the Israeli like occupying force
legal. It's not legal. It's it's invalid. It's immoral. Right.
>> Um but they're talking Hassan keeps saying under international
law they could do this, right? I believe this is a misunderstanding
but this is his understanding is uh is that he thinks under international
law any violence you would do to people who are militarily occupying
area A illegally that would be legal under international law.
What attacks could there be on Ela Klein outside of that area
that could be >> Are there any? >> Uh no. >> Okay.
Why do you believe that they would interpret that? Why is Hassan
differentiating between like area A and talking about area A
specifically if he thinks all violence against anybody who's
in the IDF or his community thinks this is legal? Why is he >> Why
is he differentiating between current day operations? >> Why
is he saying that this is legal under international law? What
wouldn't he just say that like any attack anywhere in Israel
would be valid under international law? >> I don't know
why he's saying under uh international law. I don't really understand
why he's saying that cuz I >> It's because it's in area
A where Israel is not supposed to have security >> Not
supposed to be there at all, but >> they're not supposed
to have security authorization. I believe the PA allows them
to go in because I think they um
I believe the PA allows them to go in because technically like
there could be terrorists and in area A and the PA isn't going
to stand in the way of Israel like apprehending people. But I
I don't know how that relationship works necessarily. I think
I think technically the PA can grant them authority to >> Yeah.
I don't I don't know if the PA are allowed weapons to be honest
with you. So like there might be other situations where the IDF
comes in. In any case, but this Hassan's understanding is that
it's legal to attack them. What? So I'm just going to keep we
can keep playing it. Um we've gotten through these guys.
>> We're going to get to the former terrorist part. >> It
is legal resistance against an
>> it doesn't really change. >> No, we do have to
keep playing it because we have to hear the final wording. Trust
me, we're getting there. We we'll get there. force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying force experiences
in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally legal and totally
moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't matter if they're
the Alaka Brigade. Doesn't matter if they're a part of the Palestinian
Islam. So he's saying anybody who resists the IDF is legal when
the IDF is occupying these areas. Now I think it's probably to
think that like any attacks under international law when there's
like war declared is okay. I I think there's probably some like
difference there, but I'm not exactly sure what it would be.
And he's definitely not playing around with any of the nuance.
So um I I prefer to focus on the West Bank since that's the what
the documentary is on. And uh realistically like including Gaza,
there's like some slightly different it doesn't really serve
the conversation on whether or not we would attack because she
didn't do service in the Gaza strip anyway. So I'm just going
to skip past that. But it is basically the same >> Islamic
jihad doesn't matter if they're DFLP, PFL.
>> They think uh that he would think that anyone that participated
in the
army
is a valid military target now and forever.
>> Why? uh because one he's going to say when he actually
describes who could be attacked he's going to say it would be
legal to attack them right he keeps talking about legal attacks
legal and moral legal and moral both of these things um there
is no legal international law that lets you just attack anybody
who is former IDF anywhere in Israel that that doesn't exist
that's not real >> so it's just weird to invoke someone
who's not currently part of the IDF then I think it would be
reasonable to assume that that's what he means because he's playing
very he can say the word legal it's not reasonable It's not reasonable.
You can't just say it's reasonable and then not actually follow
what he says. Like the the logic of what he says. >> I
am following what he says. He's using you're you're looking at
the word legal, but he's not giving a context for anything. Uh
>> okay. Well, we we'll just we'll >> Hela Klein.
>> There's no reason to bring up Hila Klein and then also
say like, oh, he was just >> wait, is there a context?
Is there some situation where Elila Klein would have been a legal
target? >> Yeah.
Is that source is that actual situation a source of like contention
and and strife between these two >> Is that a source of
strife? Yeah. Between the two communities. Yeah. >> So
it is both applicable in this case is both applicable in this
case and like a meme that he can bring up to these >> Okay.
And maybe he just really wants uh really believes that anyone
who participates in the army is a valid military target now and
forever. like none of these things are mutually >> seems
to that they are mutually exclusive because he's literally watching
this and talking about area A. The whole idea is that IDF the
IDF is not supposed to have anything in area A. He just watched
an IDF soldier like destroy some old lady's storefront in Gaza,
right? Like kick over their fruit stand or something and start
crushing their
that's what what sends him on this entire rant. That's what the
entire context is before this. He's literally talking about this
area. Um he and he doesn't believe, by the way, he doesn't believe
all Israelis, just to be clear, he doesn't believe that all Israelis
are valid military targets either. He's said as much multiple
times, >> just the ones that participate in the
>> but right
>> uh that so in this case, I believe he is obviously talking
about people who are actively participating in occupying the
West Bank, specifically area A. That's why he says to begin with,
um any kind of violence that illegal settlers or military experience
in the West Bank is legal. any kind of violence that the IDF
experiences in Gaza is totally legal and totally moral resistance.
Right? These areas are occupied illegally. I the Gaza one I'm
not totally sure about, but the West Bank is occupied illegally.
Right? >> So that's why he's saying it's illegal. So if
he believed it was anywhere or anybody who' ever served in the
military, why is he saying in the West >> Why is he saying
like he says in the West Bank like your favorite um podcaster's
wife? Why why are we just leaving that part out or >> We
didn't get We didn't Hold on. We didn't get to that part yet.
I'm saying he is clear. >> That's literally the next >> those
are the next words after that West Bank statement. Yeah, it was
like the like in the same sentence. >> So, no, we went
through him talking about any kind of violence that settlers
or military experience in the West Bank is legal, right? That's
that's how it starts off. That's about a minute out from the
actual quote
>> or 45 seconds. There's multiple instances of it. So,
we can keep we can keep listening. But he's already said he's
already restricted this to saying I'm talking about legal violence
in the West Bank in area A, right? And then he's going to continue
to say legal violence, legal legal resistance, legal resistance,
morally correct legal resistance. Right? There's only one area
where that could possibly really be
>> Focus on this one area. I don't understand. Like he
goes on to give an example of Hila Klein
like who >> So I'm going to ask you again. >> Why
did he give an example of Hila
>> Because she participated
in the IDF
>> Yes. Why does he say it's legal to attack her >> because
she participated in a raid? >> No, sorry. [__]
[__] with
He doesn't say it's legal to attack her. Just to be clear, he
doesn't say it's legal to attack her. >> He's saying it
would be legal to attack her in that situation. He is saying
it's legal by by saying it's legal. He's filtering out modern
day Ula. Whoops. >> How do you know that? >> Because
it's not legal to attack Klein in California. You can't murder
Ela Klein in California. Did he say that it's legal to attack
someone
>> in the military
>> in the in the area? Yes. In Oh, >> I don't know
if he's ever said it's legal. I don't think he would claim it's
legal under international law to attack any IDF soldier anywhere.
>> Okay. It is perfect.
I I feel like you're just trying to make >> it totally
it totally does because so he can't possibly be talking about
El Klein in the modern day because it's not legal to attack Ela
Klein in the modern day. >> So why is he talking about
her past
>> Because he's using it to illustrate >> he's using
it to say that no matter how safe you think these guys are, no
matter how much you think they might be in the
>> doesn't matter if they look cute, if they're okay, like
it doesn't matter who they are, they are illegally occupying.
They that by being there, by virtue of being there in a security
um >> in like a security role, it's illegal
>> And so he's saying even even up to and including when
Ela went on that raid. >> Yeah. For >> you're just
it is what it feels like you're just justifying
the statement um that Hassan is making. But the the idea that
like it's not even reasonable to assume that that's what he meant
just really weird. It it feels like we're doing like a lot of
we're playing with time for no real reason. We're just saying
like, "Oh, well, in the past,
there is a there is a reason." Hold on. There is a reason though.
>> But there there is a reason >> to play with that
to go back in time, right? We've already discussed what the reason
is. >> Yeah, I agree. I agree why you want to go back in
time, but that's not a that's not a defeater to what I'm saying.
>> It's not a defeater to what I'm saying.
It is a total defeater to what you're saying. The defeater of
what you're saying is that he says it would be >> He cannot
be talking about it, right? He would not say that. He is saying
it's legal in a specific context in the West Bank. Ela is neither
in the West Bank nor in the IDF. Right. >> I just said
he's implying that it's valid to attack her. >> But if
it's not even if it's not even legal, then
then what's the
what's the argument? We're going to >> He's not implying
it would be valid to attack her. He's in the modern day. He's
saying it would have been valid to attack her in this situation.
>> Even I think it's just like >> you you just keep
saying I don't know. You just refuse to engage with logic, right?
You're just refusing to engage with the way the English language
works. >> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I am engaging directly. You're saying,
>> You're not engaging with saying. That's the problem.
>> Engaging with he's saying as well. It sounds like it's
justification for why you would attack someone. You're pretending
that it's mutually it's not mutually exclusive, which is fine.
But I guess my bigger issue with this is the idea that it's just
like super unreasonable and there's like this lie about what
Hassan's saying is just like kind of just bad faith in my opinion.
>> Wait, there's a total lie about what he's saying. People
are saying he directly called for Ela to be killed.
>> Okay. Oh, >> that's a obvious lie. >> Asminold,
Techone, Dan, they're all saying they're all just obviously lying,
right? Nope, they're not saying indirectly. They're saying he
directly called for her to be kicked. I said like I'm saying
sarcastically. Oh, I guess indirectly I guess like I guess we
play like we play the difference between like directly and indirectly.
We pretend like implications don't exist.
>> There isn't an implication here either.
>> There is. I think so.
>> We'll just keep listening. We'll just keep listen
>> just keep walking through it. We can just keep walking
through it and we have to actually deal with what like he's saying
in terms of English >> valid and perfectly moral.
Okay. 100%. This is not like a black and this is not >> So
we both agree that he's talked about a very specific context,
a very specific action that puts you up as a legal target, right?
Is the West Bank. It is when you're a part of an unoccupying
military force, right? >> Gray area. This is black and
white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and white than this. Israel
is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an apartheid,
which is a crime in and of itself. Israel's doing a genocide
in Gaza and an aparttheite in the West Bank. Two crimes in and
of itself. And
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. The violence that the Palestinians
engage in in an act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal, definitionally legal. >> So,
is there any way that Hassan could possibly mean attacking Hila
right now when he says the action would be definitionally legal?
Has he not filtered out in the modern day versus the raid he
referenced participated in the raid? Is there any possible way
he could be referencing Ela in the modern day here
in terms of what this statement means? In terms of how you read
the transcript, right?
>> Is the transcript on screen? >> No, but we just
listen to what he said. >> Okay. Um, is he referring to
modernday Hila?
No, I guess not. According to your logic, cuz you need to say
it in plain English. Um, but no, like you don't need to reference
someone. >> Hold on. The implication is these Palestinians
are justified morally and legally to attack this person. How
could there possibly be another implication? Where's the other
implication? >> You repeat that.
>> He's saying it's both moral and legal. We both agree
that it is not legal to attack Ela Klein in California today.
>> Did did Assan directly say
the California whatever you're saying? Like here here's so let
me answer your question. No, he didn't. But I don't I don't know
why we're playing this like game of oh well he's not referring
to modernday
present day future Hila but he's referring to past Hila
who
participated in these raids who would have been >> which
he says directly yes >> she says what >> he says
directly who participated in these raids >> he said it
doesn't matter if if it's your favorite
um podcast or whatever
>> podcaster's wife who partic participate in these raids.
>> So, any action against the occupying military force,
the Israeli occupying force is justified. Doesn't matter who
it is. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcaster's wife.
Is she a part of the IDF currently? >> No, but it doesn't
have to be. That's not my argument. You don't need >> That's
what Hassan's saying directly, right? partite in the West Bank.
Two crimes in of itself and every every type of armed resistance
against the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force in
the she settler is she a settler or a part of the Israeli occupying
force in the West Bank? No, but my argument is that for Hassan
to say that while there's an occupying military force today,
like it's pretty fair to say that he was implying that she would
be a valid military military target. It doesn't matter if it's
feasibly possible to find her, >> but he's already she's
he's already explaining it, right? He's already explaining if
that violence done to these two groups. She's not in those two
groups. And then he references a time when she was in those two
groups. So, it's pretty obvious he's saying when she was in those
two groups, right, when she was a part of those groups, when
she was a part of this, that that's when she would be a military
target. Yes.
>> And there's actually no other possible way to read this.
We've actually ruled out what you've said where she could still
be a military target because she's not a part of those groups.
It is not legal to attack her. There's no way you could possibly
think he's referring to her in modern day, right? Because he
has explicitly ruled out modern day Klein. >> He hasn't
explicitly. But no, the idea is for But I already ruled it out
myself. Like, no, I don't think he's talking about >> if
I if I tell you that I'm thinking of a number between 6 and 8
exclusive, have I ruled out every number but seven? Have I explicitly
ruled out every number but >> No, you implied it. >> Okay.
All right. I think we're done >> That's what those words
are. Sorry. That's what those words mean. Like, >> okay.
Okay. Um, I guess there are things that like you obviously like
auto like there's no other way. To me, an implication is something
that has to be inferred in some way, but All right.
That's what you did. Okay. I just think that the idea that um
it's not even reasonable is like pretty terrible. >> Wait,
hold on. I can actually I can even just give you that if that's
how you want to see it, that I'm not like explicitly ruling it
out. But then you would argue that there is no way he could be
implying it either because by implication he has ruled her out,
right? So neither explicitly or implicitly. You actually made
it better for me. Thank >> No, I didn't cuz he literally
invoked her name. But evoked invoked whatever it when he when
he invoked her name in the context of her past raids into this
exact area. You think he was saying uh everybody is a valid target
here uh and it would be legal to attack them. Plus, you can legally
attack Ela Klein in California. You think that's what he >> Why
you keep saying in California like that matters? He said it doesn't
matter. So, if we want to like hyperfixate on >> said doesn't
matter. What do you mean if he said it doesn't matter? >> He
said it doesn't matter if it was your favorite um let's just
say Heliloc. It doesn't matter if it was a Hila client um who
participated in these raids. It's legal and all that good stuff.
That's what he said. >> Oh yeah. >> The idea that
the idea that it's >> Wait, what is that? If I say if I
say huh I'm
I'm uh I'm fighting the next I'm fighting the next Manchester
United fan I see. Doesn't matter if it's like um doesn't matter
if it's Brock Lesnar. Okay, Brock Lesnar's a Manchester United
fan. Am I saying Am I saying anything there that um that like
in adds additional context? It's saying up to and including that
guy, right? But it's not he's still a Manchester United fan.
I'm not saying well I would add an extra person. It wouldn't
make that that would make no sense if Brock Lesnar was not a
Manchester United fan. Right. >> If he wasn't a uh a fan
at all in his >> like you say up to an like I don't care
if it's Brock Lesnar. I'm fighting the next Manchester United
fan I I find. >> Sure. If he was ever a fan then >> doesn't
matter. Okay. Hey, what if I said, "Okay, Brock, here's here's
a here's an exact here's an exact one to one. Okay, I'm fighting
the next Manchester United fan I see. Doesn't matter if it's
Brock Lesnar when he was a Manu fan in 1998. I'm fighting that,
right? It doesn't make sense. But yeah, just I don't know if
it's a good comparison,
but >> I would say the unfortunate thing for this is it
happens to make perfect sense in this context, but nobody knows
the context that it's like an illegal raid into Manchester or
sorry. Oh my god, an illegal raid into the West Bank into area
A, right? Oh god.
>> I just Yeah, I don't Man, >> I I think you pretending
that it's like super unreasonable everyone's lying that has this
opinion is pretty weird. Oh, anybody who's saying he's directly
calling for her to be killed is just lying explicitly. >> I
didn't say directly, but I don't know why I keep say adding that
like it's >> because that's what Asmin Gold said. That's
what Techton said. That's what Destin
said.
Sorry. I'm talking about the broad public perception of this
and how it was shaped by certain people who are am I the broad
public perception? Are you >> No, but I'm telling you why.
You said you said I don't know who's saying that. I'm telling
you who said it. >> I don't care. >> Okay. Okay.
Um, >> I'm just like like I like like I said like what
I said was
you don't need to change what I'm saying just because it's >> Go
ahead. >> What I said was
>> that it's reasonable to assume that this was he was
saying. Did he directly call for it? No. Did he >> Why
is it Why is it reasonable when it's explicitly ruled out? Sorry.
When it's I Yeah. Yeah. When it's explicitly ruled out like it
he's calling you're saying he's it's reasonable to assume he's
calling for it when it's explicitly ruled out by the criteria
he sets.
>> So why would it be reasonable if it's explicitly ruled
out by the criteria he
>> You know what a simile is?
>> Okay. So when he's using like as a comparison for Hila
Klein and the occupying Israeli force, I think it's fair to assume
that he's saying that she's part of that. Wait, hold on. Can
we listen to it again? Because I don't know when he says like
here >> it doesn't change anything but >> podcasters
like wife that partic >> so
is that sorry >> like uh is was that the like right there?
That's not the like, is it for the simile? >> Both the
settlers is also you just told
>> occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if
it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife.
>> Do sorry the like uh there that is him doing a simile.
You think you think that's him making a comparison to the Israeli
occupying force when he goes like uh >> are you like playing
games right now or I don't understand. That's what a simile is.
He's making a comparison
>> like in between the like. >> Hold on. Hold on,
hold on, hold on. No, no, hold on, hold up. Let's just let's
figure out what's on the left hand side real quick. >> Also,
the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh
>> So, he's doing favorite podcasters is on the left side.
Like a So, he's comparing favorite podcasters
possessive to like a wife. So, he's comparing Ethan Klein to
like a Hila. No, what I was going to say is he's comparing the
Israeli occupying force
to he >> But he didn't do that, right? >> Was in
the middle of that. >> But he didn't do that, right? >> He
did. That's >> objectively didn't do that. So when what
what was on the left side of the like? Uh directly before. So
it's favorite podcasters like >> Why are you saying directly
before? Why does it have to be directly before? It's just it's
part of the sentence. >> Okay. You know what?
Actually, if you just tell me you're trolling, you're actually
very compelling. You're incredibly compelling if you're just
>> I think you're trolling me. Like I'm asking you what
a simile is and you're trying to be like like ah like a like
what are we doing? >> Like I just I said that >> so
just to be just to be really obvious here just to be obvious
here. He is obviously just using a filler word because he's trying
to think your favorite podcasters
>> um wife. It would be no different what he's doing. The
like um is no different from um wife, right? He's just doing
a filler word. >> That's why he compared her to the >> He
has to be trolling me, right? You You absolutely have to be trolling
me right now. This is [__] crazy.
>> I'm trolling because you don't have anything else to
say, >> dude. This is crazy. >> And we're doing
formative voices.
>> Hold on. You You think he's actually So go ahead with
this sentence structure. You believe you believe it's more likely.
You believe >> I'm playing it. >> Which is a crime
in and of itself. Israel's doing genocide in Gaza. Listen listen.
We're just playing it. I'm not pausing it. I'm going to pause
it after he finishes saying uh wife and then I will I'll let
you go. >> An apartheite in the West Bank, two crimes in
and of itself and every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. So you cook on what the simile is here. >> I
wish there was like a I just did it. Whoops. I wish there was
like a transcript of a YouTube video or >> Why did you
just compare
your wishes and a transcript for a YouTube video? >> Got
me. He literally I did get you though, right? It's like the exact
same >> No, because Oh, I'm sorry. So, was Hila never part
of the army or was he just making a weird He just brought her
up in in relation to the
uh IDF for no reason. Maybe I'm just confused. Maybe I just Maybe
I'm actually Maybe Destiny did rake my brain. Who knows?
>> I don't even know if you're a Destiny fan. I'm not assuming
you're a Destiny >> I'm I'm just reading the chat. Sorry.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I wouldn't assume you're a Destiny fan.
You could easily come from like Ice Boseidon or any of these
other
>> Lots of people here from lots of different places. >> Um
I don't know why we're pretending that he isn't comparing her
to the occupying Israeli. That's what the entire discourse is
about. >> The Palestinian I don't know.
>> Hold on. Matt Slice has got a time stamp for us here.
Hold on. Hold on. Bob,
listen to my words. Listen to my words.
>> I have no issue with someone as long as they have recognized
their mistakes. As long as they recognize that that was wrong.
What I take issue with is consistently defending Israel.
You have also participated in the defense of Israel. It makes
no sense. You're inconsistent. You say it's a genocide, but people
can't resist militarily. You say it's a genocide, but all of
the people who are >> Did you I feel like Matt Slice, you
gave me this, but then this is not even close. Unless I just
straight up wasn't listen. I wasn't listening at the beginning.
I was looking at something
>> Did she Did he say she wasn't a valid
>> Hold on. I need to start this again. God damn it. >> Sorry.
I was
listen to my words. Listen to my words.
>> I have no issue with someone as long as they have recognized
their mistakes. as long as they recognize that that was wrong.
What I take issue with is consistently def. >> So he's
saying I don't care if if Ela is recognized her mistakes has
recognized that's wrong. I think she regrets her time in the
IDF. >> Defending Israel.
>> You have also participated in the defense of Israel.
It makes no sense. You're inconsistent. You say it's a genocide,
but people can't resist militarily. You say it's a genocide,
but all of the people who are outspoken are vile anti-semites.
To be able to resist against this
Ela was doing mandatory uh military service. What should she
she have done? >> There's numerous options. One, religious
exemption. Two, refusing to serve. But even then, I don't have
a problem with her being uh socially conditioned into thinking
that this is appropriate. I have a problem with what she's saying
now. I have a problem with how she reflects that and doesn't
realize that that was an unjustifiable thing to do. Those are
>> Listen, you can talk to you can talk to her. Debate
about it. I don't know what what you're even referring to. Okay.
>> I don't even know what the you're referring to. You're
just calling my wife a terrorist. Like, what? Give me a break,
dude. >> She did manage. >> Let me ask you a question.
Please, you got to let me talk. >> How she went on a raid.
She was >> You have to let me talk. The fact that you're
just talking over me. >> It sounds like It sounds like
he's about to ask if you think she's a terrorist or you're right.
I promise.
>> Being louder and talking more does not mean you're right.
It's good to to listen to my what I have to say. She's part of
mandatory conscription. >> Did he not volunteer? Did Hila
not volunteer to go to the West Bank on a raid because she was
bored >> in Ramla? >> Yeah, she's 18. It's understandable.
>> We don't know what that guy did though. We don't know
what what the >> He could have been He could have been
a a vicious terrorist monster. >> Yeah. What if he killed
people? Of course. If he killed people, of course he would be
worthy of being arrested. >> Is Ramla a part of Israeli
territory? I mean, it's complicated, right? I don't
>> That's a really bad answer for the pro Palestinian people.
It's complicated. >> It's under occupation. No, I don't
think so. But it's under occupation, right? >> Okay. So,
why was your wife in Ramla?
>> Maybe getting a terrorist that
>> She sat in a
she sat in a car, didn't even leave it, and never did it again.
She actually did >> participated in an illegal raid according
to international human rights. That is the reality. Now I understand.
>> Are you upset if this person like a child? Would you
be upset if this person they arrested like stabbed people? Like
you don't know what you're talking >> Would you talk about
how [__] >> Okay, fine. My wife's a terrorist,
bro. What the It's so boring. >> Stop. Listen to my words.
If she were to talk about my wife the terrorist as many as many
former IDF vets have on breaking the silence. If she talked about
the night raid that she participated in in the same way that
>> just like says only I don't hate only the ones that
regret about I would have no issue with her. >> You hope
she gets PTSD too. >> Sorry Matt Slice is there an explicit
like call to sorry explicit like saying like these people aren't
valid targets in some way or what are we looking for
>> Oh thank you Jesus. Okay sorry this is a different time
stamp >> because you said that settlers are valid military
targets. Do you think your wife is a valid military target? Do
you think your wife is a terrorist? >> She's not a Westbank
settler. She's not a Westbank settler. >> But she's >> So
Ethan thinks these people are valid military targets, too. >> In
the West Empanada
thinks she's a valid Your friends over at Second Thought that
she's a valid >> You think she's a valid military target?
>> she's a valid military target here. >> Do you
think she's a valid military >> I do not, as a matter of
fact. I don't. >> Oh, great.
>> Okay. Okay. So, it seems pretty obvious the distinction
there as well. Does this make a difference for you at all that
he explicitly said he doesn't think she's invalid military target?
>> Did you say this before or after the
>> Before circling around. Okay. Like months before, right?
>> Yeah. Three months ago.
>> I don't know why that changes my opinion. Why should
that change my
>> I would just say it's pretty He makes it explicit that
he doesn't think she's a valid military target. You're trying
to say he's implying that she's a valid military target. I would
say the explicit the explicit disavow probably makes difference,
right? >> Um
and he says he says after that
right to resist they believe you said violence against HK right
now, not when she's doing illegal raids is acceptable. You didn't
say this. The context is in the clip, but everyone is just going
along with it. There is no point where I have said violence against
someone who is not actively in combat is
>> Okay. Okay, >> that is >> pretty much I
think I think it's explicitly ruled out by the way he's speaking
the whole clip, but
>> sure he clarified after the fact. Okay, >> Like
after it blew up on Twitter.
>> Well, people were explicitly lying about him on Twitter,
right? >> So, yeah, he did. He did clarify. Nobody actually
in the first in the first four days after this, nobody even cared,
right? Nobody said anything about this. There was no noise about
it. >> So, what? >> Okay. I apparently
So you think even though he said before even so just to be clear
even though he said before and after and she's explicitly ruled
out by all of the actual filters he provides all the actual predicates
he provides for who would be a valid target even though she couldn't
possibly be considered a valid target by these same predicates.
Okay. You believe that we can avoid all of that and just say
yeah I think he was putting her like a target on her back. >> Uh
no I never said that he's putting a target on her back. I just
think it's reasonable. At least
>> Hassan is implying Ela is still a valid military target
for her previous service in the IDF where she entered Raal as
a part of an IDF raid. This was your statement that you agreed
with at the beginning of the debate. >> Do you think it's
Do you think there's a difference between this and putting a
target on her back?
>> Okay. So, when I said So, you just denied that you put
a target that you're saying he put a target. She did say >> I
missed. I misspoke >> because Okay. Um, what do you mean
by putting a just comes back? I'm thinking like putting a bounty
on.
>> yeah. You're walking away. Yeah, you're walking away.
>> Um,
I'll just finish up. Uh,
if I'm thinking like you're putting a bounty on someone's head
or something like that, but no, I don't think it's like I don't
think like maybe I need to say this. I don't think like whatever
Hassan is saying, I don't think he's putting Hila in reasonable
danger. I'm just saying that like ideologically this is what
he said. I think I've said that in
other words before. I think it's like pretty reasonable to what
I'm saying >> is implying he is still a valid military
target. I think we can agree this isn't it and you're lowering
this down to I think he spoke recklessly and some people could
interpret it this way but you you basically would have to agree
now that he's not actually implying >> He's not implying
it even though he made the comparison.
>> There isn't a comparison there. Do you want to cook
on what the comparison is? because he he compares Ethan Klein's
uh wait Ethan Klein your favorite
>> he says your favorite podcasters like uh wife and you're
saying that he's comparing I guess the Israeli occupying force
even if it's your favorite podcasters like a to wife the word
wife yeah that's he's comparing her actions while she was in
the mil military to the military's current actions yes you can
say it like it sounds stupid but it's not really
>> I mean sorry he is saying that those actions she has
taken actions that are equivalent to this and >> yeah that's
why I said >> even if it were her >> even if it were
her doing those actions she would still be a valid target yes
>> that's why I made the compar that's why I called out
that he was making the >> it's I mean okay so you said
a simile so the way you said that okay you could say he is
>> he's not using like his assimile you have to give that
up he is clearly just stuttering for a He's not using like personally,
right? >> He said like
Oh my gosh. He said like,
pause with the uh your favorite. That was like a run-on sentence
if we have to go back to English class. >> It's not a runon
sentence. Just to be just to be I'll do this one more time and
then we don't have to do it again. Okay. The like uh is after
your favorite podcasters. That's when the like comes in. Now
I we already agree so we don't have to be pedantic but he's clearly
not doing a simile there. He's just using a word like >> Israeli
occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your
favorite podcasters like uh wife. >> Do you need me to
go back or like it's just obvious? I Are you watching the presentation
by the way? >> Uh my headphone wasn't working. You just
go back go you go back to like the occupying IDF or whatever.
>> Yep. Here I'm going to hit I'm going to hit play for
you >> which is a crime in and of itself. Israel's doing
a genocide in Gaza and an aparttheite in the West Bank. Two crimes
in and of itself. And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. The violence that the Palestinians
engage in in an act of resistance. So the like uh comes in at
a pretty obvious point after he's already said your favorite
podcasters and he goes like uh I believe it's clearly filler
words and not him doing a >> He said why are we doing >> he
said >> okay yeah we don't have to do it anymore >> occupying
force. No is we don't have to do it anymore but
um you said that yeah I don't know I'm just listening to it.
Can you can you just open the transcript? Is there like a YouTube
video
of this or I'm just curious. >> No, I'll just send you
the time for right now. I'll send you the time stamp right now
and you can listen to it on a device of your choosing and you
can figure that out and then you can message me which you come
up with after this or you could look up a YouTube video either
way. I think I'll just go on with the content now. Oh, whoops.
That's not that's not the correct thing. >> I guess you
won this one with a simile
>> Uh I mean I won it based on the English that he's saying.
It's just very clear from like everything about what he's talking
about. Um you
similly thing is very funny. I showed transcripts for other videos.
Um maybe maybe somebody sent me a YouTube video of this. Hold
on. Did I I didn't see if I clicked through to
Nope. I want to see if I've got a YouTube video of this. Does
not appear that I've got a YouTube video of this. Oh, that's
Nicholas.
Still no YouTube video of this. No, no, no. Am >> I to
read chat or no? >> Yeah, you can read chat. Go ahead.
Hey, >> the ciffy guy is saying you harped on the similly
point, not JTO. JTO
challenge me on assembly point after I said it. >> Yeah,
you're you're just wrong, but I sent you the time stamp. So,
thank you for coming on and >> Okay, you can just say I'm
>> Yeah, you can you can just go look it up and I know
basically
back and say, "Oh, my bad." >> We did. Okay. I love you.
Thank you for coming on. Have a good time. Uh please look at
that stuff. >> Have a good one. Bye. >> Just heard
it. >> I think I really think that's uh Schrodinger's there,
right? I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure at the end he's like trying
to go and do that to start trolling after he has walked through
it like dog walked through it. But it's fine. It's fine. I don't
I don't know if there's any way that I could assume that that
guy's like, "You guys are so annoying. You guys are so annoying
every time." All right. The simile part had me rolling. Maybe
I listen. If he was trolling at that point, that's pretty funny.
You love to see it. He was going to say podcaster like Ethan
but realized he was talking about Ela and said podcasters like
a wife.
Okay, maybe I got your rule won't happen again. Wait, what's
the rule? What do you mean? What's the rule? I didn't even see
what it was, bro. We're basically done, I think. Unless we get
more time, guys. Uh, seven subs away for another hour on the
stream. If you want another hour, go ahead and donate. Um, that
would be the last hour we do. Let's finish up some of this next
stuff real >> He can't talk about um people occupying territory
without chastising Ethan's wife to get under his skin. He can't
talk like it's it's just constantly in the back of his mind.
It's what he wants to talk about most foremost. Uh, but he also
wants to have this um element of I'm better than you. Look at
me. I'm saving the country while these guys do like tons of genocide.
Uh, what profit? >> I did not finish Ethan's video. You're
right.
Hold on one second. Pull up my YouTube history on another thing
here. One second. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where
is it? We're only halfway through this. We need to finish >> You
let on any >> need to finish this and the other thing >> kind
of, you know, I should apologize for this. Then then the mob,
then the horde has something to latch their teeth into. If you
go with the Donald Trump School of Medicine, no, you're simply
wrong. What do you think? You see you in the court, people go,
"Oh, there might be something to that." >> Yeah. You deny,
you deflect, and then you counterattack the person.
>> Ben Ruben donated $3.
>> Told him that simile is what his mom starts speaking
when you're giving her the business. >> Yeah, that would
be pretty gross. who like this investigation on you and you try
to claim that like there's a hidden bias there and most lizard
brain who like you unconditionally will go oh finally I have
an out to defend this person right >> person even when
he told me that I was thinking in my head like you've thought
a lot about this I haven't thought about it this this that deep
and if you go back though every time Hassan is accused of something
this is exactly what he does this is his playbook book. Never
apologize. Always double down.
Always accuse your accusers of being hallucinating, crazy, etc.
This is exactly his playbook.
Since Hassan and >> this is everyone online, it seems like
this is like everybody. >> Many of his friends have employed
this violent rhetoric against me and my family. Me and Ela rarely
leave our houses or make public appearances because of the constant
and overwhelming sense of danger. The last two years we've spent
more time inside than ever before and we haven't we stopped doing
our byianual live shows
right for over a year because of the fear of violence being enacted
not just on us but on our fans
I like okay you can have that fear of violence I don't think
I don't think it's appropriate to stop going outside okay I don't
think that's appropriate you can have like a fear but I don't
think Hassan Hassan didn't even do like a direct call to violence
right like like this is if it's something it's like the most
indirect thing in the world. I don't know. I don't think you
have any real reason to be scared. I don't think you have any
real reason to fear going outside. I think that's pretty crazy.
>> in our crew,
this by the way is resulting in the crew directly losing money
as
these live shows, we would donate the entire box. >> God,
do we have to donate money, guys? Donate money. We had 9 minutes
left. I need another hour on this stream cuz we got to get to
the red bar segment. Okay. I'm unfortunately going to have to
go do that red bar red bar segment. We have to watch that on
stream now to just show. Okay, we just have to do it to show.
I'm I'm I don't want to. I literally don't want to, but I have
to. I'm forced to. I'm compelled to box office to the crew and
we did this twice a year. It was a significant source of uh revenue
for them that's now been shut off out of fear.
Uh, we've been forced to hire a full-time guard at the office
because what? I don't get want to be that guy, but aren't you
wary of sharing your docs? If I had millions who hate you, I
think I that would with you. Oh, you're saying that like I don't
want myself to be known and so it should be understandable that
Ethan because he's like publicly known. He's a public figure.
He's scared to go outside cuz people hate him. Um,
I don't really Sorry. I think it's totally different. No, I think
they're totally different situations. I can't speak on the first
one like why I'm wary of it.
There's a lot of different things. >> Reban Ruben donated
$3. Bro, health is deteriorating while talking about my life
is in danger. >> It is it is like weird watching him. I
don't know if he's got like Does he have CO or something? He
is like like coughing consistently like like kind of sounds
sounds physically unwell and I'm not I'm not leaning into like
any of the conspiracies around him or something. The cough is
a tick. Are you sure his Tourette's? Wait, his Tourette's has
been like a million different things. Tiska is back if you still
want to debate him. I think if I pull Tyk in right now, people
will sh themselves in the face.
>> I've I've actually I've actually said it. Okay, I've
actually said it. Barma, dude, thank for the gifted sub. I've
said it. I asked him if he wants to come >> Everyone in
the office was feeling unsafe and me and Ela are both waiting
for our concealed carry license so that we can finally feel safe.
coughing, twisting his hand. I thought it was the sniffling was
a part of it as well, but that seems to have gone. Maybe it just
depends on like what he's Maybe it's like um like illness symptoms
or >> in public again, which is not easy to get in California
and it's going to take like over a year probably.
And I usually choose not to talk about this stuff because the
provocators
who will revel in it >> seasonal. Yeah, maybe like as he
gets as he like as his throats get scratchy, it becomes like
the cough that he does as the um as the tick, but then like when
his nose is pl he's like he's sniffling or something, right?
>> They want they want me to be afraid. They want me to
be in my house. They want me to avoid doing public events. They
want me to cower. So, this this is very much giving them what
they want. >> Yeah. Don't give them what they want,
>> exactly. moment. I do feel the entire context of how
language like this affects me and my family and my crew and everybody
around me. Twitch has served as the most prolific source of leftist
>> Do you see like so people some people don't like the
the tweet, right? The tweet that says like if you're doing this
you're only like shielding the clients from criticism. I think
when you when you intentionally try to use this like uh this
clip from Hassan is like actually he's not just coming after
me, he's coming after my whole family. He's coming after my crew.
He's coming after everybody. And you paint as like the most unhinged
thing in the world when it's really not. At most is like being
slightly irresponsible.
I I don't know how much responsibility eth like Hassan has to
defend here or to to be like kind to them. You know what I mean?
So there's a little bit I'm like a little hesitant there, right,
man?
I don't know. I just I think at most it's like a little irresponsible
to mention Ela in like any context basically in any context because
of how much his community hates her, right? In any negative consequence
or any native negative context, there's probably some argument
that that like stoastically increases the chance somebody does
something. But then I'd say probably conversely when Ethan does
this, it's doing the same thing in reverse. No. Like, can you
can you argue that Hassan's mention of Ela Klene negatively
Ela's life
significantly more than what Ethan's saying about Hassan here
when he's coming out and he's saying this guy tried to like my
my son, my wife tries to get my wife killed. Like, I feel like
those are almost you could almost equate those two things in
terms of like the stochastic harm they're doing.
And it's like, okay, once you're at that level of sta like stochastic
terrorism, quote unquote, I don't know if there's really an argument
there anymore.
>> Terrorist propag Oh god, Ty is in the waiting room.
Okay, Ty, I'm just going to finish this real quick. >> An
anti-West sentiment.
They foster, they elevate, they protect the most dangerous and
inflammatory voices. And it's obvious to anyone paying attention
that Twitch is being run by ideologues that agree with Assand.
And it's obvious to anyone who's paying attention, they use the
terms of service as a form of political activism by harshly punishing
people that they're opposed to and granting near total immunity
impunity
to their allies like Hassan. The CEO has even stated on record
that Hassan is his favorite streamer. In the past, there's been
a coordinated pressure campaign against Twitch advertisers with
some success, but the entire Twitch executive team remains protected
despite the head of inclusive marketing the head of inclusive
marketing once tweeting out. What is the difference between a
>> like I'm sorry once you bring up the Twitch anti-semitism
thing
for me personally when you're just going to use this to go after
Twitch? This is transparent. What's actually going on here is
transparent to me. Sorry. >> Boy Scout and a kid and I'll
I'll give you a hint as to the answer. It's only one returns
from camp. What's the difference between a boy scout and a kid?
Only one returns from camp. The head of inclusive marketing at
Twitch. Now, this person, as far as I'm aware, has faced zero
administrative correction. And >> wait, when was that tweet
from? Hold on.
We want to fire them from a from a tweet from 2011. I'm sorry,
but like objectively, if you're behind this guy, give your head
a shake, okay? Just give your head a shake.
>> As far as I'm aware, has faced zero
administrative correction and continues to this day to hold her
position as head
of inclusive marketing at Twitch. The irony is is uh so >> what
was Ethan doing in 2011? >> Thick you could cut it with
a knife. Now, while some sponsors have no doubt left, there's
still >> Yeah, I don't think this has happened either.
I have no idea if this I I don't think this has happened. I've
never seen this happen. I don't think Ethan's engaging in like
actual calls to violence against Hassan. Uh I But I don't think
Hassan was trying to engage in a call to violence against Ela
either. So, >> enough remaining that Amazon has not been
forced to intervene. And I would encourage anyone using Twitch
to contact advisers as soon as they're served to you. If you
use Twitch, if you're watching, when you get an ad,
>> write them and say, "Hey, I would like to know why you're
>> uh calling out a 2011 tweet is wild.
Thank you, Frank. Thank you for the donation." Also, Ethan spends
an insane amount of time mentioning Hassan is bad in a bad light
in some way beside countless Well, I sorry. I do think that like
if it's just going to be you on the other person and like getting
digs in, if that's where we're going to stocastic terrorism with,
I understand that Hassan is doing it in a context where it's
like um I understand that doing it in a certain context where
it's shitty. Okay, but like it is what it is, guys. Minute 23
left on. We are
five subs. Five subs away from another hour on the stream, guys.
>> Spending directly your dollars to support violent extremism.
Why are you supporting a platform that sanctions, protects, safeguards,
encourages, promotes
language like what Hassan just deployed against Ela and show
them that why is Hassan on the homepage every day? Every day
when I go there, why I want to give a shout out to AT&T,
by the way, who recently has been telling people that they sponsor
on Twitch that Hassan's not allowed. >> Why aren't you
doing the streamer games? Uh, AT&T is part of the sponsors
and AT&T doesn't [__] with me. It is what it
is. Why? >> So, they asked Lewig, Hassan's friend, who
by the way, who very bravely was like, "Hey, listen, buddy. You
can't be in my videos anymore. I'm going to be your friend. I'm
going to openly support you and and you know, encourage you.
My my girlfriend's going to do a podcast with you, etc., etc."
But AT&T, they're crazy. They don't want you in any of our
videos, you know. Shout out to AT&T. Let's see more of and
less of Hassan in these videos. I am encouraging you guys to
pressure advertisers, to pressure Amazon, pressure Twitch as
a last resort. This is a plea for sanity that something be done
before it's too late >> on behalf.
>> Uh, hold on. What was that? Hooligans, thank the gifted
sub. Anonymous, thank you for the gifted sub. We are
getting close. Three subs away, guys. Three subs away. all whose
safety has been compromised
to please help us stop this. This is madness. Thank you. >> Yeah,
I don't I just don't see it. I don't see it, man. I just don't
see it. I really don't see it at all. It's kind of unfortunate.
Okay. It's kind of unfortunate. All right. Um let's see here.
Oh, right. We're pulling Tykin.
Right, right, right, right. I guess we're pulling Tykin here.
Taisa, how's it going? What's up? Hello >> on the stream.
>> It's going pretty well. So, I've got a question for
you. Do you know who Brenton uh Brenton Tarant is? >> Yep.
Uh just real quick though. Okay. Uh my are you going to make
a claim for what you believe with regards to Hassan and Ela or
are you going to
>> uh Yes. But first I want to ask >> I like >> I
just want to write the claim down first. No, no, no. I don't
want to do story time first. I want to do claim first. I just
want to get that written
This was the Christ Church. >> Hold on. Churchac. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> I know exactly who it is. Reference Lord
Southern. I want you to write down or sorry, tell me what your
positive claim is here. >> Let me finish the sentence.
>> No. Stop with story time. Stop with story time. Ta.
Tiska. This is why everybody gets upset. Don't story time. Do
this first and then you can do story time. I promise I'll let
you tell us all about Brent and Taran. Just make the positive
claim first. Uh the claim is that you're discounting obvious
uh engagement in stoastic terrorism or dog >> So Hassan
engaged in >> and actually Okay. So my hypothesis is that
you are going to be
I don't need hypothes I don't need hypothesis about me. You could
just say dog whistling stoastic terrorism against Hila Klene
is your position. Engage in stocastic terrorism or dog whistling
against Hila Klein. So a at off the hop I would imagine that
you have to either do a standard here which applies so broadly
that all creators engage in stocastic terrorism basically just
talking people is stcastic terrorism or >> hold on hold
on hold on hold on so Brit
>> okay Brett and Taran go >> I haven't given I haven't
given my first thought I haven't given you my thesis yet you're
trying to do an internal critique when I haven't given an
>> so Tarant was the was the Christ Church killer. Uh he
wrote a very long manifesto in which he referenced uh the belief
in the great replacement. Uh he referenced Lauren Southern, Candace
Owens, and Tim P uh as people who convinced him to engage in
this massacre of 49 Muslims at two mosques in Christ Church,
New Zealand.
>> Uh obviously,
it's somewhat their responsibility.
This was 2019. This was the alt-right time. This was when Lauren
Southern was doing her whole This was when she did her whole
great replacement
>> She is sort of responsible for that. No. >> Uh
did she prescribe anything or was she doing descriptive stuff?
So I would say there's a level to which I think uh I think you
can like accuse people of stcastic terrorism, right? >> But
I think you have to you basically have to give people no other
option, >> right? The thing is is like think you're unless
you do something. >> Okay. Perfect. Perfect.
>> So basically the the whole great replacement idea is
that >> uh there's this cabal of elites that are doing
these things to your country and your ethnic group and there's
nothing anybody can do about it and voting doesn't work. Uh the
courts don't work. You know preaching doesn't work. So you know
you've got the four boxes. You've got your soap box. You've got
your ballot box. You've got your jury box. And then you know
what that fourth one is? It's the ammo box. Sure. >> And
so what does Hassan say? He's saying that my soap box isn't doing
anything. This is the same thing that Noah Noah Samson says.
Uh we need to escalate for Palestine because the soap box doesn't
do anything. The ballot box is worth
>> First of all, so you just said Hassan said this. Hassan
is Hassan has done this stocastic terrorism over Palestine. Can
I see where you said nothing you do
>> That your advocacy doesn't matter. Your voice doesn't
matter. >> He didn't endorse the candidate. That's the
very definition of your vote doesn't matter. Don't go vote. It
doesn't >> It's not. It's not. In fact, he went and voted
and streamed himself voting. Why would he do that if he thinks
your vote doesn't matter? >> He didn't endorse the candidate
and he didn't stream who he voted. >> He didn't endorse
a candidate, but he he went and streamed himself voting the process
of voting. Why would he do that if he doesn't believe in the
democratic process? Why wouldn't he say, "Isn't Isn't under your
what you're describing, wouldn't his action be, actually, I'm
not going to vote? [__] it. Nothing matters." I mean
maybe I guess but what his what his speech is. >> So you
can totally
concede on this doesn't matter.
>> I am not going to endorse a candidate because the audience
that I'm speaking to
you that he is not telling you that it's hopeless. Right? He
is not telling you it's hopeless. He is not saying you shouldn't
vote. He is saying specifically the most you could argue. What
hope is he giving? Most you could argue is that he is saying
if you vote in the presidential election, both of these sides
are going to not change anything on Israel, but he obviously
advocates voting in general and voted down ballot, right? And
he I've never heard him once say it's not important for you to
show up to vote
>> Hooligans donated three. >> Well, that's what
I mean is there's a genocide going on. There's nothing we can
do about it. This is the most important thing is his worldview.
Everything's about the also like the Marxist undertones. Like
everything's about the revolution. That's another let the streets
run red with their red capitalist bloods, dude. Like that's what
he's endorsing is the ammo box. >> That's
okay. So he's been doing that for 10 years now that he's been
doing the let the streets run red eight years or something and
nothing's happened.
Right. So what are what are we saying? I don't >> think
I don't think so. >> You think that's a consistent position
he's had? >> seems like he realized that you shouldn't
be saying those things, right?
>> Uh to the contrary, I mean, he would say things like
America deserved 9/11.
Uh he would just give that as his opinion, but since October
7th, at least the past two years, he has been different than
his earlier career for sure. There's no question about that.
He's much more violent and
says that there's, you know, nothing you can do to like you can't
organize, you can't vote, you can't do anything. It's, you know,
it's the same types of same types of vibes that the alt-right
was giving around 2019. >> I I just wholesale reject that
Hassan's somehow giving like uh alt-right vibes from 2019. Can
we can we substantiate that in some way? >> Altight. Okay.
So, in 2017 was the Unite the Right rally. That was like the
peak of the alt-right, right? Two years later, by 2019, they
were like on the fall, and that's why they were, you know, Stfan
Molyu and uh the gay guy, I can't remember what his name is,
Milo Yiannopoulos, uh Alex Jones, they were all being like really
hopeless, like, oh, the deep state has got to Trump. This is
like, you know, the whatever it it's not working out. Q was wrong.
this I don't remember where KQanon fits in into this. Basically,
there was a bunch of hopelessness.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. I'm going to give a competing hypothesis
with you that >> that Hassan does not think voting is hopeless
and he doesn't have like a lack of a belief in the democratic
process. He doesn't think like voting doesn't matter, but he
does believe that the problems of parties makes it difficult.
>> Okay. Um,
then if you have if you don't have proof of care, so where's
the proof of him saying don't vote? Where's the proof of him
saying where's the proof of him doing dumerism? That your vote
won't work, that nothing can change. Uh, aside from one topic
on Palest
>> You can't I reject that you can just all put that all
down to just the lack of wanting to vote, the lack of wanting
to endorse. said at least twice that
uh I don't I don't know it verbatim but he said there is absolutely
no reason to believe that Kamala would have been any different
than Trump is the most recent time he was referring to Palestine
in particular that's >> that is maybe the most important
part of
>> but it's not saying that it's hopeless >> saying
that your vote doesn't >> your vote doesn't matter on Palestine
I think if he was arguing that that Camala would do nothing different
on like abortion or I just I feel like there's no possible way
he would say that. >> Uh the first time he said it, he
was referring much more generally. The most recent time he said
it. Um I could dig up clips, I guess, if you want him. I would
be surprised if you don't know what I'm talking about. >> Okay.
I just I can't see that. Like and I by the way I I think he's
like probably a communist at heart. I think he probably doesn't
like believe democracy is the best way forward. I have no doubt
that he doesn't believe in liberalism. Like I'm just saying that
I think for for it to re for us to enforce or to do something
about this person in terms of stochastic terrorism, there's got
to be major walking up to the line of violence. Major walking.
And I don't think we're anywhere close to that yet.
>> Hold on. No, that's not what stochcastic terrorism is
because Lauren Southern never walked up to the line of violence.
She just said that there's no other solution and let you make
the decision yourself. And that's where >> yes, sorry.
You need to give them no other way forward except violence. And
I do not believe that I can say that for >> And Hassan
has not always been hopeless. He is currently deeply deeply hopeless.
And just like the alt-right in 2019, the socialists are kind
of falling off round about now. Or at least they're in a similar
sort of >> What evidence do we have of socialists falling
off? >> I mean, Bread Tube, Bread Tube was a thing around
COVID. I think or something. And it was like this big hip cool
movement, but you know, now we're kind of >> like up, right?
Like his views in 2024 were significantly worse than they are
>> Yeah, I don't doubt that. Twitch views generally are
up. I'm not sure that that >> I'm just >> I feel
like you're I feel like you're rolling with like rhetoric here.
I feel like you're just rolling with rhetoric here. That's like
not actually accurate at all. >> like I I would want some
basis for this opinion. Like you it sounds like you just said
this to people and they were like yeah socialists are totally
falling off and we have like I don't know what the evidence here
is. Like I don't even I don't know whether or not it's happening.
I just like I've never heard that from somebody. Oh, socialists
are totally falling off. Sounds like socialists are like the
big thing that you have to focus on for the Democratic party
right now. Are there not a bunch of people online saying this
that like actually we need to cut these socialists out completely?
These socialists are ruining everything. >> Yeah. So that's
a new thing. That's sort of what I'm talking about. I mean I
could maybe justify this but we could we could let that go. Um,
nonetheless, >> who do you Wait, who do you think is pushing
the Democratic Party's opinion on Israel so far down? >> So,
the Democratic Party's opinion of Israel, uh, support for Israel
has dropped massively. Why do you think that's happened?
it's I'm not entirely sure about the polling on Israel, but from
what I've seen, it's been trending down for decades now, at least
since the end of the war on terror. Would you not think >> it's
gone down significantly because of
>> No, because socialists do that. >> Even conservatives
dislike uh Israel
>> uh more so. And it's also a very distinct age thing,
too. Like if you grew up after the fall of the Soviet Union or
if you were born after the fall of the Soviet Union, then yeah,
you're going to have a much worse view of Israel
than older people who live through the Cold War. >> Sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah. Sure. Okay. Somebody asked, "Why is this
any of this relevant to the clip?" He's going to say that Hassan
is engaging in stocastic terrorism or dog whistling against Helilocline.
>> Uh yes, I think he engages in it just generally. I think
that that is the
it's >> uh I would say if you were going to say he's engaging
in stoastic terrorism, he probably went far harder, him and Aerodite
both went far harder for stoastic terrorism when they supported
Luigi. Right. >> That's Yes, that is a good example. And
I can't say for sure. In fact, I would be surprised if it were
true, but uh Aaron Bushnell um the guy who firebombed in Colorado,
the guy who shot up the um
uh Jewish
whatever event it was in May. Um
and Luigi >> diplomat shooting. Those are not related.
You can't connect Luigi to those things. >> That's insane.
Uh they're they're all examples of people doing violence trying
to use the ammo box to take initiative into their own hands uh
through means that are not socially acceptable. >> Bushnell
Bushnell No, Bushnell's thing was not the same as those things.
He's not hurting other people, just set himself on fire, which
is insane, but and useless, but it's not the same. >> Sorry,
it Sorry, you I thought you were saying there was a connection
between them. There's just a connection, but I don't even think
that there's like >> significantly more. Is there significantly
more political violence now than there has been at some point
in the past like 10 years? It feels like there's always just
oneoff events. Like I would say most mash which I don't think
mash have really fallen off. Most mash have some political agenda,
right? >> I don't know. It's It's hard to tell. I could
maybe give you that one. >> What do you mean?
>> I Okay. >> Uh I mean there's statistics on it
for sure. I don't know the statistics, but I know the FBI does
keep statistics. I don't know if uh political violence is more
common now than it was before, but it
I think left left-wing or
uh political violence is certainly seems more prevalent to me.
Anyway, >> the the diplomat is definitely left-leaning
political violence. I don't think the guy from Egypt is left-leaning
political violence who firebombed the people in Colorado. I was
like a 60-year-old Egyptian guy. You think that guy had a lot
of left-leaning beliefs? I yeah I I would put him as neutral
or
>> I think I think you have got like a big view here that's
just really difficult to tie together. So do we maybe want to
go to the Hassan example rather than going like starting from
Brettton Terren and all this like really broad stuff and do you
want to work on like why that would be stoastic terrorism? >> Well
so the the thesis with Britain is that Lauren Southern was never
actually advocating violence or anything. What she was advocating
was was hopelessness.
>> which Assan does every day. >> To be clear, Lauren
Southern kind of points you at a target. Okay. And Brett and
Taran did not follow through and attack that target whatsoever.
>> I think he did. What do you mean? What target do you
have in mind? >> A clear target for Lauren Southern is
elites, right? Elites like the European Parliament, elites like
this who are pushing mass migration policies to fill your country
up with these people. She never once said that these people like,
as far as I know, she she wasn't saying, "Oh, your target should
be the Muslims." I'm pretty clear. I think it's pretty clear
that that Yeah. Like the target she's describing is the elites
and he didn't do he didn't attack a political establishment.
He didn't do anything like that. He just attacked brown
>> Well, yeah, but that's the you can't go after the elites.
Even Luigi Manion arguably didn't I guess he went after the elites,
but didn't really actually do something particularly effective.
you know, the elite. >> Just to just to remind you, um
the billionaire former president of the United States who is
actively campaigning for the Republican party had a bullet clip
his ear last year. So when you say you can't target the elites
when you live in America, that seems like a insane concept to
me. >> No, you can target an elite, you can't target the
elite as a group. >> It's a nebulous concept. Like if Trump
had been assassinated
uh same as JFK, it probably would have uh you know led to a massive
conservative uh wave as in like you know when JFK was the country
goes you can't just president we want to you know not change
anything we want to stay in the same political lane that we were
>> like a rally around the flag effect or same as Iraq
war uh 91. If somebody if somebody felt really hopeless because
the Republicans were in office um without advocating for violence,
they're just saying we're
look at look at the changes to the Supreme Court and they were
doomer. Would you say that is stochastic terrorism? The concept
of being doomer with no concept of like pointing somebody in
a direction saying there's no way out except violence. >> No,
not really. I mean, it's it's a combination of
a deep-seated hopeless
anger and resentment and also this energy with nowhere to go
that leads, you know, followers of whatever sort to make conclusions
of their own. And somebody who's going to engage in some sort
of violent act like this is probably going to be crazy to some
degree and a poor decision maker and maybe won't follow your
rules. You know, just like like you said that Lauren Southern
uh said that the elites were the target uh and Brenton goes after
Muslims in a mosque in a country that he didn't live in. Um,
you know, it's the same thing as like Aaron Bushnell lighting
himself on fire or the guy in America over a country 6,000 miles
away with you. >> Um, wait, but it makes total sense. Sorry.
Would you argue that Israeli diplomats in America are not like
connected?
I I don't think this the 6,000 miles away argument is really
silly. I don't avow political violence in any way, but the 6,000
miles away argument is just very silly to me every single time
because obviously America is the primary supplier of weapons
and aid to Israel and like literally pressuring American politicians
may be the most vital way of curtailing Israel's aggression in
the Middle East. Right. >> All right. Sorry, say that again.
>> So, I would say the 6,000 miles away argument always
gets me, always like annoys me because obviously it the United
States are the number one provider of weapons to Israel and the
number one provider of aid to Israel. So, I think it's crazy
to say that you can't affect policy change in Israel by affecting
policy change in the United States. Pretty obviously. >> Sure.
I think
>> Yeah. I mean, I think that's right that you can affect
policy in Israel. Uh it's clear that Trump has no intention to
do it. Um but I think Biden
>> did curtail uh Israel uh a handful of times. probably
um not as much as he should have, but >> I don't really
know particularly have >> um I think he tried to pressure
them. I think he was ineffective in doing so. >> Well,
I mean,
just to be clear, I'm going to say I don't think you've come
close. I think you could try to put together a thesis on this
to better connect these things, but you're not connecting the
stochcastic terrorism like overall like stocastic terrorism could
be a thing, but I don't see how Hassan is remotely directing
stochastic terrorism at like the clines
unless you just want to say him talking is directing it. >> Okay.
So, why did he invoke uh Ela
in that? because he's talking because he's talking about illegal
uh IDF presence in the West Bank explicitly in area A and Ela
Klein went on a raid into area A into Ramala, right? Voluntarily.
>> Mhm. Uh does it matter >> factually incorrect?
>> No, because we're talking about his implication, right?
Like like what he thinks he's doing. I don't think it matters
at all that he's factually incorrect. I've said this repeatedly
that like I think I think he's incorrect. Uh, I I I've said repeatedly
I'm pretty sure he would be incorrect because it's a specific
for Hassan, >> right? Hassan is horrible at knowing specifics
of anything. >> None of my criticisms have to do with it
like actually being illegal or legal. Like, not that I think
we know that Ela's raid into Ramallo would be legal. I don't
think we could possibly know that. Um, I just don't rely on it
on saying it's illegal or I think he's saying I think he's also
explaining that he thinks >> there exists no evidence that
Ela ever did anything uh that was illegal. >> You'd agree
with that? Surely, right? >> Um,
sure. But she might have done something that could have made
her a like classified as a combatant if they were to target that
vehicle, right? Like like I wouldn't say if she was out of that
vehicle and like crying and hiding, I don't think you can really
target her. But I would say that in the case where okay, in the
case where they targeted that vehicle in some way, I think if
she had been harmed, it would have been as a combatant, like
I think under international law or something. >> Realistically,
if that happened, I think a bunch of Palestinians die and no
international court ever looks at it.
>> Yeah. So if the ID erode and the whole
crew dies, I it it could it could have been a police action.
I mean, it sounds from her story, it sounds like what they were
doing was just a police action. Then we're going in an APC because
uh you know when >> she said they were going to arrest
a terrorist and go through his house and find we sometimes we
have a particular >> Yeah. And we're going to arrest this
person. We have a >> you know maybe it's not a warrant
but uh I don't know. >> She said nightly every night >> I
would imagine. Yeah. It's the second >> Okay. Uh but so
anyway, there is there exists no evidence that what she was doing
was illegal. We're just assuming that. And if we assume that
then >> I already said in this matter statement, >> wait,
hold on. We're we're talking about his attempt to direct if he's
directing violence at her. Whether or not he whether or not he
thinks it's illegal. Sorry. Whether or not it is actually illegal
has nothing to do with the fact that he thinks it's illegal,
right? It's like the core thesis of his >> Well, it's sort
of because >> we're talking about his intention that he's
making Well, the statement that he's making is that uh resistance,
violent resistance that the Palestinians do is legal. And he
mentions a couple of groups. He mentions uh I don't remember
if he mentions um but he mentions >> I think he does >> uh
the al alkuds brigades >> alkuds would
and uh yes alkuds uh is yeah alcuds is the fighting force of
but he also mentions the al o a oxa brigades
which is only a thing in terms of the collection of Palestinians
from various organizations or unorganized who participated in
October 7th. That is the type of violence that he's saying is
justified even including if it's against
your favorite uh streamer's wife. >> Uh okay. Um Alexa's
Alaka Martyr's brigades uh emerged during the second inifata.
So is that you're saying that this thing that emerged during
the second inifata is only for collecting is only October 7th
people? >> Uh I I could be wrong about that. What? What
are you reading? That the Aloxa Brigades is a >> Martyrs
Brigades. >> Ala Martyrs Brigades. Um, are they a subgroup
of someone else? >> Allian armed groups in the West Bank.
>> Okay. All right. I'll compete on that one. I was wrong.
>> Uh, but why would he
uh invoke Ela in that in that statement? >> Uh, probably.
I would just say probably because um Ethan was calling him like
a pest. Yeah, a simple pest like on stream the day or two before.
And it's like the perfect comparison in that case, right? He's
talking about the illegal presence in area A. He believes ELO
was illegally present in area A. >> So it's like one, I
don't like these people. They're talking [__] about
me. Two,
it fits perfectly. Do you think that if I were a person like
uh Britain that
it would be
reasonable enough for me to with my bad decision-m skills conclude
that he is advocating for violence against her to the degree
that it was careless of him to say it and he should have
been a lot more careful with his words? No, I don't believe I
don't believe there's a lot of proof that Bretton was um that
like Bretton wasn't just mentally ill and acting out and that
like while he did watch Lauren Southern, it could have just been
anybody else that he could have referenced and it would have
could have had nothing to do with the like I think that guy was
just crazy. Uh you'd have to find a different
I I just don't think you could really make her like responsible
in that way. Uh, I I'm sympathetic to the conclusion, but not
the way you got there. Britain was very much coherent. He wrote
a whole manifesto that was fairly interesting and uh involved
a lot of things that seemed to be contradictory or potentially
ironic, especially
I thought I thought his I thought his didn't he say sub to PewDiePie?
Is that not the sub to PewDiePie guy? Oh, I think ah yes, that
was that was
>> Uh it's it's unclear.
That is a reasonable assumption. Um the guy was not set. >> He
didn't.
>> Oh, actually that might have been where the PewDiePie
is a Nazi
[__] came from.
comes from his anti-semitic [__] and his uh is wearing
a uniform on his stream and being like He wore an uniborn. There
was the bridge incident. He might have said something once, but
then I think that was part of
what amplified it. I don't know. Anyway, yeah. So, you're right.
I think that it is not
reasonable to say that Lauren Southern is at fault or is a direct
link um to the Christ Church massacre. However, it is plausible
that what he was writing about those figures was not actually
ironic that he did truly believe it. It's just hard to tell.
>> Um and there's even
if he did, I don't think I I don't know. Like I would have to
see Lawrence Southern like is she directing at these people?
Is she um like is there a whole thing going on there where I
can hold her really responsible or I could say like it was actually
wrong of you to to make this piece like this was way too far
beyond just the obvious racism. Right? >> Are you >> I
don't know I don't know if there's a So here's the thing. Hassan
made that statement. Okay. Is Ethan Klein going on and suggesting
that Hassan might have been receiving you know Oh, I should go
make sure he did this. Um is what did they do today? Hold on.
Oh, when Ethan Klein goes live and says, "Uh, Hassan Piker's
trying to kill my wife." Is he not also increasing the temperature?
Is he not also increasing the likelihood that somebody would
do something to attack uh Hassan [__] >> so
this is what I'm going to try to highlight here is I think a
lot of people say this and it's like, okay, the temperature is
raised, but at what point like do all of these people are they
not all continue to raise this temperature and and direct like
hate towards each other and possibly push somebody to do something
violent? >> I mean, that's it's not about temperature.
It's about the the violence in the uh in the implication that
he's giving. Uh so for instance, Ethan is clearly not directing
anybody to action. Can't even be interpreted if and I'm just
taking your word for it that that's what he said. Um I don't
know what he said. Uh but when Destiny posted on >> Wait,
you don't know what said GG or whatever it was. >> You
don't know what he said. >> I don't know what Ethan said.
>> Okay. Jesus. Okay. All right. >> At least I don't
know what he said today or yesterday. Okay. >> But when
Destiny posts in DGG chat saying um he said I think using these
statements you could justify um violence against Assan [__]
[__] I I don't remember exactly what he said. Clearly
that is implicating an action
um that a vigilante might you know take on uh with the Lauren
Southern thing that was the her um I think the documentary was
called the great replacement and this was the documentary in
which she went to the Mediterranean Sea and um quote unquote
flares at a migrant vessel
um and they were on like a a small boat. Uh the migrant ship
was um fairly big. I think there were like 80 people on board
or something. Um, and they
Lauren Southern was flares to like mark the boat. Uh,
what the flare is? >> Hold on. You understand she never
shot a flare, right? There was no flare gun. She never shot a
flare. >> A flare was I don't remember exactly what where
where the flare came from, but there was a flare in the movie.
>> It might not might not have been her that shot it, but
it did come from their group or their boat. >> She never
flare. That's like known
>> A a flare was to mark. Uh
>> they like were trying to about >> a bunch of people
in chat are saying no, it was a handheld flare. There was no
>> Handheld flare.
sure. But the the idea was we as civilians with no authority
are trying to mark the we're trying to play vigilante sort of
and uh work with the authorities to alert them of this vessel.
so that they can ask for borders and deport them back. >> How
does this tie back to Hassan? What point are we making right
now? >> Because she's doing an action. She's taking it
into her own hands because the government won't. She's implicating
an action. Ethan's not implicating an action here. Destiny certainly
is. Hassan is treading pretty close. >> How is Hassan treading
closer than >> Cuz you know, you know the message I'm talking
about, right? It was like two or three days ago when Destiny
was like uh he posted it in DGG chat. >> He said something
like >> I think these statements could he didn't even like
say by Hassan's own logic. He said that these statements could
be used to justify Hassan [__] >> or something
something like that.
>> Is that not a direct vague call call to >> It's
not vague. It's like a direct call to violence. Yeah. It's like
a It's like a direct like this guy.
I'm pretty sure you could trust V. Yeah. Yeah. Someone supposed
someone rid me of this medals priest. Yes. Absolutely. >> The
same same kind of call of violence you did against me in Que.
Yep. >> Yeah. Yes. Exactly. >> Does this stuff a
lot? >> Yeah. Yeah. I think that that's clearly more more
direct than
Hans.
>> Um. Yes. >> Although since it's in TG chat versus
like literally on stream, I don't know. Um
and
Destiny is clearly not advocating terrorism like Hassan
very obviously does. I mean the groups that he implicated um
PLP
>> he's advocating that resist the Palestinians against
IDF
>> uh in the in the illegal occupation
he
so I think that if you take him verbatim it's easy to conclude
otherwise but I think what the intent that he was the intent
that he was trying to communicate was the Palestinian resistance
against the IDF in the illegal occupation engaged in illegal
occupation
um in the West Bank and in Gaza.
Uh although he also said occupied territories and it's he sort
of blurs the line as to whether Israel proper is occupied Palestinian
>> Where does he blur the line and how does he blur the
line? >> Uh just in his in his
coverage I think he's he's not uh actually maybe I'll maybe I'll
take that back. Denims and bike from PA definitely say things
like Israel should not exist. This is all stolen Palestinian
land and should I think he might say Palestinian land. >> Do
you know the context that this clip is occurring in?
>> You know anything about the context >> Oh, he's
watching a a documentary
and it's about the the Knesset or Parliament or somebody passed
an annexation of the West Bank. >> Oh, sure. Uh yeah, there's
a symbolic annexation of the West Bank or something, but the
the documentary is on armed settlers and segregation inside the
West Bank. >> Yeah. Well, I'm not going to defend the
>> uh I I don't know that. >> So, when he's talking
about when he's talking about settlers and when he's talking
about he's talking about the IDF and illegally occupied areas
and it's specifically saying this is an area A where there's
no there's no allowance of where the IDF does not have security
authorizations, the PA,
right? I think it's pretty obvious what he's referring to. No.
Well, if he's referring to settlers, then that makes it a little
less clear, I think, because was not a settler, unless you consider
all of >> when he mentions, it's in the context of the
IDF doing illegal operations there. >> Yes. So, the documentary
I I assume >> Israeli occupied force
who are civilian said I think you said, I don't care if it's
even your favorite podcasters like a wife, right? So it's in
comparison to the it's very clearly tied tightly to the Israeli
occupying force. >> Yeah. Well, the the settlers are like
um dur civilians that are, you know, doing illegal things and
backed by the IDF who are militized
like armed settlers here, >> right? So armed settlers are
uh durian.
They're not part of the IDF. >> Sure. But they're combatants
by definition, right? So this is this is to literally talk about
this entire documentary. It's about civilians complicated and
illegally occupy um these areas and then use force. So if a group
of Mexicans come in, they they go over the US border, they set
up a shanty, okay, and then they're willing to defend that shanty
from the government and anybody else with guns. Is that are those
civilians? >> Uh yeah. So legally it's it's complicated.
It's sort of like the Mexican cartels. Are those civilians? >> Are
they military? Are they police? I would call them like militants
or combatants. It's a militia, right? Be this classified essentially
the same way that would be. >> Uh well civilians and >> yeah
that's a that's a fairly good >> Are all martyrs brigade
civilians? >> Uh they're well it depends on what hat they're
wearing at any given time. Uh Hezbollah is a really good example
where these are >> yeah militants who are ready to
we can watch the clip. Contextually, Hassan is very clearly referring
to people engaging in military operations. He says as much in
the clip, right? >> Okay. Yes. Yeah. I mean, you're right.
Yeah. And I think that that is the intent that he's uh bringing
forth with it. I think it also has to do with the fact that um
Ethan and Ela had just done um a
whole episode on his like test stuff and it had to do with bad
empanada
um and the tankies saying they're going to ditch Aan [__]
for not being tanky enough and you know it's just what was on
his mind
as an example. Um but clearly it was careless. Clearly it was
uh I would even say dangerous. I mean, as Son P like, if you
if you read his chat during any of his streams, especially when
he's talking about Ethan and Nila, there's some crazy in there.
>> There's always some crazy in there. There's some crazy
mother who watch us on [__] and might, you know,
take that as a direct call uh call to action. >> Why Why
do they take that as a direct call to action and not like anything
else? He says >> he's he's like directly called directly
supported Luigi like in his violent action and I haven't seen
any copycats. I that's because that's because communists are
all who are
agorophobic and don't go outside. But one of the one of the >> arguing
against your point or >> I mean I I would not be surprised
if you know somebody decides to take violent action into their
own hands. But it clearly his support of terrorism, his support
of Luigi Manioni, his support of um Palestinian resistance organizations
who are uh like
extraordinarily bad.
>> He's not supporting those. Just to be clear, he's not
supporting those groups here, right? >> Uh he's supporting
their actions. He's saying that their action is not only uh legal,
which it isn't, but it's moral.
He's saying attacking um the Israeli the Israelis operating the
IDF operating as a military force in illegally occupied areas
is okay. That's what he's saying. >> Justified in self-defense
in those
>> moral and legal. >> I mean uh which
>> is explicitly what he's saying just to be clear. >> That
is explicitly what he said. >> He is well no verbatim what
he said is all Palestinian resistance. >> Let's just listen
to how he talks about the terrorist groups. >> Yeah. Okay.
Okay, you just listen to the whole thing. Is this not going to
work? Hello, Mr. Twitch. Mr. Twitch, hello.
What are we doing here, Mr. Twitch? Oh, boy. Mr. Twitch is not
happy right now. >> Israeli settlers.
>> I'll back it up a little bit.
>> It doesn't necessarily mean it'll happen, but it shows
the thinking. >> Like any kind of violence that Israeli
settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences in the West Bank is literally
legal. Okay. It is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying force experiences
in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally legal and totally
moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't matter if they're
the Al Axa Brigade. Doesn't matter if they're a part of the Palestinian
Islamic Jihad. It doesn't matter if they're DFLP, PFLP, or even
former FATA militants. Okay. It is perfectly legal, perfectly
valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay. >> Okay. So, he's saying it's perfectly legal, valid,
moral to go back against those people. >> He's just wrong.
Wait, hold on. But he's not Hold on. Internet Ray, you could
say he's literally saying what's allowed. You can target the
militants operating these areas. He's not saying you can target
civilians and it's moral. That's not what he's saying. He's saying
a group that does target civilians, if they are fighting in defense
of the Palestinian people in these occupied areas, then that
is okay. There's no part in there where he goes, "Oh, I totally
love this group that civilians." He's never said that. >> Uh
but he did say the Israeli occup uh occupying force
uh which is a vague statement uh based on the context that he's
watching a documentary about. >> Wait, it's a vague state?
Hold on. It's a vague statement in what way? Uh because the Israeli
occupying force IO
uh is frequently used to refer to all of Israel
uh for any military action that they do. >> Are you Ty
be honest? You understand you just make things up totally in
like most debates, right? Like you are actually just like straight
up creative writing. >> No, the >> the F is just
a nickname for the IDF.
>> Just what they call the IDF.
>> Uh well, >> no. The IOF is just the IDF. >> It's
the Israeli occupation force. That's what they >> Israeli
offensive force or Israeli occupying force. Yes. >> Israeli
occupying force. Yeah. I'm not making this up. This is they refer
to this is the force that allows Israel to occupy all of Palestine
because that's that's the whole thing about the uh about all
of Hassan's Marxism and his you know lies about being a Sakim
versus a uh >> we just have to totally
>> um if he was calling the people the soldiers in this
video the whole time the IOF the IOF the IOF would that convince
you that he's referring to the IDF? I mean, he is referring to
the IDF, but like uh for instance,
>> there were soldiers on uh on October 7th, right? They
killed the soldiers in order to get some more civilians. It's
not clear to me
uh based on the way that he uses the term IF. It's not clear
to me that he's referring that he's not referring to those people.
>> I don't Man, I'm sorry. I You It is clear. You You could
go down to the settlers thing and I tried to give this as charity
to the first guy who called in today. Okay. Not Jer. Who's the
first guy who called in? A leader. I tried to give that as charity.
Okay. Um, so you could say on the settlers thing, but then why
is he not including with the settlers? Why is he not talking
about Ela being like a settler? >> Um, he's said multiple
times that he does not think. No, he's putting he's putting with
the Israeli occupying force, the IDF. And he's doing that because
she went on,
>> which is what she did as a part of the >> Yeah.
Okay. So, what was your point about the settlers? cuz that's
what he's talking about, right?
>> The point was maybe try to obiscate based on it being
a settler, right? >> Her being a settler, but we already
went down that whole line and like the whole settler thing. It's
just not uh >> it's not what anyone is uh it's not what
he means. So, he doesn't even believe that settlers are everybody
in Israel, right? There's no reason he would think Ela is a settler.
He's she's clearly a part of the active military, right? In the
example he uses, which is the raids.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't think that he believes that all
of Israel is settled Palestinian territory that is right to um
be attacked or reconquered. Uh although it's not clear that that
is not what he believes. I don't really know. >> That's
fine. It doesn't matter in this context. He is talking about
the occupied areas. He talks about the West Bank. He talks about
Gaza. We don't have even have to we don't have to contemplate
this, right? We don't have to contemplate it. It is actually
filtered down to by the speech he's saying, by what he is saying.
it is filtered down to. >> So th this all boils down to
Hassan is imprecise with his speech. Uh he is deliberately imprecise
with his speech and careless uh and leaves a lot up to interpretation.
Uh and so therefore when he invokes ILA in this uh argument about
it is right for Israeli forces to suffer any violence any type
of violent Palestinian resistance. >> He says it's legal.
Is that not >> He says it's legal. He says he says it's
>> He says it's moral.
>> Says it's legal as well. Legal and >> He says
it's legal, valid, and moral.
>> Yeah. So hold on. When when he says >> is it careless?
>> Why do you believe So you believe So you believe Hold
on. You believe that he is saying it was legal to attack
Klein? Uh,
I I believe what his intent was is to say that when Ela was 18
and in the IDF in 2005 in Ramla,
it would have been valid, moral, and legal for her to have experienced
any degree of Palestinian resistance, the likes of which are
demonstrated by these groups that he
>> Yeah. Wow. Why don't we just start there? Yes, exactly.
It's clearly what he said. >> Hold on. But I'm doing all
the heavy lifting here. I think that that's what his intent is.
But his intent is not clear because his words were very >> No,
his intent's very clear.
>> all we have to do No, sorry. The exact the precise implication
of his words rules out any current attack of any kind.
The exact exactly what his words say rules that out. >> it's
not it's not implied. It's not something you have to read in.
It is the only interpretation of his words rule Ela out. >> Then
why did he invoke Ela in that
>> To take a [__] at her and say that she's
the perfect example given her raid. >> Actually, hold on.
No, even even two
with Ethan Klein. So just two I'm going to I'm going to answer
this question so I don't have to answer for you again. So one
reason he did it was to with Ethan Ela Klein because they're
[__] with him. And the second reason he did it is
because it's a perfect example of the conduct that he's talking
about. >> Uh it's it's not a perfect example.
>> You already said that that is what he intended to do
was say that she was a valid target during that. Why would she
be a valid target during that if she's not a good example?
>> I did not say that that is what he intended to do. I
said that I think >> explicitly said verbatim. Okay, hold
on. >> I think that that is what his intent is, but I'm
doing all the heavy lifting. So hypothetically, so hypothetically,
Hassan's intent could be that, but honestly, I don't know. >> You
have to engage with this. Why do you think so many people
>> interpreted what he said as referring to Ethan Klein,
unamerican citizen, today? Do you think everybody is bad? >> But
um wait, wait, wait. That he's referring to her >> or that
he's calling for violence against her. The reason most people
think he's calling for direct violence against her is because
people explicitly maliciously lied about what he said. No, >> they
explicitly clipped him incredibly poorly to make it look like
he was directly calling for violence against >> I don't
I don't think the context
I mean what what clip are you talking about?
>> uh the the 30 second clip from Dan. >> Yeah. And
the uh I think maybe a clip was the same one on LSF.
Uh I don't think that those are dishonest. Those are the things
that he said. The context doesn't
really make it. Is it not stripped down so you don't even see
what he's watching? >> I mean, it >> Do you think
it's relevant that he's watching a documentary on the West Bank
and that he is talking the whole time about what would be valid
to do against the people in the documentary? I would say that's
critical context. >> No. No. Because the people in the
documentary are the settlers. They are not the IDF.
He's not talking about what's in the documentary. >> You're
just object. You didn't watch any of this. You're just objectively
wrong. You are just lying right now. You are creative writing.
You are making things up. I actually went back and watched it.
You are just creative writing right now. >> So you're saying
that >> why would you say why would you make a conclusive
statement like that? Yes. >> Why would you make a conclusive
statement like that that's inside the West Bank
already said >> who who do you think Wait, who do you think
Who do you think's doing the segregation inside the West Bank?
>> The segregation depends on what you mean by that. The
PA and Israel came to the area ABC. Is that what you're talking
>> I'm stop making this like difficult for us. We'll just
go back to the other clip. Where is this? Is it 55
54 53?
This is we're going 5 minutes backwards and this is the he's
watching
>> this is the IDF roll up and they >> number one
>> this lady's got her like >> no here no politic
here. >> Okay, so she drops this on the ground and this
guy walks over and he's like [__] your
and [__] your >> bro. They do this [__]
so much. It's like these things
are are >> are these these settlers, do you think? >> I
assume so. >> Marginal in comparison to like obviously
the the
>> death and destruction campaign in Gaza, but this is
a part of everyday existence for Pal. >> You know what
would be really up though? What would be really up is if these
people actually knew each other and they were [__]
around and she was actually just recycling her boxes and they're
actually helping her just break down her
>> in the occupied West Bank. These guys are one illegally
occupying
uh the West Bank for the record and they do this [__]
on a daily basis. You like there are a million videos like this
where they just like go into a storefront and just [__]
it up
>> illegally occupying this area. And he's he's pretty
I raid about these people. Let's see how the phones of every
single Palestinian there. They go through their social media
>> to look for things that they can find that they can
arrest them on like any sort of sympathy or any sort of like
>> That's IDF. That's IDF. Yes. These are images not dissimilar
to the Gestapo harassing random citizens and packing up people
in Germany.
>> He really hates these these IDF people. Dude, they are
[__] up her boxes. >> Yeah, there's no there
is to walk on [__] up her boxes. >> Even though
they are terrorists. >> This is Ebron. This is Ebron. >> They
are in direct violation of international law. And it is legal.
It is literally legal if every single Palestinian there took
up arms and started actively fighting against those terrorists,
the Israeli occupying force. That is literally legal and moral.
Okay.
>> Wow. It's almost like that's really important context.
That's very easily understood and digestible if you care at all
about being intellectually honest. >> All right. Is that
so? Uh yeah. So those are IDF soldiers. You said this is in
>> Yes. Area A. >> Uh Hbron is under
uh is area B. It has Israeli police. >> So, this isn't
even >> So, I thought it was I thought it was Hebron and
area A. They say in the documentary that it's area A. Hold on,
let's keep watching. >> No matter how no matter what all
of your previous social conditioning has taught you, understand.
>> That's possible. I believe they say area Aumentary regardless
of of uh the the state violence that they're doing here. >> It's
possible Hassan didn't know this >> What they're doing
is illegal. >> Hold on. Let's check it out. >> Racist.
Why use a racist voice to mock Israelis? I don't know. Cuz it's
funny. They're doing a genocide. Does it hurt your feelings?
>> Not a good look. Not a good look, Hassan. Imagine doing
a racist voice. That's up. I totally disavow that. That's disgusting.
That's gross. >> I agree with you, but I don't think legality
is the issue. No, I'm just explaining to people that like >> LeBron's
even more divided up. It's like
>> What is legal is obviously
>> I'll listen. I'll listen. Wait, it's
>> Oh, well, this is this is the I believe this is supposed
to be the area A part cuz they say so in the documentary. members
of the state, members of the [__] military, members
of the police force, and automatically we're conditioned to thinking
like, oh, what they're doing is a legal thing. Maybe it's racist,
but it's like still a legal occupation. Is not. It is completely
>> So, he keeps continuing to justify this, saying like
despite what these guys look like, they are valid military targets.
They are not in the right. They are illegally here. >> Illegally
like a police a member of the police force like being of racist
to a citizen. This is like even beyond that. That is abort. >> I
just want to say that I I listen to the documentary. I don't
make harsh claims. Tiska just rolled in and was like, "Habbran's
area B. This they're allowed to be there."
>> And now I find out it's area A and B both apparently.
>> Yes, it that was I'm sorry I had to mute stream because
I was hearing double so I was trying not to talk very much. I
couldn't couldn't hear myself think. But yeah, I mean it it I
don't know where this is. If they say that it's area A, uh then
okay, sure. But is is this who is this what Hassan is referring
to when he invokes Eline? Because it isn't. >> Yes. because
this is not what the scenario that she was involved in was the
night raids during the second inifat is not these uh I'm assuming
so this is settler violence I'm assuming in area A these are
uh like
fanatics that go out there he's literally talking about the
>> yeah so the the violent settlers are technically civilians
and they will do violence to Palestinians and then when >> he's
not talking about that in this >> call on the IDF to defend
them
>> I'm just watching the thing I'm just watching the that
actually happened here, right?
Can the IDF be called into area to defend Israelis? Is that like
a thing that's happening a lot? Isn't that Isn't that explicitly
what should be illegal? >> Isn't that explicitly what should
be illegal? It's like >> also think that's true, too.
>> I'm not entirely sure, but I think that does happen.
But that's what
>> we're in area a green screen. The visitors arrive in
small. >> Uh, I banned I banned Extreme Dad for a week
and then somebody named Fent Dreams showed up and went, "What
is this thing? And why is it not on Twitch where it belongs?"
Extreme Dad, you're not even convincing. I'm timing you over
for another week. Actually, I'll do five minutes cuz you got
a funny avatar. I'll do five minutes only. I'm pretty sure that's
extreme dad though. Fent dreams. That's got to be That's got
to be extreme. It's got to be extreme dad. It just has to be.
There's nobody else.
Yes, I know. Ela did a raid into Ramala. Raala is in area A.
I know that. >> Look at a tomb up the street. The Palestinian
city of Hebrron is in what is known as area A of the West Bank.
It means it's technically under the full control of that chatter
literally say why you don't love Israel? You are being
>> I'll just say kind of embarrassing for Hassan to be
the Israel expert, the Israel Palestine expert. And when they
say in the documentary that Haban's in area A that he doesn't
go, whoa, Habbran's in area A and B. He's doing his racist voice.
>> Racist voice to mock Israelis. I don't >> Hassan
doesn't know.
Hassan doesn't Hassan is deeply >> like a German that comes
in here and getting their feelings when I'm doing like like a
bad German accent. Is it a F >> Palestinian Authority?
>> But everyone here says the presence of Israeli soldiers
and settlers is designed to make a point to emphasize who's really
in charge. This is a journey around the West Bank and inevitably
it starts at the wall separating Israel from its Palestinian
neighbors. It is imposing and is in many ways a symbol of Israel's
desire to segregate the people who live on the other side from
them. When he says they could just attack these people, it would
be like totally legal. He's referring to the IDF. He's circling
the IDF. He's talking about the IDF with that lady in her boxes.
The wall was built over two decades ago to stop Palestinian terror
attacks inside Israel after a wave of violence. But there is
more than a wall. >> Have we asked this clip already or
is >> West and its people would make up the line share
of the Palestinian if one were to be recognized. >> 15
seconds 20 seconds away. It's on the west bank of the river.
I don't know if he actually says it gets his name from >> or
if he's on his
Palestinian state and the Israeli parliament just approved a
motion to annex the West Bank. >> It doesn't necessarily
mean it'll happen, but it shows the thinking >> like any
kind of violence that Israeli settlers or the the Israeli military
experienced in the West Bank is literally legal. Okay. >> It
is legal. >> So he's still referring to settlers and uh
the IDF in the West Bank. >> Resistance against an occupying
military force. cannot I cannot repeat this in >> totally
legal resistance against an occupying military force, right?
Military force. These are a military >> No, just like any
kind of violence, any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying
force experiences in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally
legal and totally moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't
matter if they're the Ala Brigade, doesn't matter if they're
part of the Palestinian Islamic Jihad, doesn't matter if they're
DFlP, PFP, or even former FAO militants. Okay? It is perfectly
legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral. Okay,
100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area. This
is black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and white
than this. Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging
in an aparttheid, which is a crime in of itself. Israel is doing
a genocide in Gaza and a partite in the West Bank. Two crimes
in of itself. And every every type of armed resistance against
both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force in the
West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite >> Oh,
hold on. I'm going to pull it back. type of armed resistance
against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force
in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters
like uh wife that participate in these raids, the violence that
the Palestinians
engage in. >> Okay. So, we could say pretty clearly he's
grouping her in with the IDF right here from the way he's speaking.
>> Okay. in an act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal. Definitionally legal. Okay. So it's
definitionally legal. Do you believe that there's any way to
interpret that as him? So is there any way that you could possibly
be implying here that you can attack Elleline right now? Are
you hearing me or are you >> I guess I I guess I I guess
I am swayed. Yeah, I'm thinking about it. I mean I guess I guess
that's relevant context.
um does change his meaning significantly. Um does it also so
what he what he is alleging here is that it is right to attack
the IOF the Israeli occupying forces um including
was a part of
it's right >> yeah but you're you're on the right track
I sorry I just would say morally okay like morally good I don't
know if he'd say it was right because also like he might be willing
to admit that like well if they attack those people they probably
all get killed right so it might not be the right play But like,
sorry, I just want to Yeah, but go ahead. You're you're on the
right. >> It might not be expeditiously
correct, but it would be morally good or
>> Yeah. morally justified, moral morally valid, morally.
>> Um
because what? >> Sorry, you >> because Israel is
engaging in an apartheid and a genocide. Uh the crime of crimes,
a genocide. And so he's alleging that Ela is a part of this genocide.
No.
>> Well, she would have been a part of the the system of
oppression, the genocide and apartheid, the system of oppression
when she was a part of the IDF. >> And so therefore, she
got away with being a part of the genocide. Similar to
>> soldier, he's actually explicitly saying that he's actually
explicitly said, hold on, we have to go to the other context.
>> He's explicitly he's explicitly called them genocide
propagandists. >> Okay. Well, he's calling her genocide
while he's doing the genocide propagandist. Hold on.
Oh, so what do you think what do you think Assan would say about
the that went to Argentina, SS soldiers that went to Argentina,
uh if they tried to, you know, in the 50s they immigrated to
America in those next >> He's explicitly said that he does
not believe that she is a valid target >> because you said
are valid military targets. Do you think your wife is a valid
military target? Do you think your wife is a terrorist? >> She's
not a Westbank settler. She's not a Westbank settler. >> But
she's in the West Bank. Bad empanada think she is bad empanada
think she's invalid your friends over at second thought think
they're she's a valid >> you think she's a valid military
target >> think she's a valid military target here >> do
you think she's a valid military >> I do not as a matter
of fact I don't
>> can we please move on to >> so you believe some
principles changed on his behalf since this debate so that sorry
that is all all I think I defeat there is the SS officer comment
okay he clearly doesn't think that >> sure He he it it
doesn't again it doesn't really matter what he thinks. It's what
he's uh what he's implying and what he's uh like >> I I
think we both agree that there is no possible way he could be
implying violence against her is okay in the modern day because
he said it's legal, right? How could how could somebody do legal
violence to her? >> Do you think uh do you think that he
would think that the um United Health CEO was a valid target?
>> Okay. before Luigi and Luigi Manion >> possibly.
Would he think he is a legal >> I don't think
uh uh moral uh valid and >> Not moral. Don't do valid or
moral. Just do legal. Legal is the one. It's all of them, but
legal is the one that actually filters this down.
It's the It's literally the IQ filter for us. Okay.
>> I don't think it I don't think it is. I think moral
is the one that's doing the heavy lifting there. >> Why?
Because to argue something is morally good, not just expeditious,
not just would result in good outcomes, not just deserved, but
morally good. Like vengeance is justified
reinforce
multiple times. Why does he reinforce legal multiple times? >> Uh
because he's trying to invoke uh international law incorrectly.
He doesn't know what he's talking about. But that is one of his
>> we've already agreed it doesn't matter if it's incorrect
for what he's thinking here, what he's trying to say. Uh I mean
that is but it's what he's arguing. He's arguing for the legal
principle that he doesn't understand. But we know what he's what
he is arguing. >> Totally doesn't matter in terms of what
he's saying. Right? I'm telling you that when he when he stresses
the legality of it, that is a location filter. That is a time
filter. That is a filter that removes Hila from the pool of people
that you could possibly attack in the modern day. It's why he
refers to her in the past. It's why it's it's literally explains
everything. >> So, I'm saying you can't say he's implying
anything. He is clearly not even remotely implying anything.
By the logical progression of his statements, Ela is filtered
out. Yes or no? >> Uh, yes. >> Okay. So, he can't
be implying it. He can't be doing it. There is there's only misinterpretations
of his speech that he has to deal with now, right? People misunderstanding
him. There's no implication. There's no intention. Is just being
him being misunderstood. We >> Yes. Yes. >> So now,
okay. So, don't say he's implying it again. We don't want to
go back to that. All right. So now it's possible that people
misunderstand this because he referenced Ela in a in a conversation
about military targets. Is it possible that people would have
>> Uh yes. It's always possible that people would misunderstand.
I don't think you should be responsible for people misunderstanding
your speech when you're very specific about your speech in a
way that filters them out. If it's not explicit or implicit,
I don't know that you should be held responsible for like, oh,
if some like schizophrenic goes off and and does something here,
right? Especially now, as soon as this was, but but hold on.
Especially now, people have said, "Well, I think you meant this."
And he goes, "No, I didn't. Obviously, I didn't. I've never said
that." >> So, he's corrected the next day as well. >> Uh,
I don't Is that What was his >> That he's never once advocated
she could possibly be a military target. Um, there we'll go back.
>> The clip listen right to resist.
>> They believe you said violence against HK right now.
Not when she's doing illegal raids is acceptable. You didn't
say this. The context is in the clip, but everyone is just going
along with it. There is no point where I have said violence against
someone who is not actively in combat is permissible.
>> Oh, yep. I wasn't aware of that clip. I haven't seen
that one yet. >> Well, that's today or something, right?
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay. So, >> he's clearing it
up after the fact, but he's So, it's not it's implicit. Only
people who misunderstand him could could possibly see this. and
he corrects it exactly as soon as it's pointed out. >> I
think he's done everything here to be like totally fine. And
I think it's crazy to pretend that he was like trying to get
eloqu
>> and which is what most people are doing. They're pretending
he was trying to get eloqu. It's what Ethan is doing. It's what
Dan is doing. It's what Asminold is doing. It's what Destiny
is doing. It's what Tech is doing. It's what Naku is doing. Right.
>> Yeah. Uh okay. Uh I'll I'll concede if that's So he
did issue a correction there. I wasn't aware of of a correction.
I thought he would just double down and uh
he issued a tweet that didn't really contradict what he was uh
that wasn't wasn't clearly him
>> Not a correction either. This is not a correction either.
He is making it clear what he said that he never said that. >> It's
not a correction. >> A clarification. That was the word
I was I should have said. Um >> maybe a clarification >> because
because people were misunderstanding him, right? >> Yes.
So So my Just one more thing. I
>> because people intentionally framed it to force that
misunderstanding to happen, right? Because of malicious framing
to force that misunderstanding. >> Well, I don't I don't
know if I fully buy that. I think that the context >> Why
not >> uh of what he was watching uh does clarify what
he's saying, but I don't think that it's malicious to just clip
what he said. Uh, I think and my argument the whole time has
been uh that
just like uh Lauren Southern was being hopeless and not giving
any solutions uh and letting you do all the heavy >> I
don't I do not believe you've actually I do not believe you played
this out. If you want to come back and make this argument, you
have not made this argument even at all. Like even remotely,
you're not even close to making this like stochastic terrorism.
You need way better examples for Hassan. You need way better
examples for even Lawrence Southern being responsible for >> No,
the reason the reason that everybody misinterprets him uh and
and what his intent was is that he was dangerously careless with
the things that he said. It's not just that he was clipped out
of >> I don't think so. He even specified that it wasn't
out of context. It's just not clear in his original statement
uh that he wasn't it why he was invoking El Klein at all. >> You
already agreed it is not explicit or implicit. How can you be
any more clear that it's not referencing El Klein
other than saying other than triple checking and going back and
saying but obviously I don't mean now so you need that you need
that even though it's not required that would be duplicate information.
You think he needed to do that duplicate information? Uh, I think
I think that it was dangerously careless to invoke her in that
argument at all.
Uh, I think we saw that he was like on his phone right before
he was making that argument. I imagine he was probably molding
about some tweet or something or like I mean he has been taking
a lot of heat this week. So probably that was what was on his
mind. First clip, just to be clear, the first clip where I've
seen this was O. Hassan explicitly says Ela Klein is a valid
military target live on Twitch. >> Any armed resistance,
doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcaster's wife. This dangerous
nepo baby larp makes Kenneth Copeland look genuine.
So the first thing, >> this is clearly narrative driving.
This is clearly lying explicitly to spread a narrative, right?
This is the first tweet. This goes to Asmin Gold. This goes to
uh Techone. They continue to propagate that lie. Asminold says
that Hassan needs to be reported to the FBI. Technone says he's
clearly calling out for like her death because she had forced
military conscription. He believes you should be allowed to go
kill her. Shocked that he said it was live. Asold said he's he's
saying that is legal to
that Hassan argues it's illegal to kill her in California,
>> Yeah, I can uh What was that that first O tweet again?
I wanted to >> Oh, it was posted in DG chat. Then I'm guessing
it goes to Ox Discord from some DGER. And then I'm guessing it
gets posted on Twitter by O. >> Yeah. Okay. >> The
night before this, Destiny was posting in DGG chat apparently.
So,
>> doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcaster's wife.
Yeah. I would say that's that's dishonest because he does um
like use ellipses to try to get to the general meaning of like
the clips that he posts. And that that is out of context.
Dishonest, I suppose. Actually, I don't suppose I will I will
concede that is dishonest. It's malicious. I think it's clearly
malicious. And I would say nobody did any checking on this to
see what was going on, right? It's just like clearly malicious.
It's very sad. >> I give you that one.
>> Yeah. Nobody did any checking. I don't think that it's
unreasonable seeing just the clip of the thing that he says to
infer that that might be what he's trying to say. Um, you have
to like we've done a lot of heavy lifting on his behalf here,
>> but you have to do a lot of heavy >> We haven't
We haven't We really really haven't done any heavy lifting at
all. All the heavy lifting I've made people do is listen to what
he said and engage with what he said >> instead of engaging
with their their ghost version of Hassan. That's all I've done.
That's not heavy lifting. It's just telling them to engage with
>> What is realistically being said here? I mean, realistically,
what is being said here is defense for atrocious groups, which
on its own is >> where is the defense for atrocious >> DLP,
DFLP. Um, >> why is he saying the names of those >> He
was saying the uh >> No, you already agreed with me that
Al Cuds is the military brigade of Ham.
>> Please don't reset on me. Please don't reset on me.
You're already You're already like flipping your switch back.
You're already flipping your switch back and it's up. >> What
he's saying? You understand the point? Wait, wait. What do you
think the goal of this statement is? That it doesn't matter who
does it. Even if it's the worst actors in Gaza, it's still legal
and morally justifiable. You think you think that's him defending
those people? You think that's him supporting those people when
he says they have the worst reputations when that is the entire
point that no matter how bad the Palestinian actor is, it's still
moral to defend Gaza or the West Bank from these people? >> You
think that's him defending those people? any any resistance,
even the resistance of these atrocious groups, which I would
I think it is reasonable to assume the methods of those atrocious
groups fall under that any type of resistance, which is a deplorable
statement on its own. >> He's talking he's talking No,
it's not. No, it's not. He's talking about legal resistance,
right? It would be legal. I don't think he's possibly saying
that any act by those groups would be legal. >> I think
that is what he said. Any act in the West Bank against the occupying
force, settlers or occupying force is
>> All violence is legal. All violence is
>> It depends. Cuz when he says it's legal, he he says
that it's legal. I can't imagine he would say like um like torturing
these people would be legal,
I mean, I think he'd sidestep sidestep that. Um
>> Like the the red hands protest
uh for the you know the red hands photo. I think that was in
Ramala where uh like two IDF soldiers during the second inifat
I think um and they got familiar with the red hands and [__]
like that.
>> that is resistance against the occupying force which
I'm assuming when he says is
>> So he's saying he's saying
he's saying >> he he literally
milary people of these things >> he but he's keeping it
to military members. The issue with the Ramala embassy killings,
the red hands photos that those people were not militants, >> Uh
is that
I don't know. So, you probably know more more about that than
I do. >> I think that's the whole point is they were like
officials. They weren't >> I thought they were IDF soldiers
and they took a wrong turn cuz they were doing a an arrest or
something. I could be wrong about that. I don't know.
>> that was >> I don't I thought I thought I thought
they'd like broken into that embassy, but maybe not.
>> uh that might I might not be thinking of the red hands
photo then
because there was a um there was an instance when I think it
was it was two IDF soldiers on a motorcycle. They had like asked
some Palestinians which >> they did they did lynch two
IDF soldiers. It is two IDF soldiers.
>> I think he would I think he would support that. I think
he would say that would be legal and morally justifiable.
>> Yeah. Okay. We agree. Yeah. I think that that is deplorable.
It's not Uh yeah, that would be but it's um again maybe that
could be an argument here. Any act of violence is on, right?
Maybe that could be an argument, but nobody's actually doing
that because of the lie.
>> Well, yeah, but we also know what his response would
be would be he would just sidestep it and he would talk about
doesn't really know the specifics. >> Who Let's not Let's
not throw the Let's not Let's not box of shadows. Who's saying
Hassan has good reactions to like um to violent actions from
from oppressed
groups? Nobody's saying that. Everybody knows he has really reactions
to that stuff, >> right? The point here is is he saying
Ela Klein is a valid military target. Answer no. >> Yeah.
Okay. You've changed my view on that. I will concede >> that.
Perfect. >> He is not saying that.
>> And it is not reasonable to infer that he is saying
that. >> Awesome. Sweet.
Okay. Uh, thank you for coming on. >> Do do you think do
you think that he
>> should be ought to be more careful with his wording?
Like was that a
>> So I don't know. I don't know. It depends on it depends
on how much uh Ela's been engaging and if she's like asked to
be left out of it, right? I feel like it would be reasonable
for Ela to come out and say like hey, you know, you guys you
guys go off. You guys fight in your own, okay? I'm not going
to do it. I think I think that's reasonable to say like I don't
want to be a part of this. I think I don't think that's the case,
but if she did, then that would be weird for Hassan to refer
to her. >> Uh I think she certainly has has done >> I
mean, I I think that it's >> I think there's some amount
of recklessness for Hassan mentioning her like this. I don't
think when uh what did Destiny make some Destiny made some joke?
I honestly unfortunately for a lot of people, most of my most
of my thoughts around political violence have to do with Destiny
clips. Okay, guy just calls for political violence all the time
or is accused of it all the time. It's unfortunately most of
my engagement with it. Okay. So, in the context where he said
it would be funny if Hassan went to the Houthies and then everybody
in the America could join the US Navy. I don't think that's a
call to violence. I don't think it's reasonable to call that
a call to violence. I thought Hassan was soy posting when he
called that a call to violence. Okay. But I would say that is
roughly I would say that's probably more of a call to violence
than what he did with Hila here. Uh anyway, sorry. I like desperately
have to go take a pit. So, I'm going to be right back. >> If
you want to hop off, that's fine. I'm going to pull in Kingler
and then maybe Carrier and then I'm going to end stream. Okay.
All right. >> Cool. All right. >> See you later.
Thanks for the talk.
>> Mean it'll happen.
>> But it shows the thinking >> like any kind of
violence that Israeli settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences in the West Bank is literally
legal. Okay? It is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying force experiences
in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally legal and totally
moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't matter if they're
the Al Axa Brigade. Doesn't matter if they're a part of the Palestinian
Islamic Jihad. Doesn't matter if they're DFlP, PFLP, or even
former Fat militants. Okay? It is perfectly legal, perfectly
valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay, 100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area.
This is black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and
white than
>> Israel's in the wrong. >> I'm back. I'm back.
Hello. I'm back. Do we get a raid? We got a raid from somebody.
I assume that was Queenman. I have no idea for sure, but I assume
it was Queen. Hello. Hello
viewers. We're doing debates with people who disagree on the
Hassan clip.
Kangler 92, you're on the stream. What's up, dude?
>> How's it going?
>> Pretty good. How are you? >> Uh, decent, decent,
decent. >> You ready to scream? >> Uh, debating Ty
could be exhausting >> Oh, okay. So, it was actually good
for me the timing. Um,
maybe we don't disagree. My my claim is uh Hassan's primary
reason for invoking Hila
uh was malicious
and uh it does affect his audience perception of them um more
specifically lowers their their opinion of her. >> Um okay.
So you think that this was new information for most of Hassan's
audience that she went on a night raid? >> no. Do you think
that I guess just tying her to like the events happening on screen
that lowers their opinion of her? >> Seems more reasonable.
well, I mean this is something that you've pointed out um to
to me in
>> um well to everybody in the audience as a tactic that
Destiny uses. You called it uh webbing
>> where Destiny will mention you in association with other
>> Yeah. You're describing the last thing I just said >> and
agreed with you that that could be a way of doing it. Okay. Sorry.
You could have just said yes, that one would have been.
>> Um, sure. >> Sorry. Um, okay. Was malicious and
it does affect his Okay. So, I'd say yes, it was malicious. Yes,
he did it to [__] with them. Um, I'd say probably
the malice isn't necessarily to denigrate her reputation. It's
just to like get a rise out of them, but I think that's also
coupled with the fact that it is a perfect like actual example
of somebody doing illegal operations in the West >> Um,
yeah. So, in association with I mean the context was really important
for you to to make sure that this wasn't a legal
um
justification that he was making, but ironically it it does add
to
the audience perception of her like they get he gets them all
riled up against these people doing this one thing and then he
throws in Hila's name and you know it could just inflate whatever
negative feelings that they had even more so. Would you agree
with that? Um, yeah, it could it could have some negative effect.
Sure. I mean, I think Ela's already tied to these people pretty
tightly. Not these people, the uh the IDF and the people occupying
the West Bank. Um, it's like he's redoing this for like the 80th
time, right? >> It is annoying. >> Sure. Okay.
>> yeah, it is annoying, but yeah. And I do maybe um you're
saving this for when you talk to Rei later on, but how does that
jive with his argument where um legally he uh he did make it
clear that you can't do that? But morally, it's putting her in
the in the same part of their brain as they hold these people
that he just showed on screen. >> Uh what somebody doing
those actions, right? The night raids.
>> Webbing them. webbing her with with
>> Yeah, but it's Sorry, the webbing thing is supposed
to be disingenuous. She was a part of the IDF. She did go on
the night raid.
>> But I mean, they don't know that, right? >> They
her a his audience. No, his audience knows that, obviously.
>> Okay. Well, how how does that what's your counter to
to that particular argument? I'm just curious. Or maybe you would
rather save it for when you talk to him later.
>> Um, sorry. Say that again. >> I'm probably not
talking to him tonight or tomorrow. I I was going to talk to
him, but I don't know if he's around and it's also late. I got
to go. >> It's probably late for him. Yeah. But the the
moral argument, how do you think you would contend with with
that in
>> The moral argument. Um I don't think that moral connection
is like really all that different in Hassan's audience's head.
I think they already see like that was the whole point of why
they fought, right, was people in his audience apparently have
been linking the animation of her as an IDF soldier gunning down
kids. >> Yeah. So like the basically your position is morally
it's it they've already hit rock bottom. They can't do any more
damage to her. >> Not like the soldier thing. Not really.
Yeah. Not really. >> Okay. I I mean I don't agree but um
we could talk about that another time. It seems like we mostly
agree on the other >> What do you think about his chat's
reaction to when she's mentioned >> in an apartheid which
is a crime in and of itself. Israel's doing a genocide in >> Um
about the the
thing and and all that stuff. Yeah. Okay. >> Yeah. Um,
they they think of her pretty they have a low opinion of her,
but I I just don't see >> I I just don't see it's not clear
to me that it's bottomed out. I don't I I can always imagine
them getting more angry with a with a person. I I can't I can't
visualize capping out on on distaste for >> But maybe that
I mean I haven't really thought about that in particular, so
I'm not prepared to defend that. >> Wonder if anybody actually
says that they could go after her. Well, um, one thing, uh, people,
uh, pointed out was, um, that Hassan will go into
emo I don't I've never been on Twitch, emote only mode as a way
to hide, um, some of the some of the more heinous things his
chat might might say. I didn't see that ever happening in these
heal clips, though. I don't know if you >> It doesn't look
like he did. No, just a bunch of people saying like terror wife
and stuff. So, >> yeah. So, we agree on the thing that
I came in prepared to defend and I'm I'm not we're treading into
territory. I'm not. So, I'll let you go. Thanks for having me
on. >> Okay. Yeah, no problem. See you. >> Bye. Okay.
Hold on. Apparently, uh Queen wants me to play a Chilipi clip.
I'm I'm saying it objectively here. Okay. I'm being I'm being
Listen, there's there's a puppet master who wants me to play
this. Okay. This puppet master is in my DMs and he sent me a
clip and he's like, "You should play this right now." I'm just
I'm just being honest with you guys. Okay, I'm just being honest
with you. Somebody's cabaling right now. This up. Is this Is
this worse than Hassan? >> You should be >> chat.
If I was Palestinian and I saw El Klein on the front lines,
what is what is what is this about to say? What is this guy about
to say? I was Palestinian saw Ela on the front
let it be a red bar reference. >> I wouldn't hesitate.
I wouldn't think twice. Oh my god.
They're going to see the perks I got.
I got quick draw and double tap. I got quick draw and double
tap. I got quick draw and double tap.
>> You should be Wait, this is this really that bad? This
is like clearly memeing. The unfortunate thing with this is it's
clearly memeing,
right? I don't think this is worse than Hassan. What do you guys
think? Is this worse than Hassan? Wait, sorry. It is probably
worse than Hassan, but they're both just like clear. Clearly
nothing. Sorry. It is probably worse than Hassan. I don't know
what I'm saying. >> Chat, if I was Palestinian and I saw
Ila Klein on the front lines, I wouldn't
I wouldn't think twice. Oh my god.
They're going to see the perks. I got
quick draw and double tap.
I got quick draw and double tap. Wow. No, he's saying he would
he's saying if he was a soldier and he saw Ela on the front lines,
he But he's not a soldier. It's only really good if you think
kind of think they mean it. Yeah. It's like he's clearly just
joking. He's clearly just like memeing to piss people off, you
know? It is what it is. All right, we had some fun with some
fun with some debates, guys. That was a good time. I figure we
get like some sincere person in here. I don't know if the I don't
know if that simile guy was serious. It seemed like not serious
at all. So, hard to know. I'm out. I love you guys. I'll be back
on Wednesday. Tomorrow night. Taking a night off. Okay. Night
off tomorrow. will not be back until Wednesday.
Have a good one, guys. We'll see you We'll see you then. Okay,
we'll see you then. Wednesday. Wednesday.